Scholastic Audio presents Wings of Fire
Book Five, The Brightest Night, by 2ET
Sutherland, read by Shannon McManus.
The Dragonette Prophecy.
When the war has lasted 20 years, the
dragonettes will come.
When the land is soaked in blood and
tears, the dragonettes will come.
Find the sea wing egg of deepest blue
wings of night shall come to you.
The largest egg in mountain high will
give to you the wings of sky.
For wings of earth, search through the
mud, for an egg the color of dragon
blood.
And hidden alone from the rival queens.
The sand wing egg awaits unseen.
Of 3 queens who blister and blaze and
burn.
Two shall die, and one shall learn, If
she bows to a fate that is stronger and
higher, She'll have the power of wings of
fire.
Five eggs to hatch on brightest night.
Five dragons born to end the fight.
Darkness will rise to bring the light.
The dragonettes are coming. 20 years
ago.
It is nearly impossible to steal from a
dragon, particularly a royal one with a
palace and guards and very high walls.
At least, that's what Queen Oasis kept
telling herself as she hurried along the
dark halls, breathing fire to light her
way, Nearly impossible, and decidedly
stupid.
And yet, she had this terrible feeling.
Something was wrong.
There was something scrabbling around in
her palace.
With her exceptionally sharp, sandwing
hearing.
She was sure she could hear squeaking
like faraway mice, and perhaps the
clinking of coins.
But mice didn't steal treasure.
So what was it?
Was she imagining it?
She'd woken from a deep sleep with a
start, as if someone had stabbed her in
the chest with his venomous tail.
It seemed unlikely, but she was going to
check on her treasure anyway.
The sand wing queen whirled around a
corner and collided with 2 of her
daughters, Blaze, and Blister.
Ow, Blaise complained, hopping backward
with a grimace.
Mother, you stepped on my foot.
Blister said nothing, but side stepped
into a corner to get out of the queen's
way.
Her dark eyes were fixed on every move
Oasis made, in that unsettling way she
had.
Oasis had had a feeling from the moment
blister hatched.
This was the daughter who was going to
kill her.
Her oldest daughter, Bern, was bigger and
stronger.
But Oasis and Bern actually got along in
a way.
They understood each other.
Apart from burns obsession with
mutilating animals, and it was easy to
distract burn.
Give her something creepy looking, and
she'd disappear into her rooms for days.
Blister, on the other talon, always
seemed to be calculating the moments
until her mother's demise, and she'd been
like that ever since she was a small
dragonette.
Ever since she'd 1st realized that
killing her mother would make her queen.
Go ahead and challenge me.
Oasis thought scornfully, glaring down at
blister.
I'd squash you like a bug and you know
it.
What's the hurry?
Blister asked smoothly, as if she
couldn't sense the malevolence in her
mother's gaze.
Is there a royal crisis?
Let me guess.
Smolder tried to run off with his
girlfriend again?
No, I took care of her, Oasis said.
I'm just going to check the treasury.
Ew, sparkly things.
Blaze yawned.
Good night, mother.
Dizzy Blaze.
Oasis thought, as she hurried on.
She'd be a terrible queen, but she's an
acceptable daughter.
I don't have to worry about what she'll
do to me.
She heard Claus click on the stone behind
her and whirled around.
Blister held up her talons and flared her
wings, filling the narrow passageway.
Sorry to startle you.
She said unconvincingly.
I just wondered if I could come with
you.
Oasis hesitated.
But she knew if she said no.
Blister would find a way to sneak along
anyway.
It was always better to keep her where
you could see her.
Fine, but don't touch anything.
I know what you want to see.
You conniving fiber.
It won't do you any good until I'm dead
though.
They whisked down the long passage that
led to the 4 treasure rooms.
Everything looked in order.
The torches flickered peacefully.
The doors were closed and locked.
But there was a strange smell.
Something hairy, and woodsy, and flowery
at the same time.
Something had definitely been here.
Oasis crouched to peer under the doors.
There was a large gap between the doors
and the floor, not large enough for a
dragon, of course, but do you smell
scavenger?
She asked blister.
I wouldn't know what those smell like
blister said, wrinkling her nose.
They're too bulky and squishy for my
taste.
Queen Oasis selected the right keys from
around her neck and unlocked all the
doors, then did a sweep through each room
leaving the doors open.
She came back out, glowering with rage.
That looks ominous, Blister remarked.
Scavengers, spat the queen.
Robbed me.
How dare they?
She lashed her tail, hissing.
They can't have gone far.
Wake up, burn and tell her to meet me
outside.
Burn?
Blister echoed, glancing over her
mother's shoulder at the treasure rooms.
Just in case there are a lot of them and
we need to fight.
Oasis said.
I've seen what their tiny swords can do.
I'm not such a fool as to go out there
alone.
Oh no, of course not, Blister said.
But why burn?
When I'm here.
Oasis gave her a withering look.
I need a real fighter, she said.
Not someone who thinks she can use her
brain to get herself out of anything and
isn't even as smart as she thinks she
is.
I see, Blister said coldly.
I'll wake her at once.
She took a step up the corridor, then
turned back.
What did they take?
Small things for the most part.
Oasis growled, but they also took the eye
of onyx.
That actually made blisters face twitch
as if a hint of a real emotion, worry
surprise, was trying to come through.
We'll get it back, Oasis promised, and
we'll have roasted scavenger for
breakfast.
She pushed past blister and stormed
toward the nearest route to the sky.
I'm going out there, wake burn, and
hurry.
Oh yes.
Right away, Blister said.
As Oasis charged into the courtyard
spread her wings and lifted into the sky
she thought for a moment that she saw a
blister turn to look back at the treasure
rooms instead.
I forgot to lock them up again.
Oasis thought uneasily.
But this will only take a minute.
And if she's stupid enough to take
anything.
I'll have a good excuse to kill her.
She's smarter than that.
She wheeled toward the outer walls
scanning the sands.
A disturbing thought occurred to her.
What if she doesn't wake burn?
What if I'm going to face the thieves
alone with no backup?
Then she spotted them.
Three scavengers, 2 of them waiting on
the sand, the other climbing down from a
window, none of them watching the sky.
Scab infested idiot monkeys.
Oasis growled, and folded her wings to
drop down silently behind them.
Maybe she could scare them to death.
Prey always tasted better when it died
like that.
Only 3 of them.
She thought.
I don't need to wait for burn, if
blisters even getting her.
I can certainly handle 3 annoying
scavengers by myself.
She narrowed her eyes, advancing up the
dunes toward the sound of squeaking, after
all.
What's the worst that could happen?
Part one, The Shifting Sands.
Chapter one.
Sunny had always known that she was the
right dragon for a big heroic destiny.
She was going to save the world.
She and her friends were going to swoop
in on wings of fire, whatever that meant
and bring peace to every dragon and
pyrea.
It was right there in the prophecy. 5
dragons born to end the fight.
That was her fate.
That was her purpose.
Besides, it explained everything.
Why else was she so small and weird
looking?
She wasn't a normal sandwing.
Her scales and eyes were the wrong color
and she had no venomous bar by the end of
her tail, but that didn't matter.
In fact, it made sense.
Of course, a dragon hero with an epic
noble quest would be a little different
from everyone else.
And who would care how strange she looked
once she stopped the war.
Then there were her parents, the
mysterious dragon who had left her egg
buried in the sand in the desert, alone
and unguarded.
It didn't matter that they obviously
didn't want her.
It didn't bother Sonny at all, because it
was part of the prophecy.
Hidden alone from the rival queens, the
sand wing egg awaits unseen.
That was all right.
Heroes and the scrolls often had no
parents.
Their heroic destiny was more important
than any family.
And her destiny was important.
There was nothing more important than
stopping the war between the dragon
tribes.
All her life, especially whenever she
felt trapped or sad or worried about
anything.
Sonny had imagined fulfilling the
prophecy.
How many lives they would save, and all
the happy reunited families, and all the
future dragonettes, who could grow up in
peace, without the constant fear of war.
That was the entire point of her life.
And it was a lie.
Rock walls scraped against her wings as
she scrambled away from the night wing
island.
She could feel the rumbles of the volcano
all the way through her claws.
Her friends were behind her, still facing
Morrow Seer, but she had to get away from
them, from him, from everything.
He made up the prophecy.
It was all a trick.
No, I don't believe it.
He's a vindictive, cruel dragon, who's
always manipulated us and everyone around
him.
He would say anything to hurt us.
The prophecy is real.
It has to be.
She burst out of the tunnel into the
rainforest, and immediately slammed into
the side of a skinny black dragon.
The night wind grunted with surprise and
glared at her.
So he tried to turn and fly the other way
but a floundering wall of black wings and
talons and tails drove her back.
In the moonlight, the entire rainforest
seemed to be seething with dragons, roars
and hisses and growls, drowned out the
sound of their raindrops pattering on the
leaves all around them.
It didn't help that half of the dragons
were dark as the shadows, and the other
half were camouflaged, so claws and
corners of wings seemed to suddenly poke
out of nowhere.
Sunny narrowly avoided a tail in her ear
when 2 night wings got caught in a
dangling vine, and whipped around
violently, as if they were being
attacked.
Everyone calmed down.
Glory's voice shouted.
Listen, bellowed grandeur, the old royal
rain wing.
Your new queen is speaking.
Several night wings muttered under their
breath.
But none loud enough to be heard, and
even they fell silent as others hissed at
them.
Sonny ducked and wriggled through the
crowd, but she couldn't get any farther
than the stream.
Several rain wings stood by the water, in
shades of blue and purple, holding night
wing spears.
Most of them were ruining the effect by
peering at the spears with mystified
expressions, or holding them upside
down.
Still, Sonny decided not to try pushing
past them.
Those spears would hurt just as much if
they poked her by accident as on
purpose.
What she really wanted to do was crash
away into the rainforest and not come
back.
She wasn't sure she could face her
friends, who acted as if they didn't care
about the prophecy at all.
And she couldn't even look the night
wings.
Tsunami wants to believe Marosir.
She's never wanted to fulfill the
prophecy.
She doesn't understand how important it
is.
Clay would be just as happy if nobody
ever noticed how wonderful he is.
Then he could sleep and eat and take care
of us instead of fighting.
Starflight would love to stop worrying
about the prophecy.
And glory has enough to do here, now that
she's queen.
None of them will fight for our destiny.
They certainly won't listen to me if I
try to explain that Morrow seer must have
been lying.
They'll give me that look I always get
the one that says, oh, silly little Sonny
and her crazy dreams.
Isn't she cute and harmless?
She gazed up at the mass of dark trees
overhead, where the moonbeams and
raindrops skittered in the wind, even if
she tried to run off, she'd probably get
her tail stuck in a tree branch and need
to be rescued, and then her friends would
get to roll their eyes and pat her on the
head again.
It wouldn't be like this in the desert
she thought.
She looked across the stream at the other
tunnel, the one that led to the kingdom
of sand.
There, I could fly and fly and fly all
the way to the horizon without ever
stopping to think.
Not thinking, sounded pretty appealing
right now.
You're just as ordinary as any other
dragon.
Morrisier's spiteful words kept going
around and around in her head.
I made up the whole prophecy.
Now the war will drag on endlessly, and
more dragons will die every day, probably
for generations, all of them wondering
what happened to the amazing dragonettes
who were supposed to save them.
But obviously failed.
Sonny clenched her talons and crouched
low to the ground.
He was lying.
She wouldn't let these night wings see
her cry.
Glory climbed onto a boulder and flapped
her wings loudly, even up there, and even
with her queenliest face on, Glory still
looked like a dragonette, smaller than
almost all the night wings surrounding
her.
If the prophecy is fake.
Then why was everyone so awful to glory
about not being in it?
Sonny thought, feeling another surge of
fury at Morrow Seer.
Why make her feel so useless if we're all
useless?
Because it is real.
It has to be.
But how can I prove it?
Night Wings, Glory said firmly, speaking
up to be heard over the shuffling dragons
and the rainstorm.
Your home is gone.
Your queen is dead, but this is your
chance to start over.
If you mess it up, you'll lose this home
too.
She pointed to the rain wings.
You will treat these dragons with respect
and in return, because that's the kind of
dragons they are, they will be much
kinder to you than you deserve.
The rain wing across the stream from
sunny, mustered an expression that looked
almost fierce.
Rain splattered across Sonny's snout and
wings.
The storm was picking up strength, ripping
through the treetops way over their
heads.
Tonight, you'll stay right here, Glory
went on.
I don't want any night wings wandering
off until we can count you and write you
all down.
You will each be assigned 2 rain wings to
keep an eye on you.
And yes, if you're feeling like perhaps
we don't trust you very much, it's
because we don't.
None of you are welcome in the rain wing
village until you earn that trust.
We will find you somewhere else to live.
We'll get wet out here.
One of the burlier night wings
complained.
Glory gave him a steely glare.
Feel free to go back and sleep on your
nice dry island instead, she snapped.
I hear it's quite warm there.
Sunny glanced around at the night wings.
Even in the moonlight, she could see that
most of them looked badly shaken and
subdued.
Seeing their home buried by the volcano
even if they knew it would happen
eventually, and even though the island
had been a terrible place to live, it
still must have been an awful shock.
Something like being told your whole life
is a lie, I imagine.
A roar suddenly erupted from the crowd
behind her.
Black dragons surged toward Sunny
flapping their wings in alarm, as 2 deep
red rain wings dove into their midst, and
dragged a yowling, petrified night wing
in front of Queen Glory.
This one, growled one of the rain wings.
He can't stay here.
He's the worst of all of them.
He's the one who did all the venom
experiments on us, said the other.
She lashed her tail and hissed at him.
Sonny had never seen any rain wings look
so angry before.
Besides glory.
She craned her neck to peer at the night
wing, and realized it was Starflight's
father, mastermind, the head scientist of
the night wing tribe.
From the look on glory's face, the queen
was probably guessing exactly who it was
too.
The night wings had been kidnapping rain
wings for the last year, imprisoning them
and doing experiments to understand their
venom shooting abilities.
They'd been planning to invade the
rainforest to steal it from the rain
wings, either by killing or enslaving all
the peaceful rainforest dragons who
already lived here.
Sunny had seen the lava riddled wasteland
of an island where the night wings
lived.
She knew they were desperate for a new
home, and at 1st, she thought Starflight
was brilliant for offering to let them
come through to the rainforest, as long
as they pledged their loyalty to Queen
Glory, along with a promise to behave
peacefully.
She liked the idea of dragons from
different tribes, learning to live
together.
She felt sorry for the sick and starving
black dragons, and she loved the poetic
justice of a rain wing becoming the new
queen of the night wings.
But looking at the muttering dragons
around her, the night wings who didn't
look as sorry as they should, and the
hissing rain wings, who were only
beginning to realize what their friends
had been through, Sonny wondered if this
had been a huge mistake.
Maybe they should have let the night
wings be swallowed up by the volcano.
Maybe it wasn't possible to forgive
them.
Maybe.
We shouldn't even try.
If they could lie about something as huge
and important as the prophecy and
stopping the war.
What else would they lie about?
How could glory ever trust them?
Ah, I'm sorry.
Mastermind croaked weekly.
It was, I was just, for science.
His voice sputtered out, and he cringed
away from the rain wings beside him.
Glory flared her wings, and several
colors rippled quickly through her
scales.
Tie him up.
We'll figure out what to look out.
A dragon by the tunnel roared.
Stand clear.
Fate speaker shot out of the hole, and a
moment later, tsunami hurtled after her.
Everyone, get down.
The Sea Wing yelled.
The night wings by the tunnel all threw
themselves to the ground.
A blast of scorching heat crackled out of
the hole, turning the raindrops around it
to hissing steam.
Sunny was one of the few still standing
looking at the tunnel, when 2 more
dragons burst out of it.
It was clay, with his wings shielding
Starflight.
Starflight's front talons recovering his
eyes, and long burns were blistering
along his scales.
As soon as they reached the open air, he
collapsed to the ground.
Stay back!
tsunami shouted ferociously at the
dragons who were flapping around them.
Starflight, Sonny cried, feeling a stab
of guilt.
He's hurt.
I never should have left my friends with
Maro seer.
She jumped forward, trying to squeeze
through the crowd of frantic dragons to
get to him.
But suddenly, talons wrapped around her
snout and shoulders, and she was yanked
backward into the dark trees.
Chapter 2.
Sonny thrashed furiously against the huge
wings that wrapped around her.
Quick, while they're all distracted.
She heard a voice hiss.
A shower of raindrops pattered down on
Sonny's head, as the dragon holding her
ducked through the leaves.
It was hard to see much more than black
scales, but Sunny realized she was being
dragged into the forest, away from the
tunnels and a crowd of dragons.
But I have to make sure Starflight is all
right.
She clawed the arm that pinned her wings
down, but the night wing only grunted and
held her tighter.
Wet leaves squelched and slithered under
their talons.
From the sounds around her, Sonny guessed
there were 3 night wings, including her
attacker, sneaking away from the scene
while everyone was focused on starflight
and clay.
That's ominous.
Maybe she should try to find out what
they were up to.
She stopped struggling and listened.
The dragons were moving fast and quietly
even without flying.
In just a few heartbeats, Sonny couldn't
hear what glory and tsunami were shouting
anymore.
They also moved purposefully, as if they
knew the forest well.
A hunting party, Sonny thought with a
shiver.
These are probably some of the dragons
who came through the tunnel to kidnap
rain wings.
What do they want with me?
Here.
One of the dragons said after a while, and
they all stopped.
Even with Sonny's sharp hearing, the
dragons roaring behind them sounded like
distant thunder muttering on the horizon
rain poured down harder and harder, and
the ever present insect noises of the
rainforest had gone into hiding.
Sunny was dumped onto the ground, mud
squishing between her claws and
splattering her tail.
She sprang up and hissed at the dragon
who'd been carrying her.
He barely glanced down at her before
turning to the other two.
Now what?
He demanded.
The whole plan is ruined.
I'm not staying here to kowtow to a rain
wing dragonet.
Me neither, said one of the others, a
female, who was little more than a
dragonette herself.
Then he guessed she was about 9 years
old.
She was bedraggled, wet, bony, and
hunched over, and yet when she snorted a
burst of flame, Sonny could see her eyes
gleaming with stubborn ferocity.
Plus, they'll probably kill me, said the
big dragon.
You saw how they were about mastermind.
If they remember that I was his
assistant.
I mean, I was the one who locked them up
or stuck them to the walls for him.
They'll be after my blood if we stick
around here.
Where are we supposed to go?
hissed the last dragon, another male, much
less brawny than the one who'd been
carrying sunny.
He had a few missing teeth, and his tail
was bent to the end, as if it had once
been broken and then fixed incorrectly.
We were promised the rainforest.
This is where I want to live.
But not as 2nd class dragons.
Imagine, rain wings telling us what to
do.
Well, we've got her, like you suggested.
The big male said to the dragonette
flipping one wing towards Sonny.
So, what do we do with her?
The Nightwing Dragonette lashed her tail
and narrowed her eyes at Sonny.
We use her as a bargaining chip.
We can hold her hostage until they take
our whole tribe to the rain wing village
and make one of us queen.
Like who?
said the other male.
He spat a small flame with a branch that
was dripping on his head.
Greatness is weak and won't fight for
it.
Queen Battle winner had no brothers or
sisters, and no other daughters.
There's no one else to claim the throne.
I'll take it, said the dragonette.
That'd be even better than being in a
prophecy.
If that rain wing can be queen, why not
me?
I'm bigger than her.
True, growled the big one behind Sonny.
Well, I have bad news.
Sonny spoke up.
They won't give you anything in exchange
for me.
I'm nobody.
Just a weird looking sandwing with a
useless tail.
She snapped her mouth shut before her
voice could start wavering.
She'd been saying things like that her
whole life, but she'd never felt awful
about it until today.
If there were no prophecy, then that
meant she really was just weird looking
and useless.
No, that's not how it works.
I'm weird looking because I have a
destiny.
There's a reason I'm like this.
There has to be.
The Nightwings regarded her with
skeptical expressions.
That would be annoying, said the big
one.
I'd be pretty angry if I carry this
little thing through the forest and got
my scale scratched up for no reason.
Fierce teeth.
I thought you said she'd be worth
something.
Fierce teeth.
Sonny remembered what Starflight had told
them about the dragonettes in the
Nightwing Kingdom wasn't fierce teeth, his
half sister.
We can use her if she's who I think she
is, said Fierce Teeth.
She jabbed Sonny painfully in the ribs.
Aren't you sunny?
Starflight yapped on and on about his
sonny whenever he was asleep.
Sonny blinked at her, too startled to
answer.
Yeah.
This is her, fierce teeth said, answering
her own question.
My brother's totally in love with her.
He'll agree to anything to get her back.
That might actually be true.
Sonny thought with alarm.
Does he really talk about me in his
sleep?
Only a few hours had passed, since she'd
stood in the rainforest clearing, in the
middle of dragons preparing to invade the
Nightwing Island, and Starflight had told
her he loved her, that he'd always loved
her.
She still didn't know how she felt about
that.
She didn't know what this feeling was.
The strange ripples of surprise every
time she remembered his expression.
It was, I don't know what to do, and
somebody loves me.
And don't hurt him.
And really, right now?
And imagine how happy you could make him
and why me?
Really?
Me?
And But it's Starflight.
Her sweet, smart, anxious friend.
She'd never thought of him like that.
Not once.
It was still hard for her to believe that
he meant it.
None of the other dragonettes took her
seriously.
She'd always assumed he was the same way
that he thought she was too little and
cheerful to be worth listening to.
Focus.
Don't let them use you to hurt your
friends.
Didn't you see Starflight's injuries?
She said.
He's too wounded to have any say in what
happens next?
And glory couldn't care less about me?
Face it, you can't use me.
You should go back and rejoin the other
night wings.
Nice try.
Fierce teeth said.
What if she's right?
said the night wing with the missing
teeth.
What if they don't want her?
What if we expose ourselves, and then
they just kill us?
Strong wings won't let them do that.
Fierce teeth said, stepping closer to the
burly dragon.
They're a couple, Sonny realized.
A really strange couple.
Strong Wings was nearly twice the size of
fierce teeth, but he kept turning toward
her, and ducking his head, as though he
was waiting for her to order him around.
I know how we could find out, said the
other male.
He drew something flat and shiny and oval
shaped from under his wing.
In the moonlight, it shone like polished
black glass, and fit neatly between his
front talons, and it stayed perfectly
dry.
The raindrops seemed to swerve to avoid
raining on it.
The obsidian mirror, said strong wings
with a hiss of admiration.
Nice work, prey hunter.
I wondered if someone would think to save
it.
He leaned in and touched the smooth
surface with one claw.
No surprise that it wasn't greatness.
She was more worried about saving her own
scales.
She never used it anyway, snorted Prey
Hunter.
Even when we needed to know what the rain
wings were up to.
She said she didn't trust anything that
was enchanted by an animus.
Coward.
I don't think the queen knew she wasn't
checking it.
It doesn't work as well as it used to
Strongwing said.
Everyone thinks Stone Mover did something
to it before he disappeared.
What is it?
Fierce teeth asked.
A really old animus touched piece of
treasure.
Strong wings explained.
This was one of the most important things
we had to save from the treasure room
when the volcano erupted, and buried that
part of the fortress, back when I was a
small dragonette.
We use it for he stopped and glanced at
Sonny.
Hmm.
Don't worry, we'll kill her before she
can tell anyone anything important, said
Pray Hunter.
Go ahead and try, Sonny thought
fiercely.
No one else has managed it yet.
He tilted the mirror so it caught the
light of the 2 moons glowing through the
clouds above them.
The 3rd moon was just a thin crescent
barely cresting the tops of the trees.
The rain had slowed to a misty drizzle.
Show me how it works.
Fierce teeth demanded.
She snapped a branch off the nearest tree
and set the end on fire, leaves crackling
wetly in the flames.
We just need a name, said Strong Wings.
Ah, someone important.
That rain wing queen, obviously, fierce
teeth snapped.
He looked blank, and she hissed at him
glory.
Glory, whispered the dragon holding the
obsidian mirror.
He breathed a plume of smoke across the
dark glass.
The smoke coiled and twisted, winding
like a thin snake around the outer rim of
the mirror for a few heartbeats.
All at once, the smoke vanished as if it
had been sucked into the mirror, and a
moment later, one tendril curled up from
the center of the glass, white, tinted
with purple, curving like a dragon's
neck.
Mangrove!
The tendril barked abruptly in Glory's
voice.
Make sure none of them have any more of
those spears.
Jambu, you and Grandeur start counting
them, the night wings, just to be clear
not the spears.
Fierce teeth grinned, her teeth gleaming
whitely in the moonlight.
This is happening right now, she
whispered, and strong wings nodded.
Brilliant.
Yes.
I can see how that would be a useful
trick, Sonny thought bitterly, especially
for convincing other dragons that you
have mystical mind reading abilities.
A pinkish wisp of smoke curled up on the
mirror next to the 1st one.
You bet.
No problem, Your Majesty, it said, except
uh, so counting.
Um, don't get me wrong.
I'm really good at it up to like 20?
That's a pretty big number, right?
There probably aren't more night wings
here than that.
Jambu, there are at least 200 night wings
here.
Glory snapped.
Hum, he said.
That's like 220s?
Maybe three?
I cannot even roll my eyes at you right
now.
Glory said.
Find me a rain wing who can count.
I'll do it.
A darker coil of smoke appeared, right
next to the first.
It took Sonny a moment to recognize the
voice of Deathbringer, the assassin who
had been ordered to kill glory, but
instead helped her escape the night
wings.
Funny.
Glory said, tell me another.
I love jokes about trusting night wings.
You exasperating creature, Deathbringer
said.
Haven't I not killed you multiple times
already?
I knew it, snarled Prey Hunter, curling
his claws around the mirror.
I knew vengeance was right about him.
Death bringer is a traitor.
We'll take care of him when the
rainforest is ours, hissed Strongwings.
Fine, Glory's voice said.
Go count Nightwings.
I'll have Starflight check your numbers
when he wakes up.
A ringing vote of confidence.
Death bringer answered, sounding amused.
The dark wisp of smoke coiled back into
the mirror, as did the pinkish one.
Glory's tendril of smoke twisted for a
moment, alone on the glass.
He will wake up.
Right?
She finally said quietly.
I think so.
A new spiral of mud colored smoke wound
its way up from the mirror, and Sonny
felt her heart jump hopefully at the
sound of Clay's voice.
He always made her feel better, even from
the other side of the rainforest.
But he was burned pretty badly.
We should use the darts, to make him keep
sleeping until he's healed as much as
possible, I think.
It'll hurt a lot when he wakes up.
Oh, poor Starfight.
Sonny curled her tail around her talons.
And his eyes?
Glory asked.
Will they be all right?
I don't know, Clay said.
All right, I did a perimeter sweep.
Tsunami's voice said bossily, as a blue
twist of smoke appeared on the mirror.
I made sure any gaps were filled with
rain wings, holding spears and blow guns
and I added a few more guards on the
tunnels.
I don't think they look very scary, but
hopefully the night wings will.
The blue smoke whisked around the other 2
tendrils, as if tsunami was circling them
to land.
That's why I need you to here.
Glory said.
The healers who took Starflight back to
the village can look after him until we
get there.
But for corralling night wings.
You're the most intimidating dragons I
have.
Waha!
Clay said.
That's me.
Intimidating roar.
Well, you are until you do that, tsunami
said.
Hey, at least you're not bright pink
Glory said.
That's extremely helpful right now.
It's all right, Clay said.
Sonny's probably at the village already.
She'll look after Starflight, no matter
how upset she is.
Sunny winced, and fierce teeth gave her a
sharp look.
Why is she upset?
Glory asked.
That slime lizard, Marosier?
Tsunami answered.
He told us that the prophecy is fake.
He made it all up as part of the plan for
the night wings to take over the
rainforest.
There was a long pause.
The 3 dragons around the mirror all
glanced at Sonny.
She stared down at her claws.
What?
Glory exploded.
Her curl of smoke shot up to twice its
previous size.
Yeah, Clay said, isn't that crazy?
I guess that's why Marosier wanted us to
choose blister as the next queen.
He had this whole I am going to bite thy
dragon's head off and stuff him in a
volcano.
Glory roared.
Too late, tsunami said. since that's kind
of already happened.
The volcano part, I mean, he's a pile of
ashes now.
Are you serious?
Glory demanded, talking over her.
The whole thing was made up.
There's no destiny.
No wings of fire?
No reason for us to be trapped in a cave
our whole lives, no amazing mythical sky
wing is infinitely better than me.
Absolutely no need for any of us after
all.
Hey, I'm mad too, tsunami said, but let's
go back and kill him again.
At least we don't have to worry about it
anymore, Tsunami pointed out.
No destiny means we can do whatever we
want.
The talons of peace can go shove a puffer
fish up their noses.
But Sonny was really upset.
Clay said.
She was always kind of excited about the
prophecy.
Kind of excited?
Sonny lashed her tail.
It wasn't just some fun adventure I was
looking forward to, Clay.
Oh, Sunny will be fine. said tsunami.
You know her?
She's always happy about everything.
By tomorrow, she'll be smiling again.
And by next week, she probably won't even
remember the prophecy.
She just needs something new to care
about, like making Starflight better.
Well, I can think of lots of ways to keep
her busy, Glory said, for one, she can
find me someone to yell at, I seriously
cannot believe this.
If I didn't have to act like a queen
right now...
Her voice trailed off into muffled
growling.
Sonny glared at the obsidian mirror.
This was exactly what she hated most
about the way her friends saw her
although hearing them say it so bluntly
made it much worse, as if acting happy
means I don't really care about anything
as if I just need to be distracted, and
I'll forget about the whole point of our
existence, and all the dragon to are
counting on us, as if my brain were the
size of a blueberry, 3 moons.
She caught fierce teeth looking at her
with a wry smirk.
Not too impressed with your intelligence
are they?
Said the night wing.
Sonny scowled back at her.
It sounds like they like her, said strong
wings dubiously, but not like they think
she's particularly useful or important.
I'm not sure they will give us the
rainforest in exchange for her.
I'm not either.
Sonny thought.
Not that they should, but what would they
do to get me back?
Anything?
Or will they figure, hey, she'll be fine
as a hostage.
Remember?
She's always happy about everything, and
that should be pretty distracting for
her.
Perfect.
Perhaps I'll just rescue myself then.
That'll show them.
And then I'll fulfill the prophecy all by
myself too, and then they'll see that it
was real all along.
She knew that was exactly the kind of
thing her friends would roll their eyes
at her for saying.
But if no one else cared about their
destiny anymore.
If she was the only dragonette who still
believed in it, what was she supposed to
do?
The night wing holding the mirror tilted
the glass, so the smoke tendrils swirled
together, and then he shot a small burst
of fire across the surface.
The smoke vanished, and the black glass
went still.
There is another option, Pray Hunter said
regarding the others with a sly
expression, someone else, who definitely
does want this stunted sandwing.
Pretty badly, I'd guess.
Fierce teeth inhaled sharply.
You're right.
Three some ones.
We could sell her to the highest bidder.
Whoever's willing to raise an army and
take back the rainforest for us.
Uh-oh.
Sunny was not about to be handed over to
one of the sand wing queens.
She'd spent enough time in cages and
prisons already, thanks very much.
She snuck a look at the leaning trees and
tangled vines around them, searching for
the closest gaps in the foliage.
Start with blister.
Strongwing said, his dark eyes glinting
in the moonlight.
She always pays her informants well, and
she needs us the most.
What does she pay them with?
Sonny wondered.
All the sandwing royal treasure was
stolen by the scavenger who killed Queen
Oasis, wasn't it?
And if there's any left, it would be in
the sand wing stronghold, which burn
controls.
But burn, would love to have this
weirdling in her collection, argued Prey
Hunter.
From what I hear, a deformed dragonette
would fit right in with the 2 headed
creatures and stuffed scavengers.
I am not deformed, Sonny said hotly, but
none of them paid any attention to her.
Queen Scarlet had been planning to hand
Sonny over to burn for this ominous
collection as well.
Sonny was quite sure she never wanted to
see what else Bern had collected.
Who has the strongest army?
Pierced he asked.
Burn, right?
And it would only take us a few days to
get to her.
If we fly straight over the mountains and
don't stop.
She flicked strong wings in the snout as
he opened it to speak.
Don't ask stupid questions.
We can't use the tunnel to the kingdom of
sand.
That'll be guarding...
Fierce teeth's howl of pain, send
raindrops flying off the leaves around
them as Sonny sank her teeth into the
vulnerable spot on her tail.
Strong wings, lunged to grab Sonny, pried
her jaws loose and threw her aside.
Fierce teeth!
he cried, bending over the night wing
dragonhead.
Are you all right?
Behind him, Sonny hit the ground rolling
sprang up with her wings spread and shot
into the trees.
Don't let her get away.
Fierce teeth shrieked.
Strong wings, catch her.
Kill her if you have to.
Chapter 3.
Dangling wet vines smacked against
Sonny's snout as she flew up into the
treetops.
She remembered what she'd learned from
the rain wings about rainforest flying
and kept her wings tucked close.
She couldn't use her tail to swing from
the trees like they did, but she was
small enough to maneuver through narrow
gaps and swerve quickly.
But the 3 night wings were right behind
her, roaring angrily.
I should lead them back to the tunnels
and the others.
Glory needs to know that they're not
loyal.
She needs to lock them up and keep an eye
on them.
For how long?
Sonny wondered.
Forever?
They'll never be trustworthy.
They'll always be plotting to overthrow
her.
What do you do with dragons like that?
One of her wings hit a branch as she flew
past, and a family of monkeys went
leaping off into the trees, howling and
chattering with alarm.
She twisted to glance back, and saw a
bolt of fire engulf one of the monkeys as
the night wings attacked them, thinking
it was her.
They won't be foolish enough to follow me
all the way back, Sonny realized.
Even if I can't keep ahead of them for
that long, they won't let themselves be
caught.
What will they do instead?
She narrowly missed knocking herself out
with a giant tree branch, ducking to
avoid it at the last second.
The same plan, just without me.
They'll go to burn and tell her we're in
the rainforest, where her army can find
us easily.
I need to hide.
I need to think.
She curled into a ball and threw herself
into one of the dragon fruit trees, where
the leaves were huge and overlapped one
another like scales.
Her momentum nearly carried her out the
other side, but she was able to fling her
talons out and hook onto the trunk
slamming her body into it.
She froze in place, clinging to the rough
bark, hoping the night wings had lost
sight of her in the dark.
By all the moon's strong wings, fierce
teeth swore from somewhere to Sonny's
left.
How could you let her escape?
Sorry, his voice mumbled.
She's gone, said Pray Hunter.
We'll never find her now.
Not without running the risk of a rain
wing spotting us.
Let's get out of here, said Strongwings
before she brings back reinforcements.
Talents and tales, fierce teeth hissed.
We needed her.
We still have useful information for the
next Sandwing queen, said Preyhunter.
They all want to know where the
dragonettes are.
If we hurry, we'll be the only one
selling that information, and we don't
need the sand wing as proof.
We're night wings.
Everyone believes us.
Makes sense.
Let's go.
Strong Wing said.
And with a flurry of wing beats.
The dragon's headed for the dark open sky
above the trees.
Sonny's claws were trembling with the
effort to stay still.
She took a deep breath.
If I go back until the others, we can
follow them.
But by the time they listen to me, if
they listen to me at all, the night wings
will be long gone.
Sonny was used to the way her friends
talked over her all the time.
If she really wanted to be heard.
She usually had to get Clay's attention
and have him make her suggestions for her
which wasn't fair.
She had good ideas, but her friends never
expected her to have anything useful to
say.
They also didn't trust her to keep
secrets.
They hadn't even told her about it when
they were all planning to escape their
guardians.
All they wanted was for her to be
cheerful and supportive, and agree with
everything they wanted to do.
Would Glory even listen?
If Sonny tried to tell her about the
rogue night wings, wouldn't she be too
busy?
What if she just rolled her eyes at Sonny
the way she often did?
I don't want to be distracted from
worrying about the prophecy, Sonny
muttered, I want to do something.
Like stopping the night wings.
I could follow them right now.
I might be the only dragon who can stop
them before they tell Bern where we are.
Maybe if I do.
My friends will see that I can do
important things.
And then maybe they'll listen to me about
the prophecy.
She thought guiltily of Starflight, and
what he would think when he finally woke
up and realized she wasn't there, taking
care of him.
Then she thought of what her friends had
said about her in the obsidian mirror, and
she thought about Maru Sears' smug, evil
face, and she thought of all the dragons
in Pyrea, waiting for the dragonettes of
destiny to save them.
I'm doing this.
Even if I have to fulfill the prophecy
alone, I will.
Sonny clambered up through the branches
and lifted off.
Following the black dragons into the
night sky.
It was easier to follow the night wings
than Sonny would have expected.
Her sharp eyes could catch the movement
of their small silver underwing scales
flashing against the sky, and they
weren't making much effort to be quiet
either.
Or maybe loud and flappy was how night
wings always flew.
They also were slower than Sonny, and got
tired more quickly.
So she had to be careful not to pass them
accidentally, especially during their
frequent rest stops.
The sun was rising behind them when they
reached the far edge of the rainforest
where the jungles shifted into sparser
forest and more marshes, the outskirts of
mudwing territory.
The claws of the Clouds Mountains stood
out sharply up ahead in the growing light
like a line of jagged, broken teeth.
Most of the mountains in the southern
part of the range were not as tall as the
ones in the north, where the Sky Wings
lived.
But there was one exception, Jade
Mountain.
The tallest mountain on the continent was
easy to spot, and not just for its
towering size.
Sonny remembered the picture on the map
of Pyria they'd had underground.
In reality, the 2 crags at the top looked
even more like sharp fangs sticking up
into the air.
One of the scrolls had said that from
certain approaches, the tip of the
mountain looked exactly like the head of
a snake, lunging out of the ground to
attack the clouds.
Jade Mountain.
Sonny frowned.
Someone had said something recently about
Jade Mountain, something she needed to
remember.
What was it?
Nothing came to her, as the sun slowly
lit up the mountain's fangs.
Sunny had been worrying all night about
how she would hide from the night wings
in the daylight.
They didn't seem to be watching behind
them, but it would be hard to miss her
golden scales once the sun was reflecting
off them.
She wished she had glorious camouflage
scales.
Really?
Any of her friend's skills would be
helpful, instead of her own total lack of
powers.
But as the sky grew pinker and brighter
and then started shading from gray to
blue, the 3 night wings flew lower, their
wings drooping, until finally they landed
beside a small river.
Sunny kept her distance, choosing the
tallest tree she could find and tucking
herself among the branches, close to the
trunk.
She fixed her eyes on where the night
wings had gone down and pricked her
ears.
She could hear their distant muttering
with fierce teeth the most distinct.
It sounded as if they were planning to
sleep for as much of the day as they
could, and then fly on at dusk.
They've been breathing volcanic ash, and
living on dying rotting scraps, probably
for their whole lives, Sonny thought.
No wonder they're not exactly in great
shape.
After a while, the trees stopped rustling
and the dragon voices fell silent.
A few minutes later, one of them, sunny
guest, strong wings, started snoring like
a herd of congested hippos.
Now what do I do?
Sonny wondered.
This was a perfect opportunity to wreck
their plans if she could figure out how.
Could I fly to the rain wing village and
get back with reinforcements before they
wake up?
No, it would take me all day just to get
someone to pay attention to me.
I can do this myself.
I have to.
What would tsunami do?
Would she go down there and kill them?
I don't think I could do that, even if I
could do that.
Sunny sighed.
A breeze whispered through the trees
curling under her wings as if inviting
her to fly.
Yesterday, I wouldn't have worried about
what was going to happen next with fierce
teeth and the others.
I'd be able to follow them, knowing for
sure that whatever I did would turn out
all right.
She hated Marosia for making her feel
this way.
This awful, doubting feeling.
He'd planted this worry, which she'd
never had before, that maybe things
wouldn't be all right, that in fact, she
could die.
And the war might go on endlessly, and
perhaps there wasn't a happy ending all
planned out by the universe.
She had to stop thinking about Marosir
and the prophecy.
It was like stabbing icicle sharp claws
between her scales.
Every time she pictured the haughty black
dragon, sneering about his great lies.
Stupid night wings, and their deceitful
all knowing, high and mighty, Sonny sat
up so fast, she nearly fell off her tree
branch, all knowing.
There was one thing she could do to slow
the night wings down.
She could steal the obsidian mirror.
Chapter 4.
This was one of those ideas that Sonny's
friends would totally ignore if she
suggested it, but would love like crazy
if it came from clay or tsunami.
It was also something they would never
ever let her do herself. too dangerous
too risky.
Send a dragon with fighting skills or
camouflage scales.
Not their undersized, cheerful, silly
little sister.
Well, I'm the only one here.
And I know I can do it.
She waited until the sun was halfway up
the sky, and then she carefully worked
her way closer, hopping from tree to tree
and giving herself as much cover as she
could.
There were a few spots where she was
exposed, and her golden scales caught the
light, but when she finally came to rest
on a branch within sight of the night
wings, all 3 of them were sleeping
soundly.
Starflight said, there were never any
night wing guards posted in their
fortress.
They're used to being so isolated that no
one could find them to attack them.
It didn't even occur to them to leave
someone awake to keep watch.
She snorted.
They probably also figured no one would
dare attack a group of amazing all
powerful night wings.
Fierce teeth was curled in the curve of
strong wings underbelly, with her tail
draped over his, and her head resting on
his shoulder.
Sonny had no idea how fierce teeth could
sleep. through those tree rattling
snores.
Prey hunter lay closer to the river
scrunched into a tight, tense ball with
his wings tucked close to him.
In the daylight.
Sonny could see how dull his scales were
and how ill they all looked, even
Strongwings, who was built large and
burly, looked underfed, and his snores
rasped heavily, as if his lungs and
throat and nose were lined with claws.
Sunny studied the ground around prey
hunter, until she spotted a corner of
black glass sticking out from under one
of his wings.
He was keeping the obsidian mirror very
close.
How can I get it without waking him up?
She glanced at the other 2 again, then
quietly slid down her tree, until her
talon touched the grass.
The river bubbled over smooth gray rocks
not much more than a stream.
Small purple wildflowers bent under her
claws, as sunny tiptoed over to the
sleeping night wing.
He looked miserable, even in his sleep.
His jaw was clenched.
His talons twitched defensively, and his
forked black tongue flickered in and out
as he muttered something to himself.
When Sonny crouched beside him, she
realized he was shivering.
I guess it was pretty hot, living on a
volcano.
The air didn't feel cold to her, here on
the outskirts of the jungle, but perhaps
he wasn't used to it.
Or perhaps he was sick.
It felt strange to be so close to an
unfamiliar night wing.
For the 1st 6 years of her life, Sonny
had known exactly 7 dragons, Clay, Tsunami
Starflight, Glory, and their 3 guardians
Webbs, Dune and Kestrel.
Two of those 7 dragons were dead now.
She knew the guardians had never been
particularly kind to the dragonettes, but
they were still the only parent she'd
ever had, and she missed them.
Her friends had never stopped to grieve
for Dune and Kestrel.
She wasn't even sure they were sad about
their deaths at all.
She'd tried not to show how it upset her
but at night, curled up beside clay, when
she was sure he'd sleep through it.
Sometimes she'd let herself cry for
them.
She reached toward the sliver of obsidian
but before she even touched it, Prey
Hunter whimpered in his sleep, and she
snatched her talons back.
None of the dragons moved for a long
moment.
Maybe this is a bad idea.
I could make things worse if I get myself
caught.
But if she could get the mirror away from
them, that would be one less weapon in
their claws, they'd be flying blind, with
no idea what glory was planning, and no
way to know if Byrne would receive them
with open wings, not to mention Sonny
could probably use that mirror herself.
She reached out again, and noticed the
trembling that shuddered through prey
hunter's scales.
Maybe he wasn't cold.
Maybe, it was a nightmare.
Maybe he's dreaming about the terrible
things he's done.
Or perhaps he's dreaming about the
volcano exploding.
She hesitated, and then unfolded one of
her wings.
Spreading it gently over his back.
She was too small to cover him completely
but the warmth that radiated from her
scales, spread as far over him as she
could reach.
She held her breath, trying not to touch
him.
Pray hunter let out a long, shuddering
sigh, and then the shivering stopped.
He took another deep breath, and Sonny
saw the tension in his snout, jaws, and
neck, relax.
A ripple went through his wings, and his
claws unclenched.
He stopped muttering, and even his closed
eyes seemed to smooth over, as if he were
shifting into a deeper, calmer sleep.
Sunny waited a long moment, feeling sorry
for this dragon. even though she really
didn't want to.
She couldn't help wondering what she
herself might have been like if she'd
grown up on the night wing island.
Desperate and sad, mean and hungry.
She reached for the mirror again, and
suddenly, prey hunter spoke.
Please.
Sonny froze.
His eyes were still closed.
Across the clearing, fierce teeth shifted
her wings and coughed.
Please, don't make me, Pray Hunter said
more softly.
Mother, it's awful.
A stab of sympathy shot through Sonny, and
she curled her tail in closer, remember
what he's planning, and what he said, and
what he's done.
But it was hard not to imagine herself in
his scales.
Gently, she used her front talons to
slide the mirror out from under his
wing.
Her warmth had relaxed his grip on it, so
he wasn't clutching it so tightly, and it
only took a moment until it was resting
coldly between her claws.
The obsidian felt thin, like a layer of
ice, and the edges were sharp as teeth.
Sonny could see her distorted reflection
in the dark glass.
She took a careful step back.
Then another, and folded her wings back
in.
Prey Hunter made a lost, mournful noise
and his claws twitched, as if he were
trying to pull the warmth back into him.
Will they guess I'm the one who stole
it?
What if they come looking for me?
She glanced around the clearing.
A large flat gray boulder took up most of
the ground between the 3 dragons, with
bright yellow dandelions dotting the
edges, like topaz gemstones around a
pendant.
I'll leave them a message.
Something that won't sound like me.
Maybe something that'll scare them.
Her own heart was drumming frantically
against her ribs like a caged bird.
She wanted to get out of there before any
of them woke up.
But she had a strong feeling that there
was something to this idea.
She dipped a claw in the dark red mud
that lined the river, and wrote on the
boulder in tall, jagged letters.
Turn back.
You fly toward your death.
Totally spooky.
She thought with satisfaction.
It even looked like maybe it could have
been written in blood.
That should at least creep them out, even
if it doesn't send them scurrying back to
the rainforest.
Sonny took a step back, and then suddenly
strong wings let out the loudest snore
yet, and fierce teeth rolled over to swat
him with her wing.
Shut your noisy snout, or so help me, I
will rip it off with my claws, she
hollered.
Sonny bolted into the sky and didn't stop
flying until she reached the dense green
canopy of the jungle again.
When she finally glanced back, there was
no movement from the night wings copse of
trees.
Strong wings had even started snoring
again.
I guess she was yelling at him in her
sleep, or she went right back to sleep
and didn't notice me there.
Sonny carefully tucked the mirror under
one wing and used her talons to clamber
up and along the trees until she found a
spot where the leaves overlapped so
thickly, it was like a small green cave
around her.
She studied the mirror.
What had Prey Hunter done to activate
it?
Starflight, she said softly to the cold
Abyssinian, and then she breathed a small
plume of smoke across the surface.
As it had before, the smoke twined and
twisted around the mirror, then
vanished.
Sonny could feel the mirror thrumming
faintly between her claws.
It was sort of horrible.
A sick, slithering sensation through her
blood, as if it were pulling something
out of Sonny's heart.
A faint black tendril of smoke curled up
from the center of the mirror, barely
visible in the green tinted sunshine.
It didn't speak, but when sunny leaned
closer, she could hear the faint sound of
breath going in and out.
He's alive.
Two pale blue wisps of smoke drifted by
close to the edge of the mirror.
I've never seen anything like it
whispered one.
The queen said this is what fire can do
murmured the other.
It seems almost as bad as venom, if you
ask me.
From their voices.
Sonny guessed they were 2 of the healer
rain wings she'd befriended, while she
was helping take care of webs.
Rainwing healers were odd, specializing
mostly in saying comforting things, and
offering more fruit to eat.
But occasionally they were really
specifically knowledgeable, like about
jaguar bites, or what to do if you ate
too many mangoes, or how to make salves
for tails that had been used for swinging
from rough branches one too many times.
I'd rather be Kinkaju than him right now
said the first.
She's healing well.
Did you see the messenger who was here
before?
The 2nd curl of blue smoke moved, looping
around the black smoke as if checking on
it, and then sliding back to the first.
That big brown dragon sent a message for
Sonny.
I wasn't sure whether to tell him we
haven't seen her.
I don't want to worry the queen when she
has so many night wings to deal with.
I say don't start a panic.
She's around somewhere.
This was similar to the rain wings
attitude toward their own missing dragons
some of which have been gone as long as a
year by the time Glory rescued them.
Well, that's fine, Sonny thought.
I don't need or want my friends looking
for me.
They have enough to do.
The black smoke stirred, as if the
faintest breath of wind had touched it.
Sunny.
Starfight whispered.
But, poor Starflight.
She curled her tail in around her talons
and sighed.
Shh.
We woke him by talking about her
admonished the 1st healer.
Let's get him another sleeping dart.
Sonny cleared the mirror and held it
between her claws for a moment.
She disliked it more and more the longer
she held it.
It had a chilling wrongness to it, like
the tunnels, that made her scales feel as
if invisible spiders were crawling all
over her.
But there were things she needed to know
like what the warring sand wing queens
were plotting.
The obsidian mirror could help her figure
out if any of them was an immediate
threat to Sonny's friends.
I should at least try one of them, the
most dangerous one.
She hesitated, and then whispered, Blister
to the dark glass.
The pale yellow twist of smoke that rose
from the center this time had the same
chilling stillness that blister had.
It barely even moved in the breeze.
Be careful.
It hissed suddenly.
And Sunny flinched away from the mirror.
It was unsettling to hear Blister's voice
as if she were on the next branch over.
Close it up.
Is he ready to go?
All right.
Give him his gold, and tell him I'll be
there in a moment with final
instructions.
The smoke dipped for a moment, then
turned is another small twister touched
down.
Anything?
No sign of any sea wings, Your Majesty
said the new arrival.
We waited half the day.
Blister hissed, low and long.
I'll win this war without them then.
She growled.
Burn will be dead within a fortnight, and
then I'll kill Blaze with my own talons
and the sea wings will get nothing when
they come slithering out of the ocean
begging for forgiveness.
They'll find my claws, and the entire
force of the sandwing army waiting
instead.
Coral has no idea what vengeance can
really look like.
Don't touch that, she snapped abruptly.
Sorry, your majesty, what?
It's my plan to end this war once and for
all, Blister said, in a dark voice
without the sea wings or the night
wings.
So stay away from it.
Any word from our spies in the ice
kingdom?
No sign of the Dragonettes yet?
Perhaps, I know, Blister snapped.
They could be somewhere else.
There was the sound of paper crackling.
I've been considering the possibilities.
Hiding in the rainforest, perhaps?
Sunny felt a chill down her spine.
Or perhaps they're dead, said the soldier
especially if they tried going to the
rainforest.
From what I've heard about that place.
Hmm, blister mused, dead.
They'd never do anything so convenient
for me, even with a night wing assassin
after them, supposedly, if anything
Morrow Seer says can be trusted.
Speaking of dragons, I'm going to
dismember as soon as I get my claws on
them.
She doesn't know he's dead.
How could she?
Sonny gripped the branch below her
feeling terror shudder through her
scales.
At least she's not searching the
rainforest yet.
It doesn't matter, said Blister.
Her voice suddenly brisk.
I'm done with prophecies.
I mean, I'll still kill the dragonettes
when I find them.
But 1st, I have a war to win.
My new plan will take care of burn, and
then the stronghold will fall, and the
throne will be mine.
There was a chilling rattling sound.
And a twist of smoke seemed to get a
little darker.
How?
began the soldier.
But just then, Sonny heard a roar from
the night wings clearing, Uh-oh.
She wanted to know what blister's plan
was, but she needed to know how the 3
night wings were reacting, and if she was
in danger right now, she cleared the
mirror quickly, whispered, fierce teeth
to it, then breathed smoke across it
again.
Immediately, 3 curls of black smoke
popped up on the glass, rushing around
one another like small tornadoes.
How could you lose it?
Fierce teeth's voice snarled.
I didn't lose it.
Pray Hunter snapped.
Someone stole it.
Right out from under your snout.
Fierce teeth growled.
How exactly?
I don't know.
Pray Hunter yelled.
I do, said a trembling voice, that barely
sounded like strong wings.
It was the dark stalker.
Sunny tilted her head toward the mirror.
What's the dark stalker?
What could be scary enough to terrify a
dragon as big as strong wings?
The other 2 night wings didn't respond
for a long moment.
Finally, fierce teeth hissed.
That's just a ghost story for Little
Dragonettes.
There's no dark stalker, or if there ever
was, we killed him centuries ago.
No, he's real, Strongwing said, edging
toward hysteria.
Everyone knows he's still out there
somewhere, and now he's found us.
Look at this message.
We're going to die.
It could have been someone who wants us
to think, he's the dark stalker, Pray
Hunter said dubiously.
But who else would know we had the
mirror?
Who else would know that we're flying to
our death?
Snap out of it, strong wings?
Fierce teeth barked.
Someone is trying to scare us, that's
all.
You know the story.
The dark stalker, if he did exist. died a
long time ago.
No.
He couldn't die.
Strong wings whispered.
They buried him, but they always knew
he'd come back one day.
Sunny had never heard of this mythical
dragon.
It must be a night wing legend.
Lucky for me.
She hadn't expected to tap into an old
superstition.
Maybe it was that sandwing.
Fierce Teeth said, then immediately let
out a dismissive snort.
No, that stunted salamander wouldn't have
the teeth for something like this.
She must have gone back and told someone
we had the mirror.
I bet this was death bringer.
Seems like something he would do, from
what I've heard of him.
Sonny was obscurely flattered and
offended at the same time.
She flicked her tongue at the dark
glass.
A death bringer would just kill us.
Argued Pray Hunter.
Strongwings is right about one thing.
This is what the dog stalker does
according to the stories.
He plays with his prey for days, making
sure they're nearly paralyzed with terror
before he strikes.
Yes, exactly, Strongwing said.
He'll come back the next time we sleep
and kill just one of us, or, So let's not
be paralyzed with terror.
Fierce teeth snarled.
Let's go.
The kingdom of sand is on the other side
of those mountains.
We can be there in a few days if we stop
moaning and clutching our tails.
Come on.
Her smoke tendril was nearly interwoven
with strong wings. as if she were trying
to heave them into the sky with brute
force.
But the message...
We can't go back.
Fierce Teeth said.
Glory will kill us more definitely than
any old night wing animus ghost.
And if she doesn't.
We'll be the rain wings prisoners.
I'll take my chances in the desert, even
without that mirror.
The argument didn't go on much longer.
Soon the sound of wing beats thumped
across the smooth obsidian.
Sonny tilted the smoke together, and
breathed fire across it again until there
was nothing but silence, and darkness on
the face of the mirror.
The slithering inside of her faded, but
she felt more tired and sick than she had
in a while.
I hope I don't have to use this thing too
often.
So I'd better try to keep an eye on
them.
She ducked through the leaves and flew
straight up until she slipped through the
whispering green canopy, straight into
blinding sunlight.
On the western horizon, already no bigger
than claws, she could see the 3 black
shapes winging away toward the
mountains.
She followed, feeling better and stronger
with each moment of sun on her scales.
The kingdom of sand, the desert, just on
the other side of those mountains.
I'm going home.
Chapter 5.
Sunny followed the night wings for 3 days
as they navigated the foothills, and then
the snowier heights of the mountain crags
they slept in the shadow of Jade Mountain
listening to the wind howling around the
twin peaks.
She only had to use the mirror once more
when she lost sight of them, and it
helped her catch up to them again.
She would have loved to sneak back into
their camp and leave more scary
messages.
But she knew they'd take turns staying
awake to keep watch after losing the
mirror.
And she resisted the temptation to use
the mirror on her friends, or on blister
again, although she kept worrying about
blister's new plan.
Still, she wanted to avoid that sick
slidery feeling as much as possible.
From the mountaintops, they flew down
through densely forested foothills, and
off in a distance, ahead of them, Sunny
began to see something that shimmered
white and hazy across the horizon.
The desert, she thought, with a prickle
of anticipation.
She'd been there once before, when the
dragonettes found the tunnel from the
rainforest into the kingdom of sand.
They'd had to chase mangrove all the way
to the borderlands of the Ice Kingdom.
So she'd spent 2 days flying over the
desert, but hardly any time down on the
sand, where her talons really wanted to
be.
And no time at all looking for my
parents.
Her thoughts kept circling back to that
as she flew, with no one to talk to, and
nothing else to distract her from
worrying about the prophecy.
Her friends had all found some kind of
family by now.
Even if some of it was disappointing
family, and no one was quite what they'd
expected.
Clay's mother was awful, but his brothers
and sisters were a lot like him, according
to Clay.
Tsunami's mother was the queen of the sea
wings, who had tried to imprison them, but
tsunami had 2 little sisters too, anemone
and Aucklet.
Glory had no way to figure out who her
parents were, thanks to the way rain
wings kept their eggs all together, but
she'd found a brother, Jambu, even if he
was a bit silly, and also grandeur, who
was perhaps a great grandmother, or great
aunt, or something like that.
Poor Starflight had really had it the
worst of all, between mastermind for a
dad and fierce teeth as his sister.
But at least they knew.
At least they'd found someone.
They all had dragons who wanted them in
some way.
Why did my parents leave me?
She had almost nothing to go on if she
ever wanted to look for her family.
All Kestrel had said was, Dune found
Sonny's egg in the desert, hidden near
the Scorpion Den.
The Scorpion Den.
I don't even know what that is.
She'd seen it marked on the map, but she
didn't remember reading about it in any
scrolls.
Oh.
Her wings missed a beat as she finally
remembered where she'd heard about Jade
Mountain.
It was something Kestrel said the last
time we saw her.
When you realize you need me.
You can send me a message through the
dragon of Jade Mountain.
She twisted to look back at the fanged
mountain.
So a dragon lived there.
One who dealt with at least some of the
talons of peace, that could be useful to
keep in mind.
Although, who would live somewhere so
sinister?
She wondered which tribe it was from, and
why he or she lived alone.
When she turned back around, she saw the
distant shapes of the night wings diving
toward the forest below them.
Resting again?
When we're so close?
We can't be more than an hour's flight
from the desert now.
They had only flown for half the night
before stopping to sleep, and then risen
with the sunrise to fly again a few hours
ago.
Now the sun had cleared the eastern
horizon, but the day was barely begun, and
they already needed a break.
They seriously have no stamina.
She rolled her eyes and folded her wings
to drop down into the forest as well.
Wind flurried green leaves brushed
against her scales, and a riot of gray
squirrels scattered along the branches as
she landed, her talons sinking into the
soft grass.
In the distance, she could hear the night
wings roaring grumpily, and she guessed
they were having another unsuccessful
hunt.
For a trio of menacing killers, they were
actually surprisingly bad at catching
anything to eat.
Sunny wasn't the world's best hunter
herself.
But she didn't need much.
She'd always eaten less than her friends
a lizard a day would be enough for her.
Kestrel used to grumble that that was
probably why Sonny was so stunted and
scrawny, but then Dune would shake his
head and insist that it was normal for
sand wings to be light eaters.
Kestrel and Dune.
Our dead guardians.
If only she'd had more time to ask Dune
about where her egg came from.
He'd always been evasive when the subject
came up, but if she'd known her friends
were planning an escape, if they'd
trusted me enough to tell me about it, she
thought with a frown, she could have
pressed him harder.
Sunny swiveled her head around
listening.
There was an odd noise in this forest.
Actually, there were several odd noises
like thumps, and murmurs, and a chattery
kind of bird song, almost as though
squirrels were trying to imitate their
winged neighbors.
But it sounded as though it was coming
from under the ground.
She crouched and pressed one ear to the
warm earth.
There's definitely something under here.
Groundhogs?
Rabbits?
She didn't think any normal rodents made
noises quite like this.
And from what she could tell, it wasn't a
small warren underneath her.
The sounds seemed to be coming from
fairly far away as well.
Softly, she paced through the forest
stopping occasionally to listen.
She kept an eye out for the 3 night wings
but they weren't hard to avoid.
First, there was the roaring and crashing
around, and then after a while, snoring
that shook the top branches of the
trees.
Sonny worked her way cautiously westward
in the direction of the desert.
Small brown and red birds chorused from
the trees, occasionally pausing as they
saw her approach, and then starting again
after a moment, as if they realized she
was nothing to worry about.
Bumblebees and dragonflies buzzed and
hummed and flitted around her talons.
In the mild morning breeze, Sonny could
smell apples, and mint leaves, and
something else too, like old burnt wood.
She couldn't hear the sounds from under
the ground anymore, but the burnt smell
drew her on.
Up ahead, she could see a break in the
trees.
She stepped out into the bright sunlight
and stopped.
Her eyes momentarily full of light.
There was a hole blasted in the forest.
Something had been here once, something
that stretched for more than a mile
within the forest, bigger than the
dragonette's home under the mountain.
But it was gone now, all burned to black
ashes.
Where Sonny stood at the edge of it.
The forest was trying to rise again.
Ashes drifted like dead leaves over her
claws, but she could see small green
shoots wriggling through here and there.
She spread her wings and took to the air
hoping for a better look.
The burnt area stretched in jagged
slashes through the trees, and ended at
the border with the rocky foothills that
led to the desert.
From above, she could see that the hole
in the forest was many wingspans across
and black as a night wings scales.
It looked like a dark gap in a piece of
jewelry where a gemstone had been
violently gouged out.
She circled overhead.
Everything inside the hole looked twisted
and blasted into dark ashes, but as Sonny
studied the wreckage, she realized that
it wasn't just trees that had been burned
here.
Some of the ghostly shapes that remained
looked like buildings.
But these buildings were too small for
dragons.
Sunny landed next to one of the ruins, and
stared at it in confusion for a moment.
Even she was too big to fit through the
stone doorways that leaned silently out
of the ashes.
But why would any dragon build houses so
small?
She walked around it.
Her wings stirring up small tornadoes of
ash flakes, and saw that in the center of
the burnt area was a kind of open
square.
She could feel hard cracked stones
meeting her claws under the layers of
ash.
In the middle of the square, she found a
collapsed pile of round rocks, and tipped
sideways among those was a blackened
metal bell about the size of Sonny's
head.
Somebody definitely built this, were they
keeping some kind of small animal here?
She turned to look at another of the
small stone doorways, and found a shape
sticking out of the wreckage beside it.
When she clawed it out, she realized it
was a piece of stone, roughly carved into
a shape with 2 legs, no wings, and
holding something pointy over its head.
Oh, Sonny inhaled sharply, getting a nose
full of old soot smell.
Scavengers.
The statue, if that's what it was, looked
a bit like a drawing from one of the old
scrolls about scavengers who attacked
dragons for their treasure, waving sharp
little toothpick claw things called
swords.
Did scavengers build this place?
Can they do things like make bells and
carve statues?
Sunny knew scavengers lived in dens, but
she hadn't thought they could build real
buildings like this.
She always imagined them clustering in
caves or digging out holes to live in, or
maybe leaning long sticks together to
create shelters at most.
Here, there was clearly advanced masonry
deliberate foundation work, and a sort of
organized street plan as far as Sonny
could tell.
Plus the statue.
It was crude, but wasn't it art?
What kind of prey made art?
Maybe I misunderstanding all of this.
Maybe dragons built this place and kept
scavengers here for some reason.
And then burned it all down?
Why would they do that?
She lifted into the sky, feeling
unsettled.
The dragonettes had studied scavengers in
their scrolls, but Webbs and Kestrel had
never brought any back to their mountain
caves for eating or practice hunting.
Sunny had seen a few small scavengers in
Queen Scarlet's palace, scurrying around
under the dragon's feet at a banquet for
the visiting sand wings.
But she'd been up in a giant bird cage on
display as a gift for burn, so she hadn't
gotten a very close look.
Scavengers were the ones who'd started
the Dragon War by killing Queen Oasis and
stealing all her treasure, leaving burn
blaze, and blister to fight over the
throne and the empty treasury.
Sonny didn't know much else about
scavengers.
She knew they liked shiny things.
She'd always imagined scavengers as sort
of fierce magpies or squirrels, bigger
than either of those, but not much
smarter.
They couldn't have very much of a brain
if they thought attacking dragons was a
good idea, right?
She glanced down at the destroyed village
once more, then turned back to find a
spot where she could hide and wait for
the night wings.
Maybe there's more to scavengers than we
were taught.
But what happened here?
Who burned down this scavenger den?
And why?
Chapter 6.
Heat blazed across Sonny's scales.
She burrowed into the sand, feeling the
tiny particles drift across her talons
and tail.
The obsidian mirror caught the sunshine
as if it were trying to suck all the
light into itself, and the black wisps of
smoke on its surface looked like small
sandstorms.
Why wouldn't we go straight to burn
stronghold?
Fierce Teeth's voice demanded.
Because she'll have us slaughter the
moment she sees us coming.
Pray Hunter said impatiently.
Burn is a kill 1st.
Ask questions later, kind of dragon.
It makes sense to start at the Scorpion
den.
Strong Wings agreed.
We can find someone there to take a
message to Bern that we want to see her.
Sonny closed her eyes.
The scorpion den.
That might be where my parents live.
I thought the scorpion den was full of
lowlifes in criminals, said fierce
teeth.
It is, said Prey Hunter.
It is?
thought Sonny.
Is that what my parents are?
But they're the kind of criminals who
know how to get things done from
everything I've heard, said Strongwings.
That's exactly what we need right now.
Besides, the Scorpion Den isn't far, just
over those dunes.
Sonny sat up and narrowed her eyes
against the bright glare of the sun.
The night wings were far ahead of her, but
she thought she could see a dark shape
against the sand off in the distance
which might be the scorpion den.
All right, all right, fierce teeth
grumbled.
Waste of time, if you ask me.
Sonny cleared the mirror, feeling
excitement prickle through her scales.
She knew it was unlikely that she'd find
out something about her past in the
Scorpion Den, but it was still the
closest she'd ever been to her parents.
Even if they were criminals, she still
wanted to know who they were.
Also, a detour to the Scorpion Den would
give her more time to slow down the night
wings.
She still hadn't come up with any plans
to stop them from telling Bern
everything.
In the distance.
She saw the tiny black shapes lift into
the sky.
Cautiously, she followed them.
There was really nowhere to hide in the
desert, unless she burrowed under the
sand, so she was staying as far back as
possible.
But it was hard to stop her wings from
beating faster and faster as they drew
closer to the scorpion den.
Sonny could see that it was a walled city
full of winding alleyways, ramshackle
stone buildings, tattered canopies, and
dilapidated tents and colors that had
been faded by the sun over a long period
of time.
And it seethed with dragons.
Scales glittered from every shadow and
venomous tails slithered around corners.
She was so preoccupied staring at the
town that she had to stop herself
abruptly in midair when she realized that
the 3 night wings had not gone inside, but
were standing outside the tall gates at
the single entrance.
It looked as though they were arguing
with a muscular sand wing guard, who
stood with her wings folded back and her
tail raised menacingly.
Sonny dropped quickly to the sand, hoping
she hadn't been seen.
She flattened herself against the dune
even though she knew her scales were not
quite the right color for camouflage.
Now that she was still, she could hear
the dragon's voices shouting.
You have no right to stop us.
Fierce teeth roared.
Can't you see that we're night wings?
Yeah, answered the guard.
So read my mind.
The part that says, go at your tails.
We have business in the scorpion din, Pray
Hunter insisted.
No one gets inside without a contribution
to the outlaws.
The guard said firmly.
The out claws.
Said Prey Hunter.
That's what you call yourselves.
You must be joking.
Are you asking for treasure?
Fierce teeth demanded.
Of course we don't have treasure.
Our home was just...
Surely you can make an exception for us.
Strong wings interjected, cutting her
off.
I mean, we're night wings.
And said the guard.
There was a pause.
Sonny grinned, imagining the apoplectic
fit fierce teeth was probably having.
We could give you a prophecy.
Prey Hunter suggested after a moment.
Ha, the guard said, sounding moderately
more interested.
That would be funny.
Kibley, tell Thorn we have 3 night wings
offering their pathetic services.
I think you mean prophetic services
Fierce Teeth said.
Uh-huh, said the guard skeptically.
There was a long silence as everyone
waited.
Sunny wriggled higher up on her dune
hoping for a view of the city gates, but
a long slope of sand dotted with prickly
spheres of cacti blocked her way.
What can I offer the guard to get inside
the scorpion den?
She wondered.
She glanced down at the obsidian mirror.
It was the only thing she had.
Was it worth giving up her one advantage
over the night wings?
On the other talon, she knew she'd be
happy to have its sinister weight out of
her claws.
But on the 3rd talon, she didn't know who
would end up with their claws on this
potentially dangerous weapon, what might
the out claws do with it?
Hmm.
Moreover, even if she didn't offer it to
them, what was to stop a band of outlaws
from just taking it?
Sonny thought for a moment, then quickly
dug a hole in the sand next to one of the
cactus balls and buried the mirror.
Of course, there wasn't anything here to
help her distinguish one brownish rolling
sand dune from the next.
She'd have to cross all her claws and
hope she'd be able to find it again, but
a dangerous mirror nobody could find was
better than a dangerous mirror floating
around the scorpion den, surely.
She lifted her head as the guard below
spoke.
All right, he said.
Thorn wants to see you.
Don't ask me why.
Follow Kibli, and no funny business.
Sonny waited as long as she could bear it
then scrambled up and started over the
dune.
A sand wing was standing there, no more
than 3 steps away, staring straight at
her, as if he'd been waiting for her.
His side was pocked and dented with old
scars, and he had 6 claws on each foreleg
instead of five.
She had no idea where he'd come from, or
how he'd snuck up on her so quickly and
quietly.
Oh, she yelped.
That means you too, he said calmly.
Me too, what?
Sonny stammered.
He tilted his head and studied her
curiously, registering the odd color of
her scales and eyes, and no doubt
noticing her venomless tail as well.
You're to come before the outlaws as
well.
Thorn wants to know why you're following
those scum dwellers.
He jerked his head in the direction of
the den and the night wings.
Sonny had never heard anyone refer to
night wings with that much disrespect
before, except perhaps tsunami or glory.
I'm, I'm not following anybody.
Sonny said, folding her wings back.
She could hear how unconvincing she
sounded.
He shrugged.
Lie to me all you want, but I wouldn't
recommend trying it with thorn.
He flicked his tail, and she flinched
away.
Come.
It was not a request.
At least he wasn't threatening to chain
her up, and at least going with him would
mean getting into the Scorpion den
without the problem of payment.
Fine, she said, lifting her chin.
Take me to Thorn.
They flew down to the city gates, and the
guard nodded impassively as they went
past her, straight into a crooked stone
alleyway with steps leading up and down
sharp, spicy cooking smells filled the
air, along with a sense of smoke and
crowds of overheated dragons.
The streets around them were lined with
rickety stalls and tents, and voices
began pressing in on Sonny.
Crocodile stew, roasted scorpion, bag of
crickets.
Bet you'd like some gold for them golden
scales.
Stuck up on bright stained cactus.
You never know when you might need it.
Need anyone killed, little lady?
Here, take my card.
A small flat piece of metal inscribed
with a name was pressed into Sonny's
talons, and the sand wing who'd given it
to her, vanished almost immediately.
Sonny blinked and glanced up at the
dragon escorting her.
Whose is it?
he asked, plucking it out of her claws.
Ah, you don't want him, too expensive
barely competent.
He tossed the card into another stall as
they went by, and a snout poked out of a
pile of carpets to growl at them.
Ouch!
Sonny yelped. as someone rushed past and
stepped on her tail.
She tried to sidestep a pair of
quarreling dragons and got smacked in the
face by a sandy wing.
These streets are so narrow.
And there are so many of them.
They must accidentally scratch each other
with their tails all the time.
She looked more closely at the stalls
around her, and realized that many of
them sold the cactus that was the
antidote to sandwing venom, as far as she
could see, it was nearly as popular as
the giant camel hide pouches of water
being sold by every other merchant, or
the tiny blue dragons and shiny black
spheres, that also seemed to share all
the tables with other merchandise.
A wooden signboard caught her eye. 3
dragons faces carved under the words
wanted.
Sonny twisted to try and stare at their
faces as her guard hurried her past.
She could have sworn one of them was
Dune.
And one of the others was.
But surely it couldn't be.
Her guard steered her through the tangles
of dragons, keeping one wing firmly
settled against her back.
Other dragons jumped out of his way when
they spotted him, or ducked their heads
as he went by, or slipped into shadowy
corners, hissing.
Soon Sonny realized that the same wooden
wanted sign was posted everywhere, hung
from walls, pinned to tent flaps, and
nailed to the stall boards.
She got a chance to peer at one more
closely when they paused, to let a card
of gold painted boxes clatter by.
It really does look like Morrisier.
Marosier, Dune, and a Nightwing I've
never seen before, but why?
And who's looking for them?
There was small print below the pictures
but Sonny didn't get to read it before
her guard hurried her on.
Nearly all the dragons she saw were sand
wings, although she also spotted a couple
of scarlet sky wings and even, once, the
pale blue scales of an ice wing, who must
have been miserable in this heat.
She also noticed a lot of war wounds.
Dragons with missing talons, mangled
wings, clawed up snouts, or ripped ears
many of them huddling in the spaces
between the stalls, skinny and wretched.
Although she was sure the Scorpion Den
was a dangerous place to live, she
guessed that a lot of dragons came here
to hide from the war, either before they
could be pressed into service, or after
they'd been so badly injured that they
couldn't bear to fight anymore.
One Sandwing limped up to them, and did
an odd half salute to Sonny's guard.
Going off duty, sir.
He paused and squinted at Sonny, and she
realized that he had a long scratch
across one of his eyes that had also torn
up part of his nose.
There was something vaguely familiar
about him, but she was sure she would
have remembered that scratch.
Addict.
Quit reporting to me all the time, the
guard said.
That's not how the outlaws work.
Also, I told you to stop calling me, sir.
Yes, right, right.
The dragon coughed, clearly swallowing
another sir.
Ah, who's your guest?
Sonny sidled closer to her escort.
Wishing addicts would stop staring at
her.
Her guard seemed to sense this.
He casually spread his big wings to
shield her from view.
Just a visitor for Thorn, he said.
Carry on.
Addicts bobbed his head and shuffled off
into the crowd.
Some of these former soldiers have a hard
time breaking their military habits.
The big sandwink said to her, but addicts
is harmless.
Don't worry.
Sonny twisted to look back, and saw that
the limping sand wing had stopped in the
shade of a stall that seemed to be
selling poisons.
His black eyes stared through her, and
even when she ducked behind her guard's
wings again, and after they had crossed
several more alleys, she still fell to
prickling, creeping feeling along her
spine, as if his gaze were following
her.
They wound their way toward the center of
the city, stooping under torn canopies
and tripping over uneven cobblestones
Sunny could smell something new up ahead
like exploded fruit, and she caught a
glimpse of dark green through the gaps
ahead of her, incongruous against the
sand colored buildings, faded orange
tents, and red or black brick walls.
A dragonette suddenly stumbled in front
of Sonny, holding out its front claws.
Hungry He bleated, his pale yellow scales
were slathered with dirt, and he was tiny
with bony ribs sticking out along his
chest, his black eyes caught Sonny, and
she stared down at him helplessly.
I'm sorry, she said.
I don't have anything.
The dragon beside her leaned forward, and
caught the dragonette before he could run
off again, casually pinning the little
one's tail to the ground with one talon.
Don't hurt him, Sonny cried, but the
guard didn't even look at her.
Where's your guardian, squirt?
He asked the dragonette.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, cried a female
sandwing. hurrying out of a nearby
alley.
I would never have let him bother you
sir.
Please forgive us.
She grabbed the dragonette and clutched
him to her.
He drooped.
No energy left to wriggle away.
You must be new here, said the 6 clawed
dragon, squinting at her.
He shouldn't be starving like that.
Dragonette's up to 8 years old, get a
free meal every morning after sunrise at
the pool.
Start sending him, and he'll be the size
of a real dragon soon.
The sand wings shivered and ducked her
head.
But, sir, she whispered.
I heard that was a trick.
He sighed impatiently.
Let me guess.
We feed them, and then grab them to turn
them into out claws.
Am I right?
She flinched, and her wings folded closer
around the dragonette.
Listen, we're not out to abduct a bunch
of scrawny youngsters who be more trouble
than they're worth.
Thorn just wants to make sure no more
dragonettes die of hunger in the scorpion
den.
It's not complicated.
Yes, sir, the sand wing whispered.
Look, send him tomorrow morning, or I'll
come after you myself, he said.
She nodded and scuttled away, keeping the
dragonette under her wing.
Some dragons, muttered Sonny's guard.
Is that true?
Sonny asked.
The, um, outlaws feed all the dragonettes
in the scorpion den?
He shifted his wings up and down and
scowled.
We try to.
Dragons don't change easily, though
especially in a place like this, and
especially when someone's trying to help
them.
Brainless worms, he muttered, turning to
stalk away again.
Sonny wasn't sure that she would trust a
gift from this dragon either.
What's your name?
She asked, as she caught up to walk
beside him.
He looked down at her, his black tongue
flicking in and out. 6 claws.
Oh, Sunny said, glancing at his odd
talons, and then, before she could stop
herself, your parents were feeling pretty
creative.
He barked a laugh that made several
dragons around them leap into the nearest
hiding place in terror.
Sunlight glinted off his light, yellowish
brown scales as he held up one of his
front legs and examined the 6 wickedly
sharp claws there.
I guess so.
Yours?
I'm Sonny, she said.
I never met my parents.
She chanced to sideways look at his
face.
But there was no reaction there.
He was old enough to be her father, and
from the way he walked and talked, she
guessed he'd been in the scorpion den for
a while.
Plus, he had those 6 claws.
Maybe peculiar defects ran in the
family.
Maybe he hadn't commented on her tail yet
because he'd seen other dragons with the
same flaw, dragons related to him.
Or maybe I'm totally desperate.
They stepped down a set of 5 stone stairs
and their talons sank into sand.
Sonny tore her gaze away from 6 claws, and
saw that the shadows of tents and
canopies had been replaced by the
sweeping shade of large palm fronds.
There was an oasis in the middle of the
scorpion den.
Well, that makes sense, Sonny realized
why else would dragons build a city
here?
She could see a rippling pool of greenish
blue water in the middle of the sand in
the palms.
She could also see multiple well armed
dangerous looking dragons patrolling
around the outskirts of it.
Are those all out claws?
She asked.
You guard the water in the scorpion den?
In the desert.
She who controls the water, controls
everything.
Six claws said.
And hear that she is thorn, sunny guest.
Six claws nodded toward a large white
tent, set up beside the water.
The walls billowed like swans, wings, and
venomous tail points stuck out under the
edges here and there, to particularly
mean looking sand wings guarded the
entrance, where a flap had been rolled up
to allow dragons to pass through.
As they approached, Sunny spotted a flash
of black scales through the doorway and
ducked behind 6 claws.
He peered over his shoulder at her.
Yes.
I don't want them to see me, she
whispered.
The Night Wings?
he asked.
The ones you were not following?
She nodded.
Why?
Sonny had a pretty strong feeling that it
wouldn't be wise to reveal her connection
to the prophecy, even if the outlaws
didn't immediately sell her to burn.
Someone else in the scorpion den was sure
to pounce on that opportunity.
They tried to kill me, she said.
That was basically true.
Six claws looked amused.
Here's some free advice When a dragon
tries to kill you, fly the opposite way.
I am keeping an eye on them, she said
bristling.
I need to know what they're planning.
That's up to Thorn now.
He said.
Come along and stay behind me.
Sonny's heart thumped as they approached
the tent.
Should she try to run?
Wasn't it possible, even likely?
that Thorn and the Night Wings would team
up to sell her to burn?
Thorn was the leader of a gang of
criminals after all.
Sonny wouldn't get far in this city
though, not with the outlaws after her.
Even in a place full of sandwings, she'd
stick out like a fire on a dark night.
She tried to keep the memory of the
hungry dragonette in her head as she
ducked under the soft white flap of the
tent.
A leader of criminals who fed small
dragons didn't sound so bad.
Maybe Thorn could be reasoned with.
The 3 night wings were seated in a row on
a bright orange carpet, woven with
alternating purple and white claw
shapes.
A skylight in the tent ceiling was
positioned to shine a ray of sunlight
down on them, beaming bright and hot
straight into their faces.
Sunny had a feeling that was deliberate.
They were surrounded on all sides by sand
wings.
Many of them rippling with scars or
missing teeth, as if they had fought hard
for a place in this tent, and weren't
planning to move anytime soon.
The only clear spot was at the far end of
the tent, where a pile of woven sky blue
rugs was arranged on a dais.
After a few moments, the sound of
laughter came from outside, and 5 more
sand wings pushed their way into the
tent.
Sunny could tell which one was thorn
immediately.
Although she was smaller than the others
and she wasn't wearing more treasure than
anybody else.
A solitary gold bracelet circled one of
her upper forearms, a chain of flying
dragons made from twisted wires.
Around her neck, hung a simple copper
chain with a moonstone pendant, an odd
jewel to find in the desert, Sonny
thought.
Her scales were sandy yellow, and dappled
with a pattern of small brown speckles
down her back and along her wings.
She looked young, probably barely 20
years old if Sonny had to guess.
Most dragons grew quickly for the 1st 7
years of their lives, and then a little
bit each year after that.
So the oldest dragons were usually the
largest, like Marosier, and Byrne, and
Grandeur.
But Thorn was wiry and compact, and
looked as if she might stay that way no
matter how long she lived.
What was it that made her seem so clearly
the leader of this group?
She was laughing with the others as they
came in, but she walked a step ahead of
them, her wings half open and tilted
forward, as if she had somewhere to be
and her eyes scanning the room as if she
were searching for something.
She radiated an intense energy.
Even Sonny caught herself wanting to
follow her wherever she went next.
The laughter dropped from Thorn's eyes
when she spotted the 3 night wings.
She curled her tail up threateningly
before stalking around them and climbing
onto the dais.
Sonny was glad not to be the one under
that glare.
Night wings.
Thorn said darkly.
Well, well, well.
We haven't had any of you visit our find
sitting about 7 years.
Why would we?
Fierce teeth challenge.
We're only here now because we want to
make a deal with burn.
We need someone to take her a message.
Strong wings added.
Thorn leaned forward.
That's irrelevant to me.
Where is Morrow Seer?
All 3 night wings looked startled.
You know, Morris, here?
Prey Hunter stammered.
Unfortunately, Thorn growled.
Tell me where he is, and I'll seriously
consider not killing you.
Prey Hunter flared his wings, and several
outlaws took a menacing step toward him.
You can't kill us, he protested.
We're night wings.
I assure you, Night Wings died just as
easily as any other dragon, Thorn said.
Would you like a demonstration?
No, no, no, Strongwing said hurriedly.
We'll tell you what we know.
In exchange for a messenger to burn.
Fierce teeth interjected.
In exchange for your lives.
Thorn countered calmly.
I'm not sending any of my outlaws into
that death pit.
Most of them are here expressly because
they're trying to avoid her.
But, Pierce Teeth started.
Morris Sears did.
Prey Hunter blurted out.
He died just a few days ago.
There was a terrible silence.
One of the dragons who'd come in last
took a step toward Thorn, reaching out
tentatively, her expression a surprising
mix of horror and sympathy.
Thorn's face contorted into a fury, like
nothing Sonny had ever seen before.
With a cry of rage, she leaped off the
dais, seized prey hunter by the throat
and flung him to the ground, where she
pinned him with her claws, and swung her
tail over his heart.
Fierce teeth and strong wings didn't have
time to react before outlaws were there
holding them back.
It wasn't necessary, though.
Sonny could see that they were too
terrified to do anything to help Prey
Hunter.
Say that again.
Thorn hissed in Prey Hunter's face.
He's dead.
Prey Hunter stammered.
Isn't that good news?
It sounded like you hated him.
Aren't you glad he's dead?
He can't be dead, Thorn said.
Tell me the truth, you lying bag of
bones.
Tell me how to get to your secret home
and where Marosir is, and what he did
to...
She cut herself off abruptly.
I can't tell you any of that, Prey Hunter
whined.
We're not allowed to, but I promise you
Morris here is dead.
Really, really, really did.
No.
Thorn shouted.
A burst of flame shot out of her mouth
scorching a spot beside Prey Hunter's
neck.
He screamed with fear, and 2 outlaws
jumped forward to beat out the flames on
the carpet before the fire reached the
tent.
At the same moment, Prey Hunter convulsed
and lashed out, slicing at Thorn's
underbelly with his sharp talons.
Moon's blasted crocodile spawn.
Six claws roared, knocking dragons aside
as he leaped at Prey Hunter.
Another sandwing, a male dragonette
around Sunny's age, also darted forward
from the other side, but they weren't
fast enough.
Thorn's tail stabbed down into the night
wing's heart, and with a shriek of pain
Prey Hunter collapsed underneath her
dead.
Chapter 7.
Sonny stared at the night wing's body.
His wings lying crookedly on either side
of him, his snout contorted into a final
twist of despair.
He was a bad dragon, she told herself.
The world is better off this way.
My friends are safer now that he's dead.
But he had a horrible life.
The other half of her argued.
Maybe he could have changed.
Maybe there was a better dragon inside
him somewhere, if someone had bothered to
try and bring it out.
Thorn stepped away from the body, taking
a deep breath.
Six claws put one talon on her shoulder
and she gave him a rueful look, as if she
hadn't wanted to kill prey hunter after
all.
She might not have, if he hadn't lashed
out at her, or maybe she had to.
Either way, to make sure the other night
wings know how serious, and dangerous she
is.
It's all right, Gibli.
Thank you.
Thorn said to the dragonette who'd run
forward to help her.
He stood on the other side of the body
looking as though he'd very much like to
stab it again, just to be sure.
Let's try this again, Thorn said.
Turning to fierce teeth and strong wings
the 2 black dragons had their heads down
and their wings pressed in close to their
bodies.
Thorn stopped, eye to eye with fierce
teeth.
Tell me how to find Morosir.
Fierce teeth hesitated, only for a moment
then said, It's an island.
Fierce teeth, strong wings hissed.
What?
She snapped at him.
What does it matter anymore?
It's all destroyed anyway.
She returned her scowling gaze to Thorn.
We lived on an island north of the
continent, but the whole place was just
wiped out by a volcano.
Marosir was killed by it.
That's the truth, so sorry if you don't
like it.
She lifted her chin defiantly.
Thorn's claws twitched, and her eyes
narrowed.
I can't let Starflight's sister die, Sonny
thought.
No matter how terrible she is, not if I
can stop it.
She knew it was foolish to expose herself
here, but it felt like clearly the right
thing to do.
That was what being in the prophecy was
all about.
And if she wanted to keep believing in it
she had to keep acting worthy of it.
It's true, she called.
She pushed her way through the sand wings
who blinked at her in confusion.
It's true.
Don't hurt her.
She stumbled onto the sand in front of
Thorn, half a wingspan from the night
wings who'd tried to kill her.
You!
Fierce teeth cried.
I was there, on the Nightwing Island
Sonny said, ignoring her.
Thorn's black eyes were pinning her to
the sand, like an exotic insect, studying
every bizarrely golden scale.
There was a volcano, and it wiped out the
night wings home, and killed Maro Seer.
I'm sorry, she added, and she was
although she wasn't quite sure why.
Who?
In the blazes, are you, Thorn asked.
This is the one who was following them.
Six claws said, nodding at the black
dragons.
Fierce teeth scowled, Strong wings just
looked shocked.
Ah, said Thorn, tilting her head.
Really?
So you're not here to see me about the
reward.
What reward?
Sonny shook her head.
I'm just trying to stop them before they
hurt my friends, she said, and then added
with a rush of hope, please don't let
them send a messenger to burn, it'll put
a lot of dragons in danger.
Really?
Thorn said.
She twisted to look at the night wings.
What do you have to say about that?
We have information we know Bern will pay
handsomely for.
Strong Wing said, glaring at Sonny.
Not only us.
I'm sure she'll reward anyone who helps
us get to her, and she'll pay even more
if you throw in this puny dragonette.
Thorn regarded Sonny skeptically.
Why?
Sonny shook her head, but of course that
wasn't going to stop him.
She's one of the dragonettes in the
prophecy, he said triumphantly.
Every dragon in the tent seemed to sit up
at once.
A few leaped to their feet and slipped
out the front entrance.
Sonny noticed uneasily.
Most of the others started whispering to
each other.
She caught snippets like, why so small?
And that's why that soldier?
And, but her tail, and, no wonder, burn.
One dragon, with a missing eye shifted
closer to peer at her, and Sonny tucked
her tail closer around her talons
shivering.
And we know where the others are.
Strong wings went on.
Fierce teeth smacked him in a snout with
her tail.
Shut up, she snarled.
All of Thorn's burning energy was now
fixed on Sonny.
She took a step closer, then circled
Sonny, inspecting her.
Sonny tried to look brave and calm, even
as Thorn picked up her harmless tail and
flipped it curiously between her claws.
Hmm, said the leader of the outlaws.
You're a little unusual.
I know, Sonny said.
It's all right, though.
I don't mind.
It's just the way I hatched.
On the brightest night, Thorn said, 6
years ago.
It was not exactly a question, but Sonny
answered it anyway.
Yes.
Thorn walked around Sunny one more time
her talons sending up small clouds of
sand between the gaps and the carpets, and
then stopped beside her. frowning at the
night wings.
One more question for you cowardly
lizards.
Can you tell me anything about a night
wing named Stone Mover?
Strong Wings snorted.
He took off 6 or 7 years ago, and no
one's heard from him since.
The queen was furious.
This answer didn't seem to make Thorn any
happier than anything else they'd said.
She hissed quietly, then turned to 6
claws.
Put them somewhere unpleasant.
She ordered.
I'll decide what to do with them later.
You, she said to Sonny, come with me.
They left on a tide of murmuring
dragons.
Sonny felt the same way she had when she
was in that cage in the Sky Palace, hung
up for everyone to stare at.
She stayed close to Thorn's tail.
The back wall turned out to divide the
tent in two, and when they ducked through
a flap, Sonny found herself in a smaller
area with fewer rugs, where there were a
couple of low black tables, a trunk
packed with scrolls, and 2 startling
pictures pinned to the walls.
Sonny gasped when she saw them.
One was Maroser, drawn in dark ink
glowering the way he always did.
The paper was large and pockmarked with
tiny holes.
Like someone's been throwing rather sharp
things at it, Sonny thought.
The other picture was slightly smaller
but had received the same treatment
staring out at her, looking much younger
than she remembered him, was Dune.
Sonny touched the paper lightly with one
claw.
Wow.
She said.
He still has the scars, but he looks much
healthier.
This must be back when he was still
getting the sun and heat of sandwing
needs before he went into hiding under
the mountain to take care of us.
You know him?
Thorn asked from behind one of the
tables.
She sounded casual, but there was
something ferociously intense in her
eyes.
Sonny wondered how much to admit, but
before she had to answer, the flaps
rustled, and the same dragonette from
before shoved his way in.
He was bigger than Sonny, but now that
she could see him more clearly, she
guessed he was perhaps a year younger.
A dark amber earring glowed in one ear
and a small rakish scar zigzagged across
his nose.
Kibley, thorn warned.
This is a private discussion.
I'm not leaving you alone with no
stranger, Kibley said, shooting a look
full of daggers, it's Sonny.
All prophecy like or not.
Thorn looked amused.
Your loyalty is charming, but I think I
can handle this dragonette as well as you
can.
It's better to have backup, he insisted.
He twitched his tail forward to rest on
the sand in front of him.
I promise I'll be quiet.
Well, that I do have to see.
She said, rolling her eyes.
All right, you.
What was your name?
Sonny.
Thorn crossed to the trunk of scrolls
which sat on another sky blue rug, wiping
her front talons on the fabric to shake
off the sand, Thorn leaned in and picked
up a sheaf of loose pages.
Sunny, she echoed.
Before you say anything else.
You're really not here for the reward?
I don't know anything about a reward
Sonny promised.
Kibley made a scornful noise.
Without commenting, Thorn handed her one
of the pages.
The thick, yellowish paper crinkled
stiffly between her claws.
Reward, reward, reward.
For any information leading to the
whereabouts of 2 night wings, once seen
around the Scorpion Den, known as
Marosier and Stone Mover.
For any information regarding the present
location of a scarred sand wing named
Dune, last seen frequenting the night
market 7 years ago.
For any dragonette hatched in the last 6
years with unusual features.
Come before Thorn at the Outlaw pool with
anything, your safety guaranteed.
Reward, reward, reward.
Smaller drawings of Marosir and Dune
accompanied the words, along with another
drawing of a subdued looking night wing
she guessed was stone mover.
She glanced at the other papers that
Thorn was holding, and saw similar
pronouncements with slightly different
words, 5 years ago, or, in the last 3
years, for instance, this wasn't a new
search or a new reward.
This was the latest update of an ongoing
hunt.
Sonny put the paper down slowly.
Pieces were starting to come together in
her mind. bubbling in a funny, hopeful
confused way.
You didn't know about this?
Thorn asked.
Sunny shook her head.
I haven't been in the kingdom of sand in
the last 6 years.
She took a deep breath, then let it all
spill out of her.
My egg was found out in the desert, alone
by a dragon named Dune.
That dragon.
She pointed to the picture on the wall as
Thorn inhaled sharply.
He took me to be raised by the talons of
peace, along with the other dragonets of
destiny.
After all, I fit the prophecy.
She hesitated, then added, and my parents
clearly didn't want me.
She raised her head and met Thorn's
eyes.
The leader of the out claws dropped the
rest of the papers, stepped forward and
seized Sonny's front talons in hers.
He didn't find you, she growled.
He stole you.
He knew where I'd hidden you for your own
safety, and he betrayed me.
Sonny felt as though she couldn't
breathe.
The claws wrapped around hers, the dark
eyes fixed on her.
These were the only real things in the
tent.
Everything else was blurring and sliding
away.
This is it.
She thought wonderingly.
This is the moment we all dreamed about.
All those years under the mountain.
I wanted you, Thorn said fiercely.
You were the only thing I wanted.
I've done everything I could to find
you.
Not fulfilling the prophecy, but finding
our parents.
Thorn gripped her claws tighter.
Sunny, you're my daughter.
Chapter 8.
Sunny Scales felt as if they were fizzing
and humming and trying to leap right off
her.
She flung herself into Thorn's wings
which folded around her like sunbeams.
Hey, Kibley barked, jumping up.
It's all right.
Sit down, Thorn said.
She rested her head on top of Sonny's and
pulled her in more tightly.
I knew you didn't really abandon me, Sonny
said, although she wasn't sure how much
she'd ever really known that.
I knew I'd find you one day, said Thorn.
I didn't take over this city for
nothing.
Never thought you'd just come strolling
into my tent, though, chasing a trio of
night wings, no less.
She leaned back and smiled.
Funny, brave little dragon.
It was warm, warm, warm here in her
mother's wings, as warm as Sonny had
always wanted to be.
Hang on, Kibley interjected.
Thorn, begging your pardon, but how do
you know?
She could be anybody.
She could be playing you.
She could be a con artist.
I've met enough con artists in the last 6
years, Thorn said calmly, swaggering in
here, hoping to cheat me out of the
reward.
This is my daughter.
Where's my father?
Sonny asked.
It's, It's not Dune, is it?
Bright smashing suns, no, Thorn said.
What a horrifying thought.
No.
She shot a glance at Kibley.
He's not around anymore.
We can talk about that later.
But speaking of Dune, if you can point me
Adam.
He's on this needs to be violently
dismembered list I have.
He's already dead, Sonny said.
But he wasn't so bad, really.
He died trying to protect us.
Successfully?
Thorn asked.
Well, not very successfully, Sonny
admitted, we kind of all got captured by
the Sky Wing Queen, but we're all right
now.
Thorn growled.
Teeth of the Viper.
I cannot believe my enemies have all died
before I could rip their heads off
myself.
Kibli, give me those drawings.
The dragonette unpinned the drawings of
Marosir and Dune from the wall, and Thorn
kept one wing around Sonny as she tore
them into tiny shreds.
Feel better?
Sunny asked.
Yes, Thorn said, hugging her close
again.
Would you like me to have those night
wings killed for you?
No, no, Sonny said quickly.
One of them is the sister of a friend of
mine.
She hesitated.
I kind of wish you hadn't killed the
other one.
I know, Thorn said.
She lifted her talons, checking them for
blood.
It's not my favorite part of the role, but
if you want to lead dragons.
You have to show them your claws
sometimes, Beetle.
Beetle?
Sonny echoed.
Thorn gave her an affectionate grin.
That was my pet name for you when you
were still in your egg, she said.
That's what I've been calling you in my
head all these years.
But I like Sonny.
Dune must have been paying attention when
I talked about possible names for you.
Her face darkened.
So you were friends, Sonny prompted.
I thought so.
Her mother looked up at the tent ceiling
for a moment.
Her eyes glittering.
I have so many questions, Sonny said
softly.
How did you know I would look weird?
Why did you have to hide my egg for
safety?
What do the night wings have to do with
anything?
So do I. said Thorn.
I want to know everything about
everything you've done for the last 6
years, and we should celebrate.
Let me send all my brigands about their
duties, and I'll tell armadillo to plan a
party.
Free roasted lizards and camel milk for
the whole scorpion den tonight.
She grinned.
Wait, Sonny said.
I don't need a party.
Perhaps not.
But it'll accomplish 3 things, Thorn said
briskly.
First, it'll relieve the tension out
there.
All those dragons, wondering what'll
happen with a prophecy dragonette in our
midst.
Second, it'll let everyone know you're my
daughter, so they'll treat you with
respect and not just curiosity.
And third, it'll make it very clear that
you're under outlaw protection, which
you're going to need in this city.
Oh, Sunny said.
For a moment, she'd worried that her
mother was like Blaze, just looking for
any excuse for a party.
It was reassuring to realize she had
smart reasons for what she was doing.
A commotion erupted in the main tent
dragons yelling, something being knocked
over.
Thorn whirled around with her tail high
alert for any danger, but when a sand
wing burst through the flaps and threw
himself at her feet, she relaxed and
waved Kibley back.
What is it?
Thorn asked.
Reports of a dragon bite viper, he
gasped.
Senior the orphanage.
Are we sure?
Thorn demanded, grabbing a long spear
made of 3 strands of metal twisted
together, and split into several sharp
points at the end.
Have any outlaws confirmed that it's
really there?
No.
He said, panting, but someone panicked
and set the nearest stalls on fire.
The orphanage will go up in flames.
If we don't put it out fast.
And so will the rest of the city.
Thorn said.
Sonny, I'm sorry.
I have to take care of this.
Of course, Sonny said, jumping up.
Can I help?
What can I do?
You can stay here safely, so I don't have
to worry about you.
Thorn said.
Please, Dragon Bite Vipers are not to be
trifled with.
I'll be back as soon as I can.
She snatched up a bag by the outer flap
and ducked out of the tent, gone before
the messenger could scramble to his feet
and follow her.
Sonny and Kibley stared at each other for
a few long moments.
Sonny wondered if she should be upset
that her mother had brushed aside her
offer of help.
But honestly, she wasn't sure she'd have
been much use.
As the excitement of meeting her mother
wore off.
Her wings began to feel like heavy
boulders, leaning against her sides.
Her head was woozy from the strange
smells and noises of the scorpion den.
What's a dragon bite viper?
Sonny finally asked.
Really?
Kibley said.
It's the most dangerous thing in the
desert, probably in all Eperia, but we
get them more than most tribes.
It's the only snake in the world that can
kill a dragon.
There's a snake that can do that?
Sonny said.
She shuddered from her horns to her
wingtips.
Creepy.
He nodded, and she tilted her head at
him.
Is Thorn your mother too?
she asked.
Ha, he said, startled.
He touched his snout self-consciously
where a few brown speckles stood out
against his light yellow scales, much
like the ones all over thorn, moons, no.
She saved me from my mother.
Besides, the way I understand it, there's
only ever been one egg for Thorn, and
that's you.
If you are who you say you are.
Nobody else?
Sonny asked.
I don't have any brothers or sisters.
He shook his head.
You're better off.
Mine are a pair of dumb snorting hippo
heads, who'd rather stab me with their
tails than share so much as a fig with
me.
Joke's on them, now that I'm an out
claw.
Kibli puffed his spines up and made a
ferocious face.
And you better not be messing with Thorn
either.
There's plenty of out claws lined up
behind me, who'll make you sorry if you
are.
I wouldn't know how to mess with her
Sonny said.
I promise.
I'm really very nice.
Hmm, Kibley said, skeptically.
There was a tan camel hair pillow next to
one of the black tables that looked
softer than anything Sonny had slept on
in the last several days, and she hadn't
slept much, waking up frequently to make
sure the night wings hadn't flown onward
without her.
She curled up on the cool sand, and
rested her head and front talons on the
pillow.
Kibley kept his dark eyes on her, his
brow furrowed, as if he hadn't quite
decided whether to trust her yet.
So, what do the outlaws do?
Sonny asked.
He fluffed his wings, scattering sand in
all directions.
Everything.
We keep the scorpion den from becoming a
mess of blood and teeth, which it used to
be, with everyone fighting all the time
till we sorted them all out.
And we make sure those what has too much
are convinced to pass them along to them
with nothing.
And what do you do with the pool?
Sonny was genuinely curious.
But for some reason, Kibli's answers seem
to be fading in and out.
We're the boss of it, he explained
proudly.
That way, we can get water to all the
little dragons and the sick dragons and
the wounded from the war, when they're
not too scared to come around and ask for
it anyways.
We can be very intimidating.
He added, with a satisfied nod.
Mm-hmm.
Sonny said, her eyelids drooping.
Are you falling asleep in the middle of
my fascinating explanation?
Kibley demanded, sounding outraged.
No, Sonny mumbled, inaccurately.
And if he said anything else, she didn't
hear it.
She woke up in darkness to the sounds of
dragons roaring and carousing outside the
tent, a small oil lamp, gleaming bronze
was set beside her, and 6 claws sat
beside it, chewing on something that had
been skewered on a stick and burned to a
crisp.
He dipped his head to her as she sat up
and yawned.
Your mother said not to wake you.
The shiver that sent down sunny spine. was
both lovely and unsettling.
My mother.
You could have.
I always feel like I'm missing something
when I'm sleeping, Sonny said
stretching.
Where is she?
Still trying to put out all the fires and
restore order.
He flipped one wing at the noises beyond
the white billowing walls.
There was something solid about his
presence, as though of course he would be
there, waiting patiently, whenever she
woke up and needed him.
Sunny could imagine that her mother would
be able to rely on him.
She wondered again if there was any
chance he might be her father.
Thorn had said, not around, but maybe
that just meant not attached anymore.
Or maybe there was a reason she was
keeping it a secret from the other
outlaws.
Most significantly, knowing he had
hatched with his unusual 6th clause, might
be enough to make Thorn think Sonny would
have something odd about her too.
What happened with the Viper?
Sonny asked.
Is everyone all right?
Six Claws stopped chewing and looked at
her?
We didn't find the Viper yet, but we've
contained the fire, for the most part, and
nobody was bitten, so far.
So we're either very lucky or quite
unlucky if there's really a viper out
there.
He considered her for a moment then added
thanks for asking.
Oh, Sonny said, flustered.
She'd been worried.
Of course she'd asked.
Of course.
Six Claws tossed away his stick and
rubbed sand over his talons.
Ready to be presented to the out claws, he
asked her.
Not even remotely, Sonny confessed.
He chuckled in a rumbling way, and lifted
the flap, so she could step through the
tent and out onto the shifting sands, pale
in the light of the 3 moons overhead.
The bright orange and yellow flames of
torches flickered all around the oasis
reflecting in a dance across the pool.
There were too many dragons for sunny to
count, especially in the wavering shadows
and most of them were moving, chasing one
another across the sand, calling out
insults or threats or jokes, laughing and
tossing drinks at each other.
As she blinked around, looking for
thorn.
One of the sand wings toppled into the
pool with a splash, and 3 others jumped
to hauler out, idiots.
Six claws said with affection, and
started forward.
That's far enough, said a voice in the
darkness behind the tent, 6 claws.
Stop where you are.
Six Claws swung around with a hiss.
I take orders from Thorn, and no one
else.
Oh, it's not an order, said the other
dragon.
He stepped forward, so the torchlight
could catch on his yellow scales, and
then he recognized the sand wing they'd
run into on the streets earlier.
Atics, the one with a scratch who looked
familiar.
It's a suggestion.
I think you'll really want to listen to.
Six Claws took a menacing step toward him
and addicts flicked his tail.
Two more beefy dragons appeared behind
him.
They had a small dragonette pinned
between them, perhaps 2 years old, with
nearly white scales, and a tail barb that
still wasn't fully developed.
She squeaked nervously as they dragged
her forward.
The question really, said addicts.
Is which daughter do you care about
more?
The alleged long lost egg that Thorn has
been searching for?
Or yours?
Sonny glanced up at 6 Claws and saw the
fury and fear contorting his face.
He sank his talons into the sand, raising
his tail beyond him, in the shadows.
She saw 4 more sand wings slide out from
behind the tent to stand menacingly
between them and the pool.
Ostrich, 6 claws growled.
His eyes fixed on his daughter.
Don't be scared.
I won't let them hurt you.
Don't make a mistake here.
Addicts warned him.
My friends' tails are much closer to your
dragon net than you are to me.
If you attack or even shout for help
she'll be dead in an instant.
But this doesn't have to get all violent
6 claws.
We want the dragonette of destiny.
It's a simple fair trade.
There was no dragon bite viper, was
there?
6 Claus said.
You said that fire to draw Thorn away.
Do you know how many dragonettes you
could have killed?
Yes, said addicts.
Don't make it one more.
Six Claws growled again, and Sonny saw
his eyes dart from her to his daughter.
He loves her so much, she thought.
That's what I always wanted.
That's what I might have now, with Thorn
family, and answers, and a place to
belong.
But only if I deserve it.
I can't take it at the expense of another
family.
It's all right, she said to 6 Claws.
Make the trade.
You have to.
I'll be fine.
She glanced up at the palm leaves that
blocked the view of the stars.
Addicts had smartly cornered them in a
pocket of shadow where they couldn't be
spotted from across the pool.
What do you want her for?
Six Claws asked.
Burn wants the dragonettes pretty badly.
Addick said.
She'll take me back if I show up with one
of them.
Back into her army?
Six claws demanded.
Why would you want that?
You could be safe here.
The war never comes to the Scorpion den.
Attic shifted, firelight gleaming in his
dark eyes.
I was thrown out of her army, but my
family wasn't.
There are dragons there I need to get
back to.
Ah, sad, Sonny thought.
And then her brain added, in a voice much
like tsunamis, Sonny, by all the moons
quit feeling sorry for dragons who want
to abduct you and sell you off.
She glanced down at the 6 wickedly curved
claws that were carving gouges in the
sand beside her.
She had a bad feeling that Six Claws was
planning to fight, which couldn't
possibly go well for either him or
ostrich.
Six claws, she said firmly.
I said, make the trade.
My mother will understand.
She wanted to jump forward herself and
wrench the little dragonette out of their
claws.
Ostrich was trembling so badly that Sonny
could hear her teeth clicking together.
But Thorn, 6 Claws said, twisting around
to glance back at the flickering lights
by the pool.
Doesn't have to know, Atic said.
Tell her this one ran off.
Woke up, decided she didn't want a
criminal thug for a mother, and flew for
the hills.
Don't tell her that, Sonny protested
indignantly.
She smacked her tail against the sand.
That's so mean.
I wouldn't do that.
If he tells her the truth.
Thorn is likely to get herself killed
trying to rescue you, Atic said.
Would you prefer that?
No, but at least come up with something
believable, Sonny said spiritedly.
She looked up at 6 claws.
You can tell her I had to go back to my
friends to let them know they're safe
from the night wings.
Tell her I'll be back.
Six Claws stared at her, his face
unreadable.
Addicts flicked his tongue.
You won't be.
You don't know that.
Sonny said.
Now release ostrich and I'll go with
you.
She was starting to worry that the little
dragonette would have a heart attack and
collapse right there.
No, Atic said, she flies with us until we
have an hour's head start, and then I'll
send her back.
That made practical sense, although Sunny
didn't want to drag ostrich any further
into danger, but if they left ostrich
behind, Six Claws and the others would
chase them down before they could reach
Burns stronghold.
All right, then let's go.
She said.
Even more than ostrich.
She was worried about what 6 claws might
do.
She didn't think he'd stand a chance
against 7 big dragons.
And what if he is my father?
And ostrich is my half sister?
I don't want them to die before I get to
know them.
It wasn't until they were aloft, winging
north through the cold desert night
toward the stronghold of one of the most
dangerous dragons empirea, that the
thought occurred to Sonny, that she might
be the one who was about to die.
Part two, Burns Stronghold.
Chapter 9.
The outer walls of the palace were
dripping with blood.
Sonny had read the scrolls about the sand
wing stronghold, and she'd seen it from
afar, but nothing could have prepared her
for the smell of the decapitated dragon
heads that studded the top of the walls
or the gruesome stains on the stone below
them.
They were still more than a mile away
when the horrible rotting smell 1st
reached her, making her choke, and nearly
driving her out of the sky.
Attics caught her as she faltered toward
the sand.
Shallow breaths, he advised, you get used
to it.
Do you?
Really?
Sonny asked.
He shrugged, which, as far as she could
tell, meant, no.
Ostrich had been released during the
night, shooting one last terrified look
at Sonny before bolting back toward the
distant fires of the Scorpion Den.
Sonny thought that addicts had
deliberately freed the dragonette while
the den was still visible behind them.
Optimistically, she thought perhaps he
was concerned for ostrich's safety.
It seemed kind not to make her find her
way in total darkness.
She could almost hear her friends
laughing at her inner head.
That's right, sonny.
Your kidnapper is a real sweetheart.
He's handing you over to burn out of the
goodness of his heart, too.
But if he was doing this for his family
for someone he cared about.
Sonny glanced over the scarred dragon and
thought, there's more to his story.
There's always more to everyone's story.
If you bother to find out what it is.
The sun had cleared the mountains when
they came to the sentries, a pair of sand
wings carrying long spears, relentless
heat beat down from the cloudless sky
making the smell much worse.
Sonny's wings ached from flying so long
without stopping.
She could see the brownish yellow walls
of the stronghold up ahead, stained and
crusted with a dark red and black gore
that dripped from the grisly
decorations.
It was a vast palace.
Far larger than she had realized when
she'd seen it from a distance.
The ramparts seemed to stretch across the
horizon, and Sunny guessed that 2 or 3
scorpion dens could fit inside, or about
a 1000 of the caves she'd grown up in.
Hold it, said one of the sentries
swinging the spear toward them.
He squinted, Addicts?
Ho there, said addicts.
He waved a claw, and the dragons behind
him all paused, beating the air and
craning to see past his wings.
Picked up some friends somewhere, I see
said the sentry, half jokingly.
Are you invading or what's all this?
Brought a present for the queen, said
addicts.
He flicked his tail at Sonny, and she
hissed at him.
Recognize this one?
Both sentries drew in a quick breath.
From the party in the sky kingdom, said
one of them.
Scarlet was going to give her to Queen
Bern.
That's where I've seen addicts before
Sonny realized, bowing and scraping
behind burn as she examined me like a
deformed gemstone before he got his
scar.
And now I've found her, and I'm giving
her to the queen, said addicts smugly.
The sentry looked skeptically at their
entourage.
And you need 7 dragons to transport this
midget creature safely.
I'm terrifying when you get to know me.
Sonny volunteered.
She heard a couple of the dragons behind
her chuckle, but addicts shot them a
stern look, and they subsided.
Wait, said the other sentry.
Doesn't that mean she's, I mean, she's
one of yes, Atic said.
So stop delaying and let us through.
All right?
The sentries flapped aside, both of them
examining Sonny intently as she and her
escort flew past them.
In all of Sonny's fantasies about
fulfilling the prophecy and saving
Pyria.
She never imagined there'd be quite so
much staring.
And she certainly hadn't counted on
getting locked up as often as she already
had been.
As they swooped down toward the thick
forbidding walls of Burns stronghold
Sonny thought with a shudder that this
might be the worst prison so far.
Scarlet's palace had had gladiator fights
but at least she hadn't kept the
dismembered parts of her enemies on
display.
And it isn't exactly easy to cut off a
dragon's head.
Sonny remembered Starflight saying, even
if it's already dead.
They'd been reading in the steady cave
he'd rolled out the scroll and tapped the
drawing of the stronghold, you have to be
pretty brutal to get through the scales
and everything else.
Sunny also remembered that the outer
walls had been added by burn after Queen
Oasis died.
They look solid and thick and imposing.
But useless for keeping out dragons who
can fly.
The only creatures they'd really keep out
for certain are scavengers.
A scavenger had killed Burns' mother
after all.
Is Burne afraid of them?
From what Sonny had seen of her, it was
hard to imagine that Bern was afraid of
anything.
Attics led the way as they spiraled down
onto the hot white stones of an enormous
courtyard that encircled the old palace.
Long, squat buildings had been
constructed along the inner side of the
walls.
They appeared to be extra barracks for
soldiers.
Small gatherings of armed sand wings were
visible in each direction, either
cleaning weapons, sparring or sleeping.
In the center of the courtyard, opposite
the palace entrance, stood an odd kind of
monument, a tall black obelisk, surrounded
by a circle of sand wider than a large
dragon's wingspan.
Words were carved into the sides, with
the letters all painted in gold, but
Sonny couldn't read them from where she
was.
The old palace within the walls was a lot
more elegant than the parts Burne had
added.
There were slender towers, and windows as
tall as dragons, and high pavilion
landing platforms topped with domes and
spires.
Shapes were carved all over the stone
lizards, and desert birds and suns, mostly
as far as sunny could see at 1st glance.
It made the palace look for a moment as
though it was crawling with life, or
shimmering with heat, an unsettling
illusion of motion, probably intended to
make visitors uncomfortable.
The doors were open to the huge front
entrance of the palace, and Sonny
realized with a start that a dragon was
standing just on the edge of the sunlight
staring at her from the shadow.
Her heart plunged as she thought, burn.
And then the dragon moved, and she
glimpsed black diamond shapes on the
scales.
With an even stronger burst of fear, she
thought, blister, how could blister be
here?
And then the dragon stepped into the
light, and she realized he was male, and
not one of the 3 sandwing sisters after
all.
He still looked horribly like ballister
though.
He had the same narrow face and lidded
dark eyes, the same black patterns on his
pale yellow scales.
His poisonous tail barb slithered along
the stones behind him, and his sharp
claws made a tapping sound as he advanced
toward them.
He wore a cluster of keys and pouches and
bells, on chains around his neck that
clinked and jingled slightly as he
walked.
Some of them were plain iron, while
others flashed with jewels or gold
plating.
Addicts bowed his head respectfully.
Smolder, he said, I brought a gift for
Queen Burn.
I see, Smolder said.
Sonny felt a little better.
His voice didn't have the oozing, creeping
sinister quality of blister's voice.
He sounded just normal, like one of her
friends.
Who are you?
he asked her, and she liked that too, that
he spoke directly to her instead of over
her head, as though she was nothing but a
piece of treasure.
My name's Sonny, she answered.
Who are you?
I'm...
The brother.
Smolder said.
And something in his expression said he
had many thoughts about that, but
wouldn't risk going into detail.
Burns brother?
The only one?
Sonny asked.
Trying to remember what she'd read about
the Sandwing Royal Family.
There used to be 3 of us, but the other 2
made the wrong dragon's mad, he
grimaced.
The wrong dragons, meaning your sister's
sunny guest.
So you're on burn side?
I'm here, aren't I?
He said.
And it occurred to her that that wasn't
much of an enthusiastic yes.
Where is Queen Burn?
Addicts cut in abruptly.
She is not at home at the moment, Smolder
said.
He spread one wing and beckoned Sonny
toward the main entrance.
She's out looking for a certain quintet
of young dragons.
Sunny stopped, looking up at him with a
shiver.
If Bern was searching for her friends
instead of fighting battles, she must
really want to destroy them.
Wait, Atic said.
I want to see her.
I mean, this is my prisoner.
She's one of the ones in the prophecy.
I know.
I'll take it from here, Smolder said
firmly.
You can wait in the barracks until she
returns.
He nodded at the courtyard.
Don't worry, you'll get all your pardons
and your reinstatement.
He flared his wing across Denny's back
and ushered her forward again.
But my reward.
Addix's voice trailed off as Sonny and
Smolder stepped out of the bright
sunlight into the cool shadows of a vast
hall, big enough for a 100 dragons.
Far overhead, large fans shaped like
dragon wings beat the air, and Sonny
spotted a few small dragons pulling on
ropes to keep them moving.
Tapestries woven in blues and golds and
white covered the walls, echoing some of
the same patterns in the stonework
outside, and airy white curtains billowed
the long windows.
A heavy table ran down the middle of the
hall, loaded with food, and sunny harder
stomach grumble.
Take anything you like, Smolder said.
No, thank you.
Sonny answered politely.
It seemed unlikely that the entire table
of food was poisoned, but she didn't
intend to make killing her any easier
than it already would be.
She tilted her head to study the tapestry
closest to her, and realized that the odd
pattern of rust colored spots on it was
actually dried spatters of blood.
The food is for the soldiers, Smolders
said, sounding amused.
I promise it's safe to eat.
I'm not hungry, Sunny said.
Um, when do you think Burnham will be
back?
Smolder shifted his wings in a shrug.
I never know.
She prefers not to discuss her plans.
He lifted his claws and studied them
thoughtfully, shaking out sand that was
caught between the scales.
The real question is, what to do with
you?
On the one talent.
I assume she'd rather find you alive when
she gets back, so she can kill you, or
interrogate you and then kill you
herself.
On the other talent?
If I lock you up and you somehow escape
which I'm sure you'll try to do, I'll be
in far worse trouble than if I just kill
you right now, but on the 3rd talent, if
I successfully keep you captive, she
should be quite pleased.
It's a risk, though.
You're guaranteed not to escape if I kill
you.
But on the 4th talon, Sonny said
hurriedly.
How will Bern find my friends if she
can't ask me questions or use me as a
hostage?
Think about how valuable I am alive.
Hmm, Smolders said, with a little smile.
A tiny brown mouse crept out from under
the table and made a dash for the nearest
wall.
Smolder flicked his tail toward it, but
stopped at the last minute and let the
mouse vanish into one of the cracks.
He looked back at Sonny.
All right, you talked me into it.
You can live for now.
But I'd appreciate it if you'd keep your
escape attempts as feeble and ineffective
as possible.
He started toward a doorway at the far
end of the hall and Sonny followed
wondering if that was supposed to be
funny.
Smolder had this odd way of talking that
kind of made everything he said sound
like a joke, but then Sonny's life and
death didn't seem particularly hilarious
at least if you asked her.
There were 5 doors leading off the main
hall, plus a staircase that led up to a
balcony with 2 more doorways.
Sunny considered trying to memorize the
layout of the palace, but as soon as they
stepped through into the dark, winding
passage beyond.
She knew it would be hopeless.
The corridors of the old palace
crisscrossed and twisted almost as often
and confusingly as the streets of the
Scorpion Den, and they were sometimes
barely wide enough for 2 dragons to
squeeze past each other.
Short flights of steps kept taking them
up to new levels, and then down again, and
every other turn brought them to a spot
that looked exactly like something they'd
just passed.
Sonny almost wondered if Smolder was
messing with her head, except that he
seemed to be calculating something under
his breath, and barely paid attention to
her as they walked.
The stone floors were worn smooth with
the passage of many dragons, and the
walls and ceiling were flat, and usually
bare as well.
So Sonny felt as if she was walking
through long, narrow boxes.
It was eerie and claustrophobic, with no
space to fly, except for the occasional
glimpses of sunlight from the upper
levels, and 3 times they passed open
sunlit courtyards, where dragons were
lying with their wings spread wide
soaking in the heat.
I haven't seen any treasure.
Sunny realized.
No gold talon prints, no pearl studded
pools, not even anything like the
beautiful flowers that decorate the rain
wing village, unless you count the
tapestries.
I wonder if that's because the sand wing
treasure is really all gone.
Or perhaps sparkly things aren't burned
style.
She spotted a few carved statues of sand
wings here and there, most of them with
their wings tilted back, as if they were
about to take flight.
After their experience in the kingdom of
the sea.
Sonny had to admit that all statues made
her a bit nervous.
Any of them could be animas touched
enchanted to do something sinister.
I think I should put you in the weird
Ling collection.
Smolder said after a while, as if they'd
been discussing her placement the entire
walk.
It's as safe as the dungeon, but more
comfortable.
Also, more psychologically
destabilizing.
What?
Sonny said.
The idea that you might actually belong
somewhere like that?
Smolder said, it's driven a few dragons
insane.
Oh, Sunny said.
Sounds charming.
Smolder Rumble chuckled and turned a
corner, finally leading her out of the
labyrinth into one of the inner
courtyards.
This one was surrounded on 3 sides by
colonnades and balconies, with a pit of
sand in the middle.
Sunny slid her claws through the sand as
she followed him, thinking, what if this
is the last time I ever feel sand under
my talons?
The far wall of the courtyard was
curved.
And when Sonny looked up, she realized
that it was actually a windowless tower
of red sandstone soaring up toward the
sky.
It had grooves stretching the whole
length of it, like claw marks, and bands
of carvings, all of hideous dragon
faces.
There were no holes in the tower apart
from one door at the bottom, and Sonny
was seized with a fierce, desperate
longing to stay as far away from it as
possible.
But of course, this was where Smolder was
taking her, and of course, she had no
choice.
He unlocked the door with a plain silver
key from a chain around his neck, picked
up a bucket of water that had been
waiting outside, and led her into the
dark interior.
At 1st she thought her eyes were dazzled
by the sun, but as they adjusted, she
realized that the flashes of light around
her came from small mirrors embedded in
the walls, which caught the reflections
of bronze oil lamps, dangling at various
heights on long wires from the ceiling
far above.
A winding ramp led from the floor around
and around, up to the top of the tower.
And here was Burns notorious, disturbing
collection on display.
Spaced at intervals along the ramp were
the exhibits, Sonny caught glimpses of
claws, and misshapen tales, and thought
with a shudder.
I'm one of them now.
Right at the bottom of the ramp was a
wingless white dragon, its mouth twisted
open in a roar of fury.
Sonny jumped back, nearly knocking
smolder over before she realized the
dragon was dead.
And then that was actually worse, because
it clearly had been alive once, before
Bern slid it open, let the life pour out
and then stuffed it so she could display
it.
Is that going to be me?
Instead of saving the world, am I going
to end up stuffed and mounted on a
pedestal?
The fear that flooded through her made
her want to lie down, cover her head with
her wings and scream for days.
Trust in the prophecy.
She told herself fiercely.
I can't die here.
The dragons of Pyria are counting on me.
But Maro Seer's voice was still there
whispering, The prophecy isn't real.
And as hard as she tried, Sonny couldn't
quite find that faith that had once
chased out every fear.
The white dragon wasn't entirely wingless
she realized.
It had little stubs on its back that had
never grown into wings.
There was something eerily sleek and
snake like about it.
The most truly horrifying part was the
look on its face.
Isn't it creepy?
Smolder said in her ear, and she jumped
again.
Someone brought him to burn 10 years ago
claiming he was the forbidden offspring
of a sand wing and an ice wing, which is
the right thing to say to her. even if it
wasn't true, and who knows if it was
because she has, let's just say, some
pretty strong opinions about tribe purity
and not contaminating sand wing blood
with cross tribe breeding.
Oh, Sonny said faintly.
She thought of Starflight, who felt a
1000000 miles away right now.
On her list of reasons why they probably
wouldn't work out.
She hadn't thought to include
contaminating sandwing blood.
Smelder.
A voice bellowed suddenly from overhead.
I hear you down there.
If you don't bring me more water right
now, I swear, I will catch that scavenger
of yours and eat her.
Sonny's heart plunged through the floor.
She stared at smolder in shock.
She knew that voice.
Queen Scarlet of the Sky Wings was alive
and she was Burns prisoner too.
Chapter 10.
Queen Scarlet is here?
Sonny whispered to Smolder. everyone's
looking for her.
There are dragons who think we're holding
her captive.
He scratched his nose with one claw
inside.
My sister likes to keep a close eye on
her.
Things, he said.
The sky wing queen is a bit of a problem
right now, although mostly she's a
problem for me, the unlucky dragon
sitter.
He glanced up at the dark ceiling way
above them, then peered around the
floor.
Flower, he shouted suddenly.
Flower?
He lifted a small bell from around his
neck and rang it. letting the tinkling
noise echo across the dark space.
Something pitter pattered on the ramp
above them, and after a moment, Sonny
picked out a tiny figure scurrying down.
That's not a dragon, she thought with
surprise.
It was a scavenger, alive and upright and
chattering like a squirrel, bold as you
please, right in the middle of the sand
wing palace.
It jumped down the last level to the
floor and darted over to smolder.
For a grim, worrying moment, Sonny
expected him to rip the scavenger's head
off, or offer the whole creature to her
for dinner or something.
Instead, the sandwing prince rested his
front talons on the floor, and the
scavenger clambered right onto one of
them, sat down, and resumed chattering a
little louder, along with some vigorous
paw waving.
Oh my gosh, Sonny said, momentarily
distracted from Queen Scarlet.
It's so cute.
The scavenger looked kind of like a
bigger, less hairy version of the sloths
in the rainforest.
It ran on its back 2 legs with easy
balance, and its slender paws had no
claws on them.
A thatch of dark fur covered the top of
its head and ran down like a mane onto
its shoulders.
It had a square of white fabric tied
around itself that looked suspiciously as
though it had been hacked off one of the
main hall curtains, plus a sort of pouch
bag made of the same material.
I know, isn't she?
said Smolder.
That's what I've been saying.
I have to watch her carefully though.
Several dragons would be perfectly happy
to eat her if they caught her alone.
This is one place I figure she's safe.
He lifted her up to his snout, and the
scavenger leaned forward to bump noses
with him.
Where did you get her?
Sonny asked.
And why do you call her flower?
Smolder reached around and set this
scavenger on the back of his neck, where
she grabbed onto his spikes and balanced
as he started up the ramp.
Sonny trailed behind him, wondering if
this might be a good time to make a run
for it.
But she was pretty sure the tower door
had locked behind them.
We had some scavenger visitors about 20
years ago.
You may have heard about that.
Smolder said in his sarcastic voice.
This is the one who didn't escape. 20
years ago?
It took Sonny a moment to realize what he
must mean.
Wait, visitors plural?
Sonny asked.
I thought it was just one scavenger who
killed the queen and stole the treasure.
They passed a fish tank, glowing with a
greenish light that seemed to be coming
from the sea creatures themselves.
There were fish with bulging eyes and
extra flippers, seahorses with fangs
snails that oozed purple ichor, and an
octopus kind of thing with at least 20
arms that was busily occupied with
crushing up seashells and dropping them
into its black beak of a mouth.
Nope, said Smolder. 3 scavengers. 2
escaped with a treasure.
But we caught this one trying to hide
just outside the palace.
Burn was going to put her head on a spike
on the wall and eat the rest, but I
decided I wanted to keep her.
And at the time, I had other dragons to
back me up.
He took a deep breath and folded his
wings back into a tent over the scavenger
for a moment before tucking them into his
side again.
Blister argued that a scavenger head on a
spike wouldn't impress anyone.
In fact, it would just remind everyone of
mother's embarrassing death.
He went on.
Blaise thought flour was cued too, and
wanted to see if we could get another
scavenger and breed them to make more
pets.
And my brother said I should get to have
one thing I wanted, now that mother
wasn't around to keep making me unhappy.
He paused, and Sonny glanced up at him.
She got the feeling it wouldn't be a good
idea to ask any questions about Oasis.
Smolder!
Queen Scarlet bellowed again, and a burst
of fire lit out the tower from an upper
level.
Coming.
He called politely, then carried on
talking to Sonny as if there were really
no hurry at all.
Anyway, they voted to let me keep her.
And by now, burn is used to her.
I was going to call her stabby.
She was pretty fierce with this little
sword she was carrying before we took it
off her.
But then she found a tapestry with some
flowers on it and kept pointing to them
and then to herself.
So I think she wants me to call her
flower.
Although all her chattering noises sound
the same to me.
Sunny glanced at another glass exhibit
case as they walked by, and then really
wished she hadn't.
Inside were lots of parts of dragons
webbed sea wing talons, a few tongues
with 3 forks instead of two, half a wing
that was speckled purple and gray, unlike
any dragons she'd ever seen, a coil of
tail with strange lichens growing on it
and a number of oddly bent teeth and
claws.
She shuddered and dragged her focus back
to smolder and flower.
I've never heard of an animal choosing
its own name before. she said.
But then, I've never heard of anyone
keeping a scavenger as a pet either.
The only pets, she stopped, and clapped
her front talons over her mouth in
horror.
She'd nearly mentioned the rain wings and
their pet sloths, which could have given
away exactly where her friends were.
Stupid, stupid, stupid, sonny.
She scolded herself.
Be more careful about what you say.
The only pets smolder echoed, giving her
a curious look.
The only pets I've ever heard of are kept
by scavengers, Sonny said quickly.
Ah, yes, said Smoulder, and for the 1st
time, his voice was affectionate instead
of sardonic.
Flower likes mice, and she's always
feeding any birds that dare to come down
into the courtyards.
He lifted one of his claws, and the
scavenger patted it, as if to reassure
him she was still there.
Does she?
Understand you?
Sonny asked.
Of course not, but she's very clever, he
said.
I trained her to come when I ring this
bell, and I taught her to draw.
So she can draw pictures of anything she
needs.
She can draw?
Sonny said, fascinated.
She'd learned to write and draw with a
paintbrush that was more than half this
scavenger's thighs with what?
She made herself this adorable tiny
paintbrush.
She likes to make things.
Smolder said proudly.
She's also made all these cute little
costumes for herself.
Don't ask me why.
It's like how birds build nests, I think
all instinct, but really endearing.
Although Burne complains that she's worse
than moths, leaving holes in all our
curtains.
I'd call it resourceful, if anyone asked
me.
Resourceful?
I'll say, Sonny thought, remembering the
burnt out village as well.
She gave the scavenger an appraising look
and the scavenger stared back at her with
those dragon like brown eyes, deeper and
wiser than you'd expect.
What's going on in that tiny head?
Sonny wondered?
Her brain can't be any bigger than a
grapefruit, but maybe it works in
mysterious ways.
Maybe scavengers are cleverer than they
seem.
Another dragon suddenly loomed out of the
shadows, but Sonny was able to stop
herself from flinching away this time.
It was another stuffed specimen, this
time a mud wing, with striated red lines
along his outstretched wings.
He had no claws, no teeth, and a puzzled
expression.
Three moons, Sonny said.
What happened to him?
The seller said his egg was animus
touched, Smolder said, or rather, animus
cursed, some kind of vengeance thing
maybe?
Who would want a dragonette without claws
or teeth?
How could he live?
He was destined to end up here
eventually.
Like me.
Sonny thought despite herself.
Weird looking.
No other use for me.
Stop that.
You have a real destiny.
She tilted her head at the sad, stuffed
dragon.
Animus touched?
Could that be what happened to my egg?
Did some dragon do this to me before I
was hatched?
Deliberately?
But who?
And why?
Her mind flashed back to the questions
Thorn had asked the night wings.
She was looking for a night wing named
Stone Mover.
That sure sounded like an animus name.
What if he did something to my egg?
She was so preoccupied with this question
that when they came within sight of an
orange dragon, she assumed it was another
stuffed specimen and barely glanced at
it.
But then the dragon lunged at them with a
furious hiss, and smolder backed up in a
hurry, nearly knocking Sonny off the
winding ramp.
She dug her talons into the cracks in the
stone as her heart tried to leap out of
her chest.
Smolder.
Queen Scarlet hissed.
Finally.
Coils of smoke wreathed around her horns
but they couldn't hide what was
underneath, how the side of the sky
wing's face was melted into a hideous
dark mess, revealing a glimpse of her
jawbone underneath, and pulling one of
her yellow eyes down and out of
proportion with the rest of her face.
The rubies that had been embedded in her
scales, were gone above that eye, and so
were all her earlier adornments, the
golden chain mail, the medallions, the
rings on her claws, the rubies on her
wings, the only jewels left were the tiny
rubies above her good eye, which
glittered malevolently in the dim light.
The last time they'd been face to face, it
had been through the bars of a cage.
Sonny had been the prisoner, and Scarlett
had been one of the most beautiful
powerful dragons in Pyria.
No wonder she hates us, Sonny thought.
But glory did this to her to save the
rest of us.
We'd all be dead by now otherwise.
Here's your water, Smolder said, setting
the pail down on a claw scratched X on
the floor.
The queen snatched the pail, and Sonny
realized that the ex marked the very
limit of her reach.
Heavy chains kept her from moving any
farther.
On the other side of the X, littering the
floor around Scarlet's claws, were shards
of shattered glass, and puddles of
glowing green slime.
Here and there in the puddles lay the
corpses of peculiar insects.
Sonny could see oddly bulging
caterpillars, nine legged hairy spiders
and a bright blue dragonfly whose back
bristled with sharp needle spines.
When are you going to clean this up?
Scarlet snapped at smolder.
Her snout dripping as she came up for air
from the bucket.
There's slime on my beautiful tail, and I
keep finding bits of horrible bugs in
between my scales.
He snorted.
Perhaps, you should have thought of that
before smashing up your host's prized
collection.
He nodded at something lumpy, glittering
in the shadows behind her.
Burn is going to be especially upset
about her night wing.
They're not exactly easy to replace.
Sonny realized that Scarlet must have
been chained up near a stuffed night wing
which she had then clawed and shredded in
a fit of rage.
Sonny shuddered.
Scarlet lashed her tail.
I'll get to the rest of her toys too.
Once I'm free.
Scarlet.
Smolder said patiently.
We are not keeping you prisoner.
We're keeping you safe.
If you were in your own kingdom right now
you'd be dead.
You're in no condition to fight Ruby for
the throne.
That's Queen Scarlet to you.
She said fiercely.
Her gaze moved to Sonny, and then she
swiveled her head to stare with her good
eye.
Sonny took an involuntary step back
behind smolder.
I know her.
Scarlet growled.
That dragon is mine.
I am not, Sonny retorted.
I'm not anybody's.
I know where your rain wing friend is.
The queen snarled, pacing to the end of
her chains and glaring at Sonny.
As soon as I am free, she is dead.
Then I hope you stay locked in here
forever, Sonny snapped.
I have friends too.
Scarlet hissed.
I won't be here much longer.
Sonny looked up at Smolder, but his
expression was more tired than worried.
Come along, he said to Sonny.
We have to fly around her.
I know it's inconvenient, but I'm not
taking responsibility for unchaining
her.
Burn can move her when she gets here, if
she wants to.
He spread his wings and soared over
scarlet to the next level up, with flour
clinging tightly to his neck.
Sonny followed, a bit nervously, her
wings brushing the walls as she tried to
stay as far out of scarlet to reach as
possible.
They landed close to the top of the tower
where the light was dimmest, and Sonny
saw with a sinking heart that there were
chains just like scarlet's here, waiting
for her.
They lay collapsed on the ground like
dead snakeskins, and they clanked
horribly as smolder picked them up.
Sonny curled her tail around her talons
and looked at them for a moment, breathing
deeply to calm herself.
She looked up, and met Smolder's eyes.
Do I really have to stay here?
She asked quietly.
Smolder hesitated, with a chain draped
across his front talons.
Flower looked from him to Sonny, then
slipped off his back.
To Sonny's surprise, the little scavenger
came right up and patted Sonny on the
side of her neck.
She didn't have to be able to talk.
The gesture said clearly, don't worry
you'll be all right.
As clearly as if the scavenger had had a
tail to twine around Sonny's.
It's not like I have much choice.
Smolder said, I can't imagine what else
to do with you.
It's just...
Really dark, Sunny said.
Her scales were practically crying out
for the sunlight right beyond these walls
but more than that, the thing she
couldn't bring herself to say, was that
she could already tell that being in here
too long would carve out her soul, one
miserable moment at a time, until she'd
be as empty and hopeless as one of the
stuffed dragons.
I know, Smolders said.
And Sonny sensed the 1st hint of possible
compassion in his voice.
She wondered if it was partly because
Flower felt sorry for her.
Tell you what, he said after a pause.
I'll think about it tonight and see if I
can come up with something else
tomorrow.
If not, I'll take you out for a bit at
midday.
At least let you stretch your wings in
the sun.
As long as you promise not to escape.
Deal?
Sure, Sunny said.
Thank you.
It wasn't much, but it sounded like the
best she could hope for.
He clamped the chains around her ankles
locking them with another one of the keys
around his neck.
Sonny turned her head away, unwilling to
watch herself made a prisoner yet again
and spotted a large box tucked against
the wall not far away, at the very end of
the spiraling ramp.
What's that?
she asked.
Something new for Burns collection
Smolders said, glancing up at it.
The dragon who came by to sell it claims
it's something rare and priceless, and
that Byrne will definitely want it, but
that it might die as soon as we open the
box.
So I'm leaving it closed until burn gets
here, and she can decide what to do with
it.
You don't even know what it is?
Sonny asked.
What if it's an empty box?
Then I'll get yelled at, Smolder said, but
he'll get hunted down and killed, so I
doubt he'd risk it.
Dragons have tried to trick burn before
sowing odd animal parts together, dying
normal insects, strange colors, and it
has always proven to be a very bad idea.
Besides, he haggled so hard over the
price, he nearly refused to give it to
me.
It must be something pretty unusual.
Also, it keeps making this strange, high
pitched hissing noise.
He gave her a sharp look as he snapped
the last chain on, don't get any ideas
from Scarlet's bed behavior.
My sister has reasons to keep the sky
wing queen alive.
She has a lot more reasons to make you
dead.
So don't add to them.
Sonny nodded, not trusting herself to
speak.
This was the nightmare.
The situation she and her friends had
always feared.
She was in Burns clutches now, and she
couldn't think of any possible way she
might escape.
I'll be back before you know it, Smolders
said.
He dipped his wing toward the scavenger.
Up flower.
The little creature looked up at Sonny
with her thoughtful brown eyes, then
patted Sonny's side again and sat down.
Smolder tipped his head sideways and
peered at her.
Flower, come along.
He rang his bell and held out his claws.
Flowers shook her head firmly and put one
paw on one of Sonny's front talons.
She wants to stay with you, Smolder
said.
That's funny.
Flower is usually extremely cautious
around any dragon who's not me.
He narrowed his eyes at Sonny.
If I leave her with you, will you be
careful with her?
No knocking her off the ramp, no stepping
on her, indefinitely, no eating her.
I wouldn't eat her, Sonny protested.
I barely even like meat, except sometimes
a lizard here or there, and I think she's
being really sweet.
There was something comforting about the
idea of having someone with her in this
dark tower, apart from Queen Scarlet, even
if it was a scavenger.
Whoa, Smolder said fidgeting.
If you promise to be careful.
Flower, are you sure?
Flower kept her paw unsunny, and stared
back at him without moving.
All right, he sighed.
See you soon.
He lifted off the edge and flew in a
gentle spiral down to the bottom of the
tower.
Sonny leaned out, and saw the shaft of
sunlight that spilled into the room as he
opened the door, and then saw it
disappear again as the door slammed
behind him.
The weight around her ankles felt
suddenly even heavier.
She rested her head on her front talons
with a sigh, curling her tail in close.
Flower immediately tucked herself into
the curve of sunny side, reached into her
bag, and pulled out a scrap of scroll
paper and a lumpy stick of charcoal.
In the dim light, she started to sketch
and sunny, peering over her shoulder, saw
a dragon's face appearing in rapid
strokes.
Her face, in fact.
That's amazing, Seni said.
How could an animal create art like
that?
Flower glanced up and did something with
her mouth that looked exactly like a
dragon smile.
Sunny found herself smiling back, despite
her fear and her worry.
At least she wasn't alone.
Little Sandwing.
Queen Scarlet's voice hissed softly from
below her.
Using burn is what you have to worry
about right now.
She's not.
I am.
I'll be free soon.
Free.
And I'll be coming for all my enemies.
Think about that while you try to fall
asleep.
What I'm going to do to your friends when
I get my claws on them.
How messy and thrilling it's going to
be.
Sunny closed her eyes and covered her
ears, but the whispers continued inside
her head.
What if burn comes tomorrow?
What if she kills me right away?
What if I never get to find out the truth
about my mother and my egg?
Never get to spend more time with her.
What if the prophecy is fake?
What if I really have no destiny?
Other than to end up here.
What if nobody is going to end the war or
save the world?
And worst of all, what if I never see my
friends again?
Chapter 11.
Somehow, eventually, Sonny slept, which
she knew because she woke up to find
Flower tugging gently on her tail and
smolder, unlocking her chains.
She sat up slowly and stretched her wings
which still ached from all the flying
she'd done in the last several days.
What's happening?
She asked Smolder.
Oh, I thought we'd go for a walk, he said
wryly.
Sonny squinted at him.
Are you joking?
Or is that just your voice?
Can other dragons tell when you're
joking?
Because I can't figure it out.
He threw back his head and laughed.
I have heard that before, he admitted.
There was someone who used to tease me
about it.
She told me she was going to assume that
everything I said was a joke. since that
would simplify things.
You can do that too, if you like.
All right, Sonny said.
Smolder wasn't exactly the sinister
prison guard she would have expected from
Burns brother.
She much preferred this oddness instead
even when it wasn't settling.
The last chain clattered to the floor, and
Smolder held out one talon, so Flower
could climb up onto his back again.
Make sure to steer clear of scarlet.
He reminded Sonny, who didn't need
reminding.
She's in a foul mood today.
I heard that.
Scarlet roared.
Smolder rolled his eyes at Sonny and dove
off the edge.
She followed, catching a glimpse of the
smoking orange queen as they whisked
past.
Scarlet sent a blast of flames into the
air right behind them.
Sunny felt the heat crackle along the
scales of her tail, and saw Flower press
herself closer to Smolder's back.
Outside, it was early morning.
Barely sunrise, then he realized.
Smolder didn't leave me locked up very
long.
He didn't even wait until midday to come
get me.
Maybe he's secretly kinder than he wants
me to think.
The light slanted low across the
courtyard, and small brown birds hopped
along the top of the walls, gossiping
cheerily.
The air smelled like roasting lizards, and
the sand was still cool under her claws
as she followed, smoldered to an archway
on the left.
Where are we going?
She asked.
I have been investigating a mystery for
the last 20 years or so, said Smoulder.
Occasionally, I ask other dragons what
they think.
Invariably, they disappoint me, but you
seem unusual, more unusual than most, so
I figured I'd try again.
Ever hopeful.
That's me. 20 years?
Sonny said.
I hope it's not a very urgent mystery.
Smolder chuckled, then said, well, it
rather is, but it's been resolutely
impossible to solve nonetheless.
He led the way through a room of pillars
all of them carved with swirls that
looked like dragon tails and into a long
hallway lined with sparkling rust colored
tiles in a spiraling pattern.
Sunny brushed one of the tiles with her
wing, thinking that it was the 1st
beautiful thing she'd seen in this
palace.
The hallway slanted down and down and
down until Sonny was sure they were
underground, and finally it ended in a
room with 4 locked doors.
Smolder walked to each door and opened
them with large brass keys from around
his neck, revealing 4 rooms of roughly
equal size, with thick stone walls and
plain gray stone floors.
All of them were completely empty.
The rumors about the sand wing treasure
were never entirely accurate, he said as
he did this, twisting the keys in his
claws.
We were very wealthy, yes.
But we weren't quite stupid enough to
keep it all in one place.
Almost that stupid, but not quite.
We kept only our most prized possessions
in our treasure rooms, along with a
backup stash of rubies, diamonds, and
gold in case we ever needed it.
So it wasn't our entire wealth, or a
palace full of treasure that went
missing.
Only the contents of these 4 rooms, but
they contained quite a lot.
He held up a talent for flour to climb
onto, then set her carefully on the floor
in front of the treasure rooms.
She looked even smaller next to the
massive rooms.
Sonny realized the flower was probably
small enough to squeeze under the doors.
The scavenger put her tiny paws on her
hips, tossed her head for her back, and
looked for all the world like she was
bored at this dragon game.
So here's what I'd like to know.
Smolder said, how did 3 scavengers about
this size?
Two, actually, once they lost this one
managed to carry 4 rooms worth of
treasure off into the desert.
Sunny studied the little scavenger in
front of her.
It was actually a very good question.
Flour was only about as tall as a full
grown dragon's head.
She had no wings, and miniature
practically useless pause.
Well, maybe not that useless, she thought
remembering the sketch of her face from
the night before.
Could they have built something to carry
it?
she said, crouching to examine flowers
pause, the scavenger squeaked at her.
I saw the ruins of one of their villages
on my way here.
Their dens look like real houses, and
there was an iron bell in the wreckage
too.
So they're good at making things.
Maybe they made some kind of wagon to
carry it in.
A wagon, would have left tracks across
the sand, Smolder pointed out.
The only tracks we found were hoofprints
3 horses galloping flat out.
You tell me how they could do that, with
more than 2 bags of gold on their backs
let alone all of this.
Oh, you found prints?
Sonny said, stepping into the 1st room
and peering around.
Didn't you follow them?
She moved to the 2nd room, which was the
same as the first, except perhaps with a
little more sand on the floor.
Follow them, said Smolder.
If only we'd thought of that.
Aha, Sonny said.
That was definitely sarcasm.
He gave her a crooked smile.
Well, look, there was a lot of confusion
when we 1st found the queen's body.
We all heard her roaring in the middle of
the night.
It must have woken every dragon for
miles.
That's what brought us outside the palace
thinking something terrible had
happened.
All we found at 1st was mother, lying
there, dead.
Had one of our daughters killed her.
Why not in a proper duel?
Who else would dare kill the sand wing
queen?
Who else could?
And why wouldn't they admit to it?
The 1st clue we found was this little
creature, trying to hide by burying
herself in a dune.
She was injured and, of course, had no
treasure on her, apart from a cute little
claw sword thing.
Smolder reached into the bag around his
neck, and somewhat startlingly produced a
banana.
He handed it to Flower, who sat down and
began peeling it with expert little
twitches of her slender paws.
That's when we realized scavengers were
involved.
So we knew they must have come here to
steal treasure.
Burn was so furious.
We finally found the horse tracks, Smolder
went on, but they had at least 2 hours
head start by then.
We caught up shortly before they reached
their forest home, and then Byrne decided
we should let them reach their forest
home.
His eyes were dark, watching flower.
Once they let us ride to it.
We burned it to the ground.
Yikes.
Sonny said.
That's a lot of scavengers to wipe out
just because 3 of them did something
stupid.
Burn said we had to stamp out the vermin
before they began to think they could do
something like that again, Smolder
pointed out, as if he guessed what she
was thinking.
So after you burned the village.
We searched for the treasure in the
ashes.
No sign of it anywhere.
Not a single jewel or gold nugget.
We tried hunting down a few scavengers
who'd escaped the fire, but some of them
must have slipped through our claws, and
one of those must have the treasure, even
now, 20 years later.
Sunny started pacing from room to room.
Something wasn't right about this story.
A lot of things weren't quite right about
this story.
That much treasure?
How could it disappear into thin air?
How could scavengers make it disappear
into thin air?
She stopped and looked down at flower
again.
The brown eyes looked back at her
curiously.
Are you sure the scavengers killed Queen
Oasis?
Sonny asked.
It wasn't maybe just really bad luck that
they were there at the same time as some
other killer?
Smolder nodded.
I thought of that, but it was a scavenger
sized spear in mother's eye, and this
part is a little weird.
They cut off her tail barb and took it
with them.
We never found that either, but there was
a trail of venom drops and dragon blood
beside the horse tracks.
Sonny wrangled our snout.
Why would they do that?
Why do scavengers do any of the
inexplicable things they do?
Smolder tossed another banana to flower.
Sonny wonder if the scavenger had any
idea they were talking about her.
Hmm, she said, studying the rooms.
Now that she was here, looking at the
space, and at a scavenger at the same
time, the original story sounded more and
more ludicrous, it was crazy enough that
scavengers had managed to kill a dragon
queen, but then they also stole all her
treasure without getting caught and
eaten?
Her wings twitched with a sudden idea.
Maybe the question wasn't, how did they
transport all that treasure?
Maybe the real question was, what else
could have happened to it?
Wait, she said.
When did you check these rooms?
When did you see how much was missing?
Oh.
Smolder breathed a plume of smoke and
squinted at her.
When we returned from burning the den.
I remember flying back and thinking that
the scavengers couldn't have gotten much
if we couldn't find any trace of it.
And then Byrne led the way down here to
do an inventory, and we found everything
gone.
I never figured out how flower unlocked
the doors either.
Sunny lashed her tail so hard.
It smacked into one of the doors, sending
a shiver of pain through her scales.
That's it then, she said excitedly.
Someone else took it while you were out
hunting the scavengers.
Who didn't go with you to chase the
scavengers and burn the den?
Lots of dragons, Smolder said.
He frowned thoughtfully at the open
doors.
Blister and Blaze both stayed here.
Then, of course, it was one of them, Sunny
said.
The scavengers probably didn't even get
anything before Oasis caught them.
They don't have your treasure.
One of your sisters does.
Smolder was already shaking his head.
No, he said, no, that's not possible.
It must be scavengers, or this war would
be over already.
Sonny met Flower's eyes, then looked back
at him.
Over?
How do you figure?
There's, I'm not supposed to talk about
it.
You can't do that.
Sonny said, flaring her wings.
You can't tell me half of something and
then not tell me the rest.
He wrinkled a snout, looking faintly
amused again.
You are my prisoner, remember?
He said.
It's a royal sand wing secret, I'm
afraid.
Oh, aren't you fancy?
Sonny said.
All right, I'll figure it out.
Don't do that, Smolder said, with a hint
of alarm in his voice.
A royal secret involving your treasure
that would end at the war if someone had
their claws on it already.
Oh, Sonny said.
I bet it's something animas touched.
Is that it?
That must be it.
Ooh, is it some kind of enchanted
treasure that's like, oh, if you're
holding this, you're the sand wing
queen.
So a scavenger must have it, because if a
dragon had it, she'd be queen and the war
would be over.
Interesting.
Smolders stared at her with unfathomable
black eyes for a long moment.
That's not it?
Sonny finally asked nervously.
That was unsettling, he said.
It was just logic, Sonny said.
My friend Starfight would have figured it
out faster.
She stopped and curled her tail around
her talons.
If only Starflight were here, or Clay, or
any of them.
Well, he said, I suppose you're likely to
be dead by the end of the week anyway.
Just remember that if you tell anybody
we'll have to kill them too.
Aren't you cheerful?
Sonny said crossly.
What is it anyway?
The Sandwing Scepter?
He shook his head.
I'm not telling you that.
The Lazulite Dragon?
Sonny racked her brain, trying to
remember what famous pieces of treasure
were mentioned in the scrolls.
Stop guessing.
The Eye of Onyx.
Sonny said.
And from his expression, she knew that
was it.
His face wasn't quite the emotionless
mask the blisters was.
Well, that's why the scavengers must have
the treasure.
Smolder said quickly, as if hoping she
hadn't noticed.
If Booster or Blaze had it, one of them
would be queen instead of hiding in
another kingdom.
If any sandwing had it.
They'd be ruling the desert already.
Sonny shrugged.
So the scavengers managed to get
something and happened to get the most
important thing.
Someone else still took the rest of it.
I bet you anything.
Hmm.
Smolder narrowed his eyes.
Smoke billowed from his nose, writhing
around his horns.
In that case, we'd still have to find the
scavengers and what they stole.
Sunny didn't have an answer for that.
She had a feeling find the scavengers
meant burn down more dens, and it made
her feel sorry for the squishy little
creatures, especially if they were all as
cute and clever as flower.
Smolder, a voice called smolder.
Talons scrabbled on stone as the
snubnosed sandwing came pelting down the
long sloping hall.
He started calling out as he ran toward
them, his voice traveling across the
distance.
We're under attack.
He yelled.
Help!
Turtle Sandstorm is already dead.
No one knows what to do.
It's chaos.
We're all going to die.
He skidded the last several steps toward
them, and nearly tumbled into one of the
treasure rooms.
Sunny jumped out of the way of his
flailing tail.
Who's attacking?
Smolder said sharply, grabbing the
messenger and steering him back up the
hallway with one brisk motion, ice wings
or sea wings?
I don't know.
It happened so fast.
It was like they rose straight out of the
sand.
Maybe it's Queen Scarlet's friends, Sonny
said anxiously, scooping up flour and
hurrying behind them.
Smolder gave her a look, as if he'd
forgotten she was there.
Remember?
She said someone was coming to rescue
her.
What if this is them?
The messenger let out a horrified
squeak.
Then we're definitely all going to die.
Stop that.
Smolder said, giving him a quick shake.
There are enough sandwing soldiers here
to fight off any invasion.
He held out his talons and Sonny passed
flour to him.
Smolder said his pet gently in a side
room with no windows.
Stay, he said sternly, pointing a claw at
the little scavenger.
Flower put her paws on her hips and
chattered something indignant at him, but
he ignored her and swept on up the
corridor.
I don't have time to lock you up again
right now, Smolder said to Sonny, but I'm
still watching you.
If you try to escape while we're fighting
you'll end up back in that tower, and
you're never coming out again.
I get it.
You're menacing.
Sunny shouted at him.
Now, what are you going to do about Queen
Scarlet?
You should send more guards to watch her
right now.
She's the one you should worry about
escaping.
At least I won't murder everyone on my
way out.
Smolders, stern expression wavered for a
moment as he looked down at her.
I think I should be offended that you're
obviously more afraid of my prisoner than
you are of me, he said.
But I suppose I'll worry about that
later.
You, he shouted, at a pair of guards
running by.
Find 4 more soldiers and take them to
guard Burns Weirdling Tower with your
lives.
You understand?
They nodded, about faced, and took off
toward the tower.
Thank you, Sunny said, more than a little
surprised that he'd actually listened to
her.
Now they could hear roars and snarls and
the clash of claws outside, along with
the sound of shouts and running talons
all over the palace.
Watch her, Smolder said to the messenger
pointing to Sonny.
An unearthly shriek tore through the
morning air, and smolder hurtled into the
nearest courtyard, then up into the air.
The black diamonds on his wings flared
like crows taking flight as he soared
higher, then banked sideways and shot
toward the outer wall.
Sonny ran into the courtyard behind him
and spread her wings.
Wait!
the messenger protested.
Where do you think you're going?
To see what's happening, Sunny said, I
want to know who's winning, don't you?
Because if it's Scarlet's friends, then I
need to get out of here.
No matter what smolder thinks I've
promised him.
Um, the messenger said.
Twisting his tail between his talons, but
I'm not sure.
Come on.
Sonny launched herself into the sky and
heard the scramble of his claws behind
her as he followed.
She aimed for the highest point of the
palace that she could see, a spire with
an open pavilion platform at the top.
The corners of the roof were carved like
dragon wings open in flight, and wind
chimes on each side glittered and
whispered in the faint breeze.
In a few moments, her claws touched down
on white stone, and she took a fluttering
step for balance, spread out before her
to the south of the stronghold was the
battle.
Sonny squinted, her eyes adjusting to the
light of the rising sun as she searched
for distinctive colors, perhaps the blues
and greens of sea wings, or the white and
pale blue of ice wings, as smolder
expected, or perhaps the reds and oranges
of loyal sky wings come to rescue their
queen.
There is something strange about this
battle.
Sunny couldn't see any unusual colors
down there, nothing but the tan, pale
yellow, and off-white scales of sand
wings.
Sand wings fighting sand wings.
Was it blisters army attacking?
But it didn't look like a hole invading
force.
In fact, if Sonny had to guess, she'd say
there were only about 30 dragons
attacking the stronghold, against about
100 defenders.
And then she saw a flash of sunlight
catch on a gold arm bracelet, and she
leaned forward with a gasp.
That's Thorn.
Now that she'd spotted her, it was
unmistakable, the wiry, pale yellow
dragon was deep in the thick of the
fighting, slashing at sandwing soldiers
with her talons, and stabbing her tail as
she rose into the air, then dropped below
2 warriors, then hurtled up to smash into
another.
Sonny scanned the rest of the attackers
and picked out 6 claws, then Kibley
fighting as close to Thorn as they
could.
This wasn't another army, or one of the
sandwing sisters.
The stronghold was being attacked by the
outlaws.
My mother came to get me, Sonny thought
her scales humming with joy.
Six claws must have told her the truth
instead of the lie we came up with.
But then she took another look at the
battle, and her heart sank.
Five sand wing soldiers lay dead on the
sand, but the outlaws were still
outnumbered almost 4 to one.
Smolder with shouting orders as he shoved
soldiers into formations, tightening the
defenses, so a bristling wall of spears
was ready to ram the scattered attacking
dragons.
One wave of sand wings piled into 6 claws
who staggered back with a roar, losing
height, so his bloodied tail swept the
sand below him.
Sunny watched in horror, as 7 soldiers
encircled Thorn, cutting her off from her
allies.
The outlaws came to rescue me, and it's
going to get them all killed.
Chapter 12.
Sunny paced from one end of the pavilion
to the other, her heart pounding.
Her eyes hurt from staring at the battle
as if she'd been trying to change the
outcome with the power of her eyeballs.
Don't die trying to rescue me.
Please, please, please don't die.
It was almost killing her to watch as her
mother dodged flames and claws and deadly
tails.
A giant sand wing slammed into Thorn's
chest and tried to drive her down onto
the sand.
Thorn slashed at his snout and darted
away, but another soldier attacked from
behind her, stabbing his venomous tail
down toward the center of her spine.
Sunny shrieked with fear, and the
messenger behind her nearly fell off the
spire.
What?
He yelped.
What is it?
Who's dead?
At the last moment, Kibli barreled into
the soldier and knocked him away.
Sonny wasn't sure her mother had even
noticed how close that had been, she's
not careful enough, Sonny thought
anxiously, standing up on her back legs
and flapping her wings.
What's happening?
The messenger said plaintively, craning
to see around her.
It's my mother, Sonny said.
She's here to rescue me.
The sandwing scrunged his snout at her.
Are you sure?
That doesn't sound like any mother I
know.
Well, that's just sad, Sonny said. trying
to listen to him and watch the battle at
the same time.
Even your own mother?
The other dragon made a noise that
sounded half chuckle, half snort.
My parents sent me to Burns Army to
toughen me up.
They said this way, I'd end up as brave
as a real soldier or else dead, and
either of those would be an improvement.
What's your name?
Sonny asked.
Down below in the battle, 6 claws seized
2 soldiers and smashed their heads
together, then whirled to slash another
one's throat with his tail.
The messenger hesitated.
Am I allowed to tell you that?
Why not?
My name is Sonny.
I know, he said.
All right.
My name is Camel.
Sonny flicked her wings open and shut
brushing against the wind chimes.
Camels seemed like a normal nervous
dragon, someone she could be friends with
in another life.
Maybe he'd listen to reason.
Do you have any dragonettes?
she asked.
Not yet, but my partner and I have 3 eggs
hatching next month, he said proudly.
So you can be a different kind of parent
than yours were, Sonny said, the kind
that takes care of his dragonettes, the
kind who would attack a stronghold full
of soldiers to protect them?
She added hopefully.
She didn't know much about parents in
general, but she knew what she would do
if she had dragonettes, and any of them
were in danger.
Hmm, said Camel, looking even more
anxious.
He swished his tail and gazed down at the
battle.
The blood on the sand, the sprawled
bodies, the flashing claws.
Maybe this isn't the right approach for
this dragon, Sonny thought.
All I'm saying, she continued, is that I
can't stand here and watch my mother die
trying to save me.
Please, please let me go help her.
She leaned toward the wide open blue sky
imagining how she would dive in and drag
all the soldiers away from Thorn.
Oh, Camel said uncomfortably.
Oh, no, no, I can't do that.
If Burne finds out, she might take my
eggs away.
That wouldn't be good parenting, would
it?
Sunny sighed.
I guess not, she admitted fairly.
But maybe I can stop the fighting, so
nobody else has to die.
Camel hesitated again, looking down at
the battle, and Sonny wondered if his
partner was one of the ones out there
fighting.
How?
He asked.
I mean, you're not.
He glanced at her harmless tale and away
again quickly.
Not exactly scary, not exactly big, not
even a little bit useful.
He was kind of right.
What did she think she could really do if
she joined in?
Is there another way to stop them?
A sunny way?
She stared down at the battling dragons
racking her brain, and then something
moved under the sand.
Sunny leaned forward, staring intently.
Not far from one of the fallen soldiers, a
patch of sand rippled as though something
were buried underneath it.
Something or someone.
Sunny had the horrible feeling for a
moment, that the ghost of Queen Oasis
herself, was about to come bursting out
of the sand to attack the dragons.
But the head that popped out was not as
sand wings.
It was followed by shoulders and wings
that glowed coppery orange in the bright
sunlight.
The dragon wriggled the rest of the way
free, and began swarming across the sand
toward the stronghold walls.
Sonny gasped.
She recognized those scales.
Like hers, they were a color unique to
only one dragon in Pyria, as far as
anyone knew.
It was peril.
It had to be, Peril, the Sky Wing who had
helped them escape from Queen Scarlet's
palace.
Well, 1st she had pretended to help them
escape, And then she'd betrayed them, and
then she'd nearly killed Clay, but in the
end, she'd done the right thing.
Although sometimes it was hard to
remember that.
But without her, the dragonettes and
Kestrel might have been trapped in the
Sky Palace until Scarlet figured out a
thrilling death for each of them.
Sunny's heart sank, thinking of Kestrel
and how she'd died under blisters, claws
and the kingdom of the sea.
How would peril react to the news of her
mother's death?
But more important, what was she doing
here?
And why was she clearly trying to sneak
into the palace?
Peril reached the walls and glanced back
at the battle, but the fighting was too
fierce for anyone to notice her.
She spread her wings and launched herself
over the wall, landed neatly in the
courtyard, and darted into the palace.
Sonny inhaled sharply as an awful thought
struck her.
Surely not.
Did you see that orange dragon?
She asked Camel.
I have to follow her.
Come with me, so it's not like I'm
escaping from you.
Um, camel said.
But wait, shouldn't I?
Sonny didn't hear the end of that
sentence.
She was already in the air, and winging
toward the courtyard that held the weird
link tower, she could see the dark red
crown of it looming over the rooftops.
Her talons came down with a thump in the
sand pit, and she glanced around at the
tower door, but it was still closed, and
she hoped, locked.
Not that a lock on a wooden door would be
much use at stopping peril into her fiery
talons.
The 6 sand winged soldiers arranged
outside wouldn't be able to stop her
either.
They looked curiously at Sonny, but held
their positions.
Camel flapped down behind her and landed
on the wall, as far from the tower as he
could get without losing sight of Sonny.
She waited a moment, trying to calm down
her heartbeat.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe peril isn't here to rescue
Scarlet.
I mean, why would she?
But then she heard talons clattering over
stone, and peril came running into the
courtyard.
The Sky Wing skidded to a stop when she
saw Sonny.
Her flame blue eyes went wide through the
wisps of smoke that rose from her
scales.
Hi, peril, Sonny said, hoping she sounded
more friendly than terrified, peril
twitched nervously.
She said not to let you guys stop me.
Peril glanced around the courtyard
peering into the shadows with a hopeful
expression, is, um, I mean, are you all
here?
No, sorry, Sonny said.
She knew who peril was really looking
for.
Clay's not here, but he worries about
you.
Did he say that?
Parel asked.
She touched her front talons together, the
same way she had after Clay had taken her
talons in his when they had said goodbye
Sonny remembered.
That he worries about me?
What did he say exactly?
Um, Sonny said, trying to remember the
last time Clay had mentioned peril.
They'd been a little busy lately, escaping
from the sea wings and invading the night
wing island and running from volcanoes
but he had said something about her one
night in the rainforest after Starflight
had disappeared.
Clay and Sonny had been curled together
near Kinkaju, the little rain wing
dragonette who'd been injured in the
contest where glory became queen.
She was asleep, and it was Sonny's turn
to watch her.
Clay was keeping her company.
He said, I wonder where peril is right
now, Sonny said.
I hope she's all right.
There's that new queen in the Sky
Kingdom.
And I said, Ruby, and he said, right
her.
I hope she's taking care of peril and not
making her fight anymore.
Carol waited for a moment and then said
That's it?
Well, then his stomach started growling
and he had to go look for something to
eat, Sonny said, but he wants to see you
again.
I'm sure of it.
I bet you've had all kinds of adventures
together, peril said, a little bitterly.
It's been really scary, Sonny said.
It seems like every dragon we meet either
wants to kill us or lock us up.
She glanced around at the tower inside.
Case in point.
Peril looked down at her talons, the
sunlight gleamed on the gold veins in her
wings.
What about you?
Sonny asked.
Um, have you...
She didn't know how to finish that
sentence.
Have you stopped killing dragons?
Have you found a safe way to live around
others?
Have you by any chance come here to
rescue a dragon who really wants to kill
me?
The answer is, she's not, Pearl said
sharply.
Ruby is not taking care of me.
She ordered me out of the Sky Kingdom as
soon as she took over.
She said if I ever set claws in the sky
palace again, she'd find a way to kill me
and I'd better believe it.
She said I was dangerous and
unpredictable, and she didn't want me
near her subjects.
Her voice broke, and she coughed, ducking
under one wing.
Oh, peril.
I'm so sorry, Sonny said.
Don't feel sorry for me.
Peril lifted her head and frowned.
I am dangerous.
That's like the whole entire point of
me.
That's not true.
Sonny said.
You can be whatever you want to be.
I mean, I could say, well, I have no barb
on my tail.
I guess I'm just harmless and useless and
should sit in the corner covering my head
whenever there's a fight.
But I don't want to be useless, and I'm
not going to do that.
Not if dragons I care about are in
danger.
She glanced at the sky. wondering
anxiously how the battle was going, and
whether Thorn was still all right.
Um, speaking of which, I could really use
your help right now.
Peril shook herself.
Copper scales flashing.
I can't help you.
I have to rescue Scarlett while everyone
is distracted with that battle outside.
Sunny felt a cold, shiver fear run
through her scales.
She had still hoped maybe that wasn't why
peril was here.
But why?
she cried.
I've been waiting days for a chance like
this, when I could get her out without
fighting anyone, Pearl said.
So you can tell Clay, I'm trying really
hard not to kill anyone.
She hesitated, looking at the guards
behind Sunny, between her and the tower.
I'm trying, she said again.
No, I mean, why would you help her?
Sonny asked.
After everything she did to you.
The breeze picked up into a quiet wind
scattering grains of sand across Sonny's
claws, and bringing her the heavy, scaly
smell of fear from the sand wings behind
her, they hadn't moved from their spots
but they stood tensed and ready with
their weapons.
Sonny guessed at least some of them knew
who Perel was from visits to the sky
kingdom with burn.
I know Scarlet's not perfect, Peril
said.
Understatement of the year, Sonny
thought.
But she didn't kill me when she could
have.
When anyone else would have, when I was a
dragonette, and she didn't throw me out
she treated me like I was special.
She lied to you, Sonny pointed out, about
Kestrel, and about the black rocks she
said you had to eat so you could never
leave her, she was using you, not taking
care of you.
She took better care of me than my mother
did.
Peril flared.
And from what I saw of her, Kestrel isn't
the nicest dragon in the world either
right?
She hesitated again.
Then said tentatively, have you seen
Kestrel?
Do you know where she is?
I wonder, I've been wondering if I should
have gone with her when she asked me to.
Sonny's heart sank.
She didn't want to deliver this news.
But I can't lie to her.
Literally 20 seconds after I just accused
Scarlet of so much lying.
I don't know how she'll react, but I have
to tell her the truth.
Peril, she said softly.
I'm really sorry, but Kestrel's dead.
Carol stared at her for a long moment, her
odd eyes glowing blue and black, and then
slowly, like a mountain crumbling, she
collapsed to the stones and covered her
face with her talons.
No, no, no, she said.
I sent her away.
I said we'd find each other again.
I know.
Sonny said, wishing she could wrap her
wings around peril the way Clay had, but
Clay was the only dragon she knew who
could touch peril without dying.
I know.
Oh, peril, I'm so sorry.
Listen, she said desperately.
Her anxiety about the battle outside, was
making every scale on her wings feel like
jumping off and flying away.
Listen, I'm like you.
I thought my mother didn't want me either
but I just found out that's not true.
Just like you.
My mother wanted me, the way Kestrel
wanted you, except I'm so afraid she's
going to die before I get to know her.
And that's why I need your help.
Please, peril.
She's attacking the palace right now
trying to rescue me, and you could save
her.
I'm sorry.
I know it's awful to throw all that at
you at once, but I really need you.
Peril pressed her talons into the stone
and sat up.
She took a deep breath, exhaling smoke
and a cloud around her wings.
Finally, she looked down at Sonny, with
an expression as though she was trying to
find any small part of herself in Sonny's
eyes.
Tell me more, she said.
Her legs trembled, as if they might not
keep holding her up, but she listened
intently as Sonny explained about Thorn
and the outlaws.
All right, she said at last when Sonny
paused for breath.
I'll stop the battle.
But then I'm setting Scarlet free, so
don't try to get in my way.
But that's the deal, Pearl said
stubbornly.
I've already lost one mother.
Scarlet is what's left, so she's the best
I can do.
Sonny curled her tail around her talons.
She was very worried about this plan, but
there wasn't time to keep arguing.
And what could she say?
Having no mother would be better than
having that mother.
What did she know about it, really?
Thank you, she said instead.
I trust you, she added.
She wasn't sure she really did, but she
wanted to.
I know you can do it without hurting
anyone.
Um, Camel said, and happily from above
them.
I really think I shouldn't let this
happen.
You can't stop her, Sonny said to him, as
peril shot into the sky.
And your job is to watch me.
That all Smolder said.
I'm not going anywhere.
See?
Well, except back up to the pavilion to
watch.
Come on.
She followed Peril up and watched the
shimmering copper scales flash toward the
battle outside the walls.
From the high pavilion, Sonny could see 2
more corpses lying below the battle, but
after a heart stopping moment, she
realized that neither one was thorn or 6
claws, she stared at the battle intently
until she finally spotted her mother
grappling claw to claw with a soldier.
Smolder was there too, not far from
Kibley, shouting orders and darting
around the formations.
He was one of the 1st to spot peril as
she approached.
Sonny could tell because he froze very
suddenly, staring in the direction of the
sky wing.
The soldiers around him turned to see
what he was looking at.
Three of them took one look at peril
shrieked, and fled into the desert. their
shadows flickering rapidly across the
dunes, until they vanished in the
direction of the scorpion den, Sonny
guessed they had been to Burns Palace, and
seen what peril could do.
She'd never seen what peril could do, not
to another dragon.
She'd been trapped in her cage while all
her friends were in the arena at the Sky
Palace, so she'd missed all the
fighting.
But Claya told her about it.
The melting scales, the black talon
prints burning into her victims, the
scorched smell, and it sounded
terrifying.
She hoped she wasn't about to see it
now.
Gradually, the outlaws stopped fighting
too, and fell back. until there was a
wide circle of dragons around the clear
space of sky where peril hovered.
Sonny's sharp ears caught some of what
peril was saying to them, but not all of
it.
Something about taking over the fortress
something else about surrendering.
She saw a smolder start forward, as if he
were going to argue with peril.
Oh, please don't, she thought anxiously.
It was strange to admit it, but she
actually liked him.
She definitely didn't want him to die, or
get his scales melted.
But several sandwing soldiers grabbed him
and pulled him back, shaking their heads
and pointing to the smoke.
There rose clearly from Pearl's wings.
Thorn said something, imperil gestured
toward the stronghold.
With a sort of grateful bow, Thorn flew
past her, followed by all her outlaws.
Hooray!
Sonny cried, flapping her wings with
excitement.
Brace you to the courtyard, camel.
She leaped off the tower and soared down
toward the stones, where she'd 1st landed
in the stronghold.
Thorn had just sat down and was turning
to issue orders to her dragons, when
Sunny catapulted to a stop in front of
her, and threw her wings around her
mother.
By all the snakes, her mother yelped
Sonny.
She lifted Sonny off her talons and spun
her around.
Never mind.
She shouted at the outlaws over Sonny's
shoulder.
Found her.
Sonny felt giddy and weightless, like a
tent with its pegs pulled up, flying
loose in a sandstorm.
You came to get me.
She said breathlessly.
Of course I did, Beetle, her mother said
stepping back and looking around.
Six claws told me everything.
I spent 7 years looking for you.
I wasn't about to lose you after only 10
minutes of conversation.
She grinned with all her teeth.
Besides, I've always wanted to invade
Burns stronghold.
I take it she is not here.
Luckily, Sonny said, I doubt she'd have
surrendered as graciously as Smolder
did.
We should do the tour quick before she
comes back then.
Thorn said cheerfully, as if she hadn't
been scales away from death a few moments
earlier.
What do you think that is?
She put one wing over Sonny's shoulders
and steered her toward the black obelisk
Sonny had noticed before.
Their claws sank into the sand around the
monument, which was white and clean, as
if it were swept every day.
As they got closer.
Sonny could read the words carved and
painted in gold on the side of the
pillar.
Here lies Queen Oasis, mother of Queen
Bern.
Her bones now belong to the sands of
time.
Yikes, Sonny said, suddenly realizing
what it meant, she scrambled sideways, off
the sand, pulling Thorn along with her.
Queen Oasis is buried under there, right
below us.
Probably where she died, Thorn guessed.
Looking up at the walls Burne had added
after she took over.
This would have been right outside the
original palace, where the scavengers
attacked her.
She peered at the inscription again.
That's more poetic than I would have
expected from Bern.
Very impressive.
The sound of wing beats overhead made
them both look up as the sand wing
soldiers came flapping back into the
courtyard.
With them were peril and smolder, who
spiraled down to land beside Thorn.
I'm going to be in so much trouble.
Smolder said to Sonny with a sigh.
Burn might actually kill me this time.
Losing you and Scarlet in one fill
swoop.
That's probably worse than anything my
brothers ever did.
I'm sorry, Sonny said.
Sorry enough to stay our prisoner, Smolder
asked hopefully.
Who is this hilarious dragon?
Thorn asked her.
This is Smolder, Burns brother, Sonny
said.
Smolder, this is Thorn, my mother.
She's the leader of the out claws, and
this is peril.
Thorn half bowed again to peril.
Our lucky angel, she said.
Pearl nodded, looking a bit
uncomfortable.
Sonny guessed she wasn't used to
gratitude, and that she'd certainly never
been called an angel before.
Perhaps I should move to the scorpion
den.
Smolder said gloomily.
Thorn, was it?
Hmm.
He gave her a thoughtful look, as if he'd
heard of her somewhere before.
I need to kill the dragon who betrayed me
Thorn announced.
His name is Addix.
Please produce him.
Oh no, don't.
Sonny blurted.
I mean, don't kill him, please.
He only, he just, he had his reasons, and
look, I'm all right, aren't I?
Her mother tilted her head at Sonny
looking surprised and concerned.
Don't you want to punish him?
Aren't you angry?
Am I?
Sunny glanced at the barracks of soldiers
beyond Smolder.
Somewhere in there, addicts had been
reunited with his family, and somewhere
in there, he was probably hiding right
now, knowing what might happen to him
next.
Punishing him won't make anything better
Sonny said.
It'll probably just make someone else
angry and vengeful and lead to more awful
things.
I'm really all right.
Let's leave him and get out of here.
Thorn brushed Sonny's wing with hers and
nodded.
All right, if that's what you want.
Mercy is yours to grant.
I have one more question for this dragon
though.
She turned to smolder.
You've lived here a long time.
Can you tell me if you have any night
wing prisoners?
Smolder shook his head.
No, I'm afraid my sister doesn't keep
most of her prisoners.
Alive, I mean.
You had one night wing, though, Sonny
offered.
In Burns collection, didn't you?
The stuffed one that Scarlet destroyed?
What?
Thorn said.
Her wings went very still.
What do you mean?
Stuffed.
It's sort of a hobby for burn.
Smolder said, with an embarrassed
expression.
If she finds a dragon she wants for her
collection, she'll usually kill him and
stuff him herself.
I know.
It sounds pretty horrible.
It is horrible, Sonny told him bluntly.
It's one of the worst things I've ever
heard, ever.
Where?
Thorn said to smolder, in a cold voice.
Show me this murdered night wing.
Right now.
Chapter 13.
As Smolder led them through the labyrinth
of the palace again, Sonny noticed that
Parel kept her wings pressed as close to
her body as she could.
Afraid of setting something on fire, she
guessed, feeling sorry for the sky wing.
Mother, she whispered.
Why do we care about this night wing?
Hopefully, we don't.
Her mother answered cryptically.
They crossed the sand pit to the tower.
The 6 sand wing guards jumped aside with
a relieved expression when they saw
smolder.
Sonny heard peril take a deep breath.
Time for her to face Scarlet.
She realized.
And us too, since we'll have to get past
her to see the night wing.
They could hear Scarlet roaring as soon
as they opened the door.
Who's down there?
Smolder, I hear your stupid keys
clanking.
If you.
She cut off abruptly, and Sonny looked
up.
She could see yellow eyes glinting
through the smoke, as Scarlet peered down
at them.
The silence that followed as they wound
their way up the ramp was more unsettling
than the shouting.
What was Scarlet thinking?
What would she do when they reached her?
The former queen of the sky wings sat
with her tail curled around her talons
glaring fiercely at them.
Smolder stopped in front of her, but she
ignored him, fixing her malevolent gaze
on peril instead.
What are you doing?
She growled.
Rescuing you?
Pearl muttered, staying behind, Sonny.
This is an odd way to go about it.
Scarlet swept your tail in an arc
knocking glass shards over the edge to
shatter on the floor far below.
Such an interesting group of friends
you've brought with you.
Where is the night wing?
Thorn demanded.
Smolder pointed wordlessly at the shadowy
lumps behind Scarlet.
Don't go near her.
Sonny warned her mother, as Thorn started
forward.
She's really dangerous.
That's true.
Scarlet hissed.
Thorn paused, then faced the prisoner.
Show me the Nightwing's face.
Looking for someone?
Scarlett said, sounding amused.
Now, why would I help you?
Because I'm telling you to, Peril
interjected abruptly.
Do it if you want me to get you out of
here.
Queen Scarlet rose up on her back legs
spreading her wings so she looked
majestically powerful despite her
disfigurement.
It sounds to me, like you've forgotten
who your queen is.
She snarled at peril.
It sounds to me like you forgot who has
the scale melting talons here.
Pearl snapped back.
Scarlet hissed, and more smoke poured
from her snout to envelop her horns.
Don't you threaten me.
I don't take orders from anyone.
Then you can rot here, Pearl said hotly
turning around so fast.
The Sonny had to jump out of the way of
her tail.
She'd only taken 3 steps when Scarlet
cried, wait.
Wait.
Peril stopped, breathing deeply. but
didn't turn around.
The night wing.
Thorn said, with quiet authority
pointing.
Scarlet growled deep in her throat, then
picked up something from behind her, and
threw it as hard as she could at
smolder.
He caught it, and then tossed it to Thorn
with a yelp.
It was the night wing's head.
Thorn looked down at the dragon head in
her talons with an expression of pure
horror, but it quickly melted into
relief.
She gently set the head down on the stone
and stepped back.
Is, is everything?
Sonny asked.
A stranger, Thorn said.
Nothing to worry about.
She rubbed her forearms.
Let's go back to the sunshine.
Peril.
Scarlet said, a low rumble in her
throat.
Where are you going?
I'll be back to let you out once Sonny is
far away from here, peril said, looking
over her shoulder at the imprisoned
queen.
Don't try to argue with me.
I know what you want to do to her, and I
won't let you.
She set off down the ramp as fast as she
could, and Sonny followed, feeling
grateful and anxious in equal parts.
I know what you want, and it's not going
to work.
Scarlett shouted after her.
He's never going to love you.
You can keep trying to save his friends
but no one will ever love you except me.
I'm the only one who accepts you the way
you are.
You'll always be a monster to everyone
else.
Peril threw the door open, leaving scorch
marks on the wood, and dashed out of the
tower.
Sonny caught up to her outside, where the
sky wing was curled up small in the
middle of the sand, rubbing her claws
together.
She's wrong, Sonny said to peril's back.
She hesitated.
Glancing back at Smolder and Thorn as
Smolder relocked the tower.
Don't let her make you hate yourself.
I can't promise you anything about clay
but I think, I mean, if I know him at all
I can tell you the way to his heart is by
helping his friends.
Although, I cannot picture him with you.
The kindest dragon empyrea, and someone
who's killed, who knows how many
dragons?
How could you ever deserve him?
She didn't say any of that out loud
though?
If she was being perfectly honest, she'd
have to admit to herself that she'd never
think anyone was worthy of clay.
Peril sniffed and then nodded.
And I don't think you're a monster, Sonny
added, thinking, you've been monstrous
but maybe you can change.
I have to believe you can change.
You're a dragon, like anyone else.
You can remake yourself however you want
to.
Peril snorted.
Easy for you to say.
Not really, Sonny thought.
My friends think they know who I am too
no matter how much I try to show them.
I' more than that.
You don't have to set scarlet free.
Sonny reminded her.
You could come with me instead.
Pearl tossed her head, folding her wings
back.
Don't worry about me.
I'm fine.
Which means I don't want any more
sympathy right now, Sonny thought.
She turned back toward the tower as her
mother and smolder approached.
I think we have something that belongs to
you.
Smolder was saying to Thorn.
If you don't mind waiting.
I'll go check Burns library.
Thorn gave him a suspicious look, and he
chuckled.
Or you can come along, but it's rather a
mess is all.
He glanced at peril.
Lots of papers everywhere.
I'll wait here.
Parel said sadly.
She drew her tail in close to herself
leaving a moon shaped swath in the sand.
Lead on, Thorn said to Smolder.
Sonny joined them, and they headed into
yet another twisting set of corridors.
These ones lined with flickering diamond
shaped mirrors that caught the sunlight
from small holes in the roof and walls.
Mother, Sonny said as they walked.
What's going on?
I thought you hated Night Wings.
Why did you think you might care about
that one?
Thorn stopped and waited until Smolder
was far ahead, picking through his keys
with a bright, brassy jingling sound.
I don't hate all night wings.
Thorn said quietly.
I mean, I'm not fond of them, and I don't
trust them as a rule, but I'm looking for
one in particular, an animus dragon named
Stone Mover.
Because he did something to my egg?
Sonny guessed.
Is that why?
Not exactly.
Well, I guess in a manner of speaking
Thorn said.
Glancing up at the skylights with an odd
half smile, Sonny stared at her, she had
a pretty good idea what that look meant.
He isn't, she whispered.
You wondered why you don't look like a
regular sandwing, Thorn said.
So, it's because Sonny's claws trembled
with shock of all the theories she'd ever
imagined.
Yes, this one had crossed her mind, but
of all the tribes she'd wondered about
never this one.
Never, never this one.
Yes, sonny, said Thorn.
Her voice falling like drops of water
into the stillness between them.
It's because you're half night wing.
Chapter 14.
But the night wings are awful, Sonny
cried.
I don't want to be anything like them.
So don't be. her mother said.
She started walking again, and Sunny
hurried to keep up.
No one's making you be awful.
And didn't you say you're friends with
one?
Starflight is different, Sonny said.
So was Stone Mover, said Thorn.
At least, I thought so.
It's been a long time.
Sunny's scales seemed suddenly too large
or maybe too small.
Everything felt wrong, as if she was
wearing someone else's wings.
Half night wing by all the moons.
Please tell me about him.
I want to know everything.
I mean, I think I do.
Do I?
How did you fall in love with a night
wing of all the tribes?
Thorn folded her wings back and ducked
under a low archway.
Eight years ago, I met a dragon, out in
the sands not far from here, actually.
His scales were like the desert sky at
night, and he was always nervous in a
sweet, worried way, like no other dragon
I'd ever met.
Remember, I grew up in the Scorpion Den.
There you have to be tough and cutthroat
all the time, or you're dead.
I liked the way Stone Mover fidgeted, and
the questions he was always asking.
And I liked that he wasn't pretending to
be scarier and meaner than he really
was.
It was just himself, and he was very
smart.
He sounds a lot like Starflight, Sonny
said.
She wondered if that meant anything.
If she was like her mother, did that mean
she would end up in love with a dragon
who was like her father?
Was that her type?
Was that her destiny?
Her and Starflight together?
She had many thoughts about that, but no
idea how to sort them out.
He gave me this, Thorn said, touching the
moonstone around her neck.
I asked him why he was here, and he said
he was trying to save his tribe.
I liked that too.
She went on.
He really, really cared about saving his
tribe.
I'd never seen loyalty before because
there was nothing like the outlaws back
then, not in the scorpion den.
He said he was doing something essential
that nobody else could do.
Oh, Sonny gasped.
The tunnels.
He must be the animus who built the
tunnels.
Thorn looked at her curiously.
You know about that?
Wait, tunnels, as in multiple tunnels?
Two of them, Sonny said.
As far as I know, those are the only ones
I've been through anyway.
You have been around, Thorn said. with a
hint of admiration in her voice.
I only knew about one tunnel.
He was here every day for a while, trying
to pick the right spot and working of the
energy to create it.
So I kept coming back to bother him.
And finally, I guess he fell for me too.
Who wouldn't, Sonny thought.
But, she said, didn't anyone care that
you were from 2 different tribes?
If Bern thinks it's wrong?
I'm guessing she's not the only dragon
who feels that way.
What if it were me and Starflight?
She realized she didn't really know what
dragons in the outside world thought
about intertribe relationships.
It had never come up in any scrolls, and
the guardians under the mountain had
never talked about it, but they never
talked about families or love at all.
No one knew, except Six Claws and my
friend Armadillo, Thorn admitted.
Stone Mover was my secret.
Of course, I didn't have a whole lot of
other friends back then.
If they knew now, Sonny said slowly, would
you lose the outlaws?
Thorn stepped in front of Sonny?
and put up her wings to stop her in
place.
Listen to me.
She said.
I don't tell everyone about my past
because I like my privacy, and there
isn't much of that when you lead a band
of outlaws.
But I'm not ashamed of you, or of where
you came from.
If other dragons have a problem with it
that's their problem.
It's not against the law to be with a
dragon from another tribe.
It just hardly ever happens, that's all.
Usually each tribe keeps to itself, which
makes you rare, but not illegal, or taboo
or horrifying, or anything like that.
Don't ever let any dragon make you feel
like you shouldn't exist.
You understand?
Sonny nodded.
She thought Dragon should be allowed to
love whoever they fell in love with, but
at the same time, she couldn't help
thinking, look at me though.
No natural weapons, no powers, scales
that mean I don't fit into any tribe.
I'm kind of a walking argument for
avoiding intertribe relationships, aren't
I?
Her mother looked as if she could read
Sonny's thoughts on her face.
She brushed her front talons over Sunny's
head and horns and cupped her snout.
Sonny, you are perfect.
The way you are.
So what happened to stone mover.
Sonny asked.
She didn't want to think about her weird
looks anymore, at least for a little
while.
He disappeared.
Thorn let go of her, and blew out a
breath with hints of fire in it.
I came back one day and he was gone.
Morrow seer was there instead.
He said it was my fault, whatever had
happened to Stone Mover, and never to
look for him or try to speak to him
again.
Pompous, worm faced, snobhead camel
turd.
Mother!
Sonny said, nearly shocked into
laughing.
That's what he was, Thorn growled.
Morrow seer.
I dream about wringing his neck all the
time.
She sighed, and her claws scratched
across the stone as if they were
frustrated too.
We didn't like him much either, Sonny
admitted.
So that was it?
Didn't you ever see Stone Mover again?
No, but of course that wasn't it.
Thorn said, turning to walk on again.
I looked for him everywhere.
I went through the tunnel, but it led to
the rainforest. isn't that odd?
I thought it would lead to their hidden
kingdom, but no, I searched the whole
place, but there were no night wings
there.
Only some very sweet, rather bewildered
rain wings.
Very confusing.
I never understood how that would save
his tribe.
I'll explain it to you later, Sonny
said.
Did he know about me?
No.
Thorn said.
We were fighting, a little bit, when I
found out I was with Egg, I planned to
tell him once he apologized, but he'd
gotten very strange and cold, so maybe he
wasn't going to.
That's what happens to animus dragons
Sonny said.
Whenever they use their magic, they lose
a little bit of their soul or something
like that.
They get meaner and colder and a little
more crazy.
From what I've heard anyway.
Thorn stopped again and stared down at
her, worry filling her dark eyes.
I didn't know that.
That's what was happening to him?
I wonder if he knew.
He must have known.
Why didn't he tell me?
She flicked her tail thoughtfully
furrowing her brow.
So then, Sonny prompted her.
So then I was afraid the night wings
would come after your egg if they knew
about it.
That's why I buried it in the desert.
That's why I asked Dune to help me look
after it.
I had no idea he was with the talons of
peace.
And even if I had known, I wouldn't have
guessed that would make him steal my
egg.
Would you?
Here we are, Smolder called, and they
realized he'd stopped in the tunnel ahead
next to a dark wooden door.
He selected a delicate gold key and
unlocked it, then had to shove hard to
get the door open.
Sonny realized why as they squeezed
inside behind him.
He wasn't kidding about the mess, piles
of scrolls had toppled over to block the
door, and there were papers and glass
paper weights, and small carved onyx
lizards scattered all across the small
square room.
If there had ever been any system of
organization, there was no way to tell
now.
This is not Burn's favorite place, Smolder
said, stepping around the piles gingerly
and still knocking over several more with
his tail.
I can't guarantee she's ever been in here
in fact, and our mother wasn't the most
organized dragon in the world either.
I tried once to put it all in order.
As you can see, I was wildly successful.
Hmm, Sonny and Thorn said, the same non
committal noise at the same time.
Smolder gave them an amused look.
And while I was organizing, I discovered
that we have a system for intercepting
messages that go across the kingdom of
sand.
Well, Queen Oasis had a system.
Again, I'm not sure Byrne knows or cares
about it, but we have dragons who pose as
messengers, and other dragons who are
instructed to attack real messengers, and
so a fair percentage of the letters sent
in our realm come here instead.
Presumably so that we can scan them for
hints of rebellion, or assassination
schemes, which, clearly, we are keeping
careful track of around here.
He waved his claws at the disaster strewn
library.
I guess that's how it seems like my
mother always knew everything.
I keep it going in case we need it one
day, even though no one has time to
review all this.
In any case, I thought I saw one marked
Thorn, which I carefully filed somewhere
useful, I'm sure.
Smolder dug his talent into a pile of
scrolls, and Sonny realized with a start
that there was a desk there, underneath
the drifts of paper.
Help me look, he suggested.
Thorn and Sonny waded in and began
peering at scrolls and mini scrolls, and
thick papyrus notes with scrawls of black
ink on them, Sonny's wings toppled over a
stack of thin, scraped stone tablets that
turned out to have messages carved on
them as well.
Are you sure about this?
Thorn asked.
After they'd searched for a few minutes.
Maybe you remembered wrong.
Or maybe it wasn't anything important.
Maybe.
Smolder said, lifting a bowl filled with
dried leaves and peering at the papers
underneath.
I'm pretty sure I remember it looked
important though.
Sonny wished she had time to read
everything in here, or a way to bring it
all back to Starflight.
So many scrolls.
So many scraps of dragons, lives, moments
and messages, caught in between scent and
never received.
I wonder if the world would be different
if some of these letters had gotten to
where they were supposed to go.
Claws scrabbled on the stone in the hall
outside, and smolder went to the doorway
to poke his head out.
What is it?
He called, as 2 guards rushed by.
A wing approaching from the northeast.
One of them called back, might be
burned.
Sonny's head snapped up, and she flapped
her wings at her mother.
We have to get out of here.
Oh, great moons, at last, Smolder said.
Sorry about this, you two.
Sorry about what?
Sonny asked, turning toward him just as
he jumped out of the room and slammed the
door on them.
No, Thorn roared.
Sonny leaped over the scrolls and grabbed
the door handle, but she could hear the
key turning in the lock already.
She threw herself against the wood, but
it was solid and only bruised her
shoulder.
Smolder, don't do this.
She shouted through the door.
Don't give us to burn.
Please.
I can't let you waltz out of here, he
said.
His voice faint and muffled.
I saw what Byrne did to my brothers.
I know how to stay alive.
Like I said, I'm sorry.
Sonny pounded on the door.
At least give us a fair chance to fight
her.
Smolder.
But she could hear his tail slithering
away into the palace.
He was gone.
Leaving her and her mother locked in
trapped, and waiting for burn.
Chapter 15.
Thorn picked up an onyx lizard and hurled
it across the library.
Blood, red eggs, and fireballs, she
shouted.
I'm going to flay that dragon alive.
Won't your out claws save us?
Sonny asked, waiting through the papers
to the desk.
She ran her talons all over it, but there
were no drawers, and no place for a
hidden extra key.
If they're smart, they'll fly for the
hills the moment they hear the burn is
coming. said Thorn.
They'll expect me to run and meet them at
the Scorpion Den.
Act smart.
Stay alive, stick together but don't be
an idiot.
Those are our basic rules.
She picked up a scroll and ripped it
furiously down the middle.
All right, so we do that, Sonny said.
We figure a way out of here.
I know we can.
She twisted to look around the library
searching for anything she could use to
pick the lock.
Not that she had any idea how to do that
but she'd read about someone doing it in
a scroll once.
There were no windows, so no way to call
out for help.
The light came from a small chandelier of
hanging oil lamps high above them.
The ceiling was tall, but made of solid
stone.
The door was the only way out.
What about your sky wing friend, Thorn
said.
Might she guess what's happened and come
looking for us?
Sonny shifted her wings and shook her
head.
I doubt it.
If she hears burn is coming, I'm sure
she'll free Scarlet and run too.
She stepped back and stared at the door.
The wooden door.
But if she could burn down this door, we
should be able to do the same thing
right?
Wait.
Thorn cried, as Sonny drew in a breath.
She spread her claws at the mess around
them.
It's not safe.
If you set the door on fire, it could
spread to the papers in here, the whole
room could be in flames in a heartbeat
and we'd burn to death before we made it
out.
That was a horribly good point.
Sonny guessed that that had occurred to
smolder as well.
He was more cunning than he looked.
Perhaps as cunning as blister.
He'd also cleverly found a way to
separate them from peril.
Well, Sonny said.
I suspect I'd rather burn to death than
end up stuffed in burns collection, but I
think I can do it carefully.
I'm pretty good at aiming small flames.
Let me try, all right?
Thorn hesitated, then nodded.
Sonny was pleased.
She was pretty sure her friends wouldn't
have trusted her to do anything this
risky.
She swept papers away from the door with
her tail until it was surrounded by a
half circle of clear stone floor.
Then she leaned forward, opened her mouth
and hissed, letting fire build up in the
back of her throat.
It felt fierce and hot, like she'd
swallowed the sun, and she never liked
using it for long.
Aiming carefully.
She breathed a small jet of flame in an
arc around the lock.
The thick wood turned black where the
fire touched it, and smoke curled from
the gash left behind.
Nothing burst into flames.
Not yet, anyway.
Sunny did the same thing again, trying to
trace the same line over and over, 4 more
times, until she saw a glimmer of light
on the other side.
She jammed her claws into the blackened
wood and twisted them around, digging and
slashing, until the whole lock came loose
and thumped into her talons.
I did it, she whispered to her mother, as
the door swung a few inches open.
Sonny turned and found her mother holding
a folded square of thick papyrus paper
with the word thorn, scrawled across the
front in black ink.
There is a letter for me, said Thorn
curiously.
He wasn't lying about that part.
How odd.
She flipped it over and opened it.
Mother, we really have to go, Sonny said
but her voice trailed off as she saw the
expression on her mother's face.
Mother?
Thorn?
It's from him, Thorn said, glancing up at
Sonny.
From your father.
Listen, dearest Thorn.
I can't keep doing this.
I can't use my powers for the night wings
any longer, or I'll lose myself
completely.
So I'm running away, and I'd like you to
come too.
Meet me at Jade Mountain.
I'll wait for you as long as I have to.
I love you.
Stone mover.
Her voice trailed off.
Jade Mountain, Sonny cried.
There's supposed to be a dragon who lives
there.
Maybe it's Stone Mover.
Oh, maybe he's still waiting for you
after all these years.
Isn't that romantic?
That frog faced blob of camel spit.
Thorn shouted abruptly, making Sonny
jump.
She crumpled the paper in her front
talons, threw it to the ground, and
smashed it with one of her feet, all
these years.
He's alive.
He's not a prisoner.
And he's known exactly where I was this
whole time, but he never once came to
look for me or tried to contact me.
Well, Sonny faltered.
Maybe he thought you got his letter, but
didn't want to be with him.
So send me another letter, Thorn cried.
Try a little harder.
Don't be at your boa head.
She stomped past Sonny and into the hall
checking in both directions.
Come on, let's run for it.
I saw a courtyard this way.
They bolted down the long stone corridor
and swerved to the right at the end.
Sunny could see a patch of blue sky up
ahead beyond a wall of dark red columns.
She started to unfold her wings as she
ran.
The prisoners.
A voice shouted behind her.
Prisoners escaping.
Sonny's heart plunged.
Uh-oh, Thorn muttered.
They skidded up to the courtyard and
found several sandwing soldiers milling
about there, preparing their weapons as
if they were getting ready for battle.
The soldiers all turned and stared at
them.
Go!
Thorn shouted, flaring her wings.
Startled, Sunny hurtled into the sky.
One of the soldiers roared and leaped
after her.
She felt the wind of his talons slashing
just short of her tail.
She twisted away and looked back in time
to see her mother blast the soldier in
the face with a burst of flames.
He shrieked and plummeted to the ground.
The other soldiers were slower to react
and faster to catch on fire, when Thorn
blasted the rest of them as well.
She soared up out of the shrieking and
mayhem and smoke, and circled Sonny.
What are you waiting for?
She called.
Thorn banked around and headed for the
main courtyard.
Sonny followed close behind her.
I hope they'll be all right, Sonny said
glancing back at the flames.
I hope we'll be all right, Thorn said.
Oh, no.
Moon liquors.
Six claws, you idiot.
She swerved suddenly sideways, and Sonny
saw what she was aiming for, a cluster of
battling sand wings on the stones below
with 6 Claws and Kibley in the center of
it.
She heard 6 claws roar.
Where is Thorn?
And then Thorn snatched a loose brick
from the nearest wall and lobbed it past
his head, clocking the dragon behind him
in the snout.
I'm right here, snails for brains.
She bellowed.
Let's go.
Without a moment's hesitation, Six Claws
and Kibli and 20 other dragons leaped
aloft, kicking off their opponents, and
swinging their deadly tails wildly behind
them.
Where the others, Thorn called to 6 claws
as they all veered south, flying as fast
as they could.
Fled already.
Six claws said tersely, cowards.
Following orders, Thorn reminded him, as
you should have done, we weren't leaving
without you, he growled.
Yeah, Kibley piped up.
I didn't trust that smolder dragon.
I knew there'd be trouble.
Didn't I say so?
Can't trust a royal.
That's what I always say.
Because you've met so many royal dragons
in your life, have you?
Six claws demanded.
Thorn shook her head, but didn't argue
saving their breath for flying.
Sunny risked a glance back, but nobody
was chasing them yet.
She guessed the stronghold was
disorganized chaos right now, with no one
sure whether they were still in a
surrendered stalemate, whether peril was
still lurking around to kill them all
whether it was really burn on her way, or
whether Smolder was still in charge.
She could see the wing of dragons in the
distance, approaching the stronghold, too
close, only minutes away from finding out
what had happened, and she was pretty
sure the hulking shape in the lead was
truly burn.
Her eyes scanned the horizon, had peril
made it out safely?
Or would peril always be safe, because no
one could get near her with talons like
hers.
She spotted 2 small shapes winging away
to the north, glinting orange and gold in
the sunlight.
Peril and Queen Scarlet, now free.
Sonny shuddered.
If Queen Scarlet really did know where
the dragonets were, how long did they
have before she came for them?
What kind of revenge had she planned?
All those nights in the horrible tower?
A feeling of dread climbed into her chest
and squeezed.
For a moment, she couldn't breathe.
Clay, tsunami, glory, and poor wounded
Starflight.
Mother, she called, beating her wings to
catch up to Thorn.
Thorn grinned toothily at her.
I've been called lots of things in my
life, but that's the strangest and the
best at the same time.
Sonny brushed her mother's wingtip with
her own.
I have to return to my friends, she
said.
I need to warn them.
I'm afraid they're in danger, now that
Queen Scarlet is free.
Probably, Thorn agreed.
She hesitated.
Couldn't I send a messenger instead?
I wanted to bring you back to the
Scorpion Den.
I still haven't heard about your life, and
what you've been doing all these years.
I know, Sunny said.
She wished she could stay with her mother
with those warm, strong wings close by to
keep her safe.
For the 1st time, she could imagine life
without the prophecy, she could be a
normal dragon, living in the scorpion den
with her mother, instead of worrying
about saving the whole world.
But prophecy or not, her friends were her
real life, her whole life, she couldn't
leave them in danger.
But this is really important.
I'll come back to you soon, or you could
come with me?
Thorn sighed and shook her head.
There might be retaliation from the
stronghold.
I have to fortify the den, prepare my
dragons, make sure everyone's safe.
That was true.
Thorn had risked a lot, bringing her out
claws into this dangerous rescue
mission.
Sonny touched her wing to begin.
Thank you for coming to get me.
Always, Thorn said fiercely.
I'll see you soon, Sonny said, tilting
her wings.
Sonny, Thorn called.
Be careful.
I will, Sonny called back.
Already soaring toward the mountains.
No, I mean, Thorn swooped out of the
formation for a moment, catching up to
her. and circling her in the air.
I mean, if you go see your father.
I know you're thinking about it.
She nodded at the line of mountains, where
the jagged peak of Jade Mountain towered
darkly over the rest.
Be careful with Stone Mover.
If all that is true about being an
animus.
Well, I saw him do a lot of magic.
We don't know how much soul he has left.
Are you going to go see him?
Sonny asked.
Someday, Thorn said, with a small flicker
of anger in her eyes.
Apparently he's in no hurry, so I'll take
care of my dragons first.
I should do that too, Sonny said, with my
dragons, I mean.
Thorn smiled at her.
See you soon, daughter.
Sunny watched as the outlaws soared away
across the desert, all their wing beats
together, stirring up small sandstorms
below them.
Then she oriented herself toward the
mountains again and flew, beating her
wings as fast as they would move.
She couldn't use the tunnel to the
rainforest.
She couldn't risk the trip past Burns
stronghold to get to it.
It would be safer, if longer, to go over
the mountains, but she should have a head
start on Pearl and Scarlet, who had flown
the other way, and who didn't know about
the tunnels.
I hope, she thought.
I don't think there's any way they could
know.
Her breath seemed to come more easily
with every wing beat, even as the forest
and the mountains came closer and
closer.
She was leaving the desert, but she was
going back to her friends at last.
Chapter 16.
The plan was to go straight to the
rainforest.
As tempted as Sonny was by the idea of
meeting her father, she was more worried
about her friends.
She needed to get back and warn them
fast.
But the weather had other plans.
A gale force wind howled down the
mountains that night, carrying with it
the worst storm Sonny had ever been
caught in.
Not that she'd encountered many living in
caves her whole life.
But there was that one hurricane in the
kingdom of the sea, and Sonny was pretty
sure this was worse.
Or maybe it only felt worse, because she
was alone and caught outside with no
shelter, and rapidly becoming very, very
wet.
The rain pelted in her eyes and dragged
down her wings, while the wind kept
trying to slam her into the cliffs, and
the whole time, thunder roared, as though
the clouds were playing drums on the
mountaintops.
Lightning cracked terrifyingly close to
her wings, and Sonny thought, I won't be
able to save anyone if I end up as a
fiery heap in a ravine.
She veered toward the peak of Jade
Mountain, the one solid thing she could
identify in the driving storm.
Will he be there?
Will he want to meet me?
Will he be scary, or awful, or
dangerous?
Will he be like Orca?
The crazy animus seawing who killed all
those dragonettes?
She wished she had clay or tsunami with
her.
That would have been better if she could
have gone back to the rainforest 1st and
gotten one of them to come along, so she
didn't have to meet her mysterious
powerful, potentially homicidal father
alone.
But the storm drove her on, as if it had
talons of its own, dragging her up the
mountain with shrieking fury.
Soaking wet, exhausted, and shivering
with anxiety, Sunny finally crash landed
in a cave high up on the mountain's south
side.
She stumbled to a stop, scraping her
scales painfully on the rocky floor, and
shook out her wings in a flurry of
droplets.
It was dark inside, and Sonny thought it
was unlikely that she'd have accidentally
wandered into the exact cave where her
father lived.
Surely there were other caves all over
the mountain, but the darkness made her
uneasy, and cautiously she breathed out a
plume of fire.
Nothing.
An empty stone cavern loomed around her
not that different from the ones she'd
grown up in.
She breathed more fire, letting it warm
her from the inside, and searched the
cave until she found a thick branch that
had been swept inside by the storm.
She set it ablaze, and held it up to use
as a torch.
The flickering light revealed a gap in
the rocks in the back corner.
When she investigated, she found a sort
of natural tunnel that seemed to lead
farther into the mountain to a cave
system that probably ran all the way
through it.
Sunny hesitated, leaning against the
stone wall.
Should she rest here and fly on in the
morning?
Maybe she could leave unnoticed, and come
back when she had reinforcements.
But how could I get this close to my
father and not try to see him?
She thought of peril and kestrel, and how
peril had thought they'd have more time
to get to know each other.
You never know what might happen.
That decided her.
Holding out the torch, she slipped into
the gap and started down the rocky slope
beyond.
She wandered for what felt like a long
time, marking the walls with her claws
whenever she came to a fork in the
tunnels.
She found caves dripping with stalactites
clambered over rocks like giant bubbles
flew over a dark pool with no ripples
where her torch reflected eerily across
the glassy surface.
It felt familiar, being underground like
this.
She wondered if other dragons, especially
other sand wings, would be more unnerved
by these surroundings.
But this was so similar to the small
enclosed world she grew up in.
She almost expected to turn a corner and
find the steady cave, with a map spread
against one wall and scrolls piled in the
corner, and her friends arguing over who
would play Blaze when they acted out the
history of the war.
And then, she stopped in a narrow
passageway with a low, craggy ceiling.
Was that breathing?
She held her own breath and listened.
It sounds like breathing.
Air rasped quietly somewhere, in and out
as if something large were sitting
concealed in shadows, not too far away
maybe even watching her.
Sunny's scales crawled, and she clutched
the torch closer.
Do not panic.
Listen.
After a long moment, she realized that
the breathing was even and rhythmic.
That's not the sound of something
lurking.
That's the sound of a dragon sleeping.
She crept up a passageway toward the
noise.
I think it's this way.
Sharp edges of rocks caught on her tail
and stabbed at her feet as she climbed
closer, and closer.
The torchlight flickered suddenly, dipping
and swaying, and then Sonny felt it as
well, a gust of wind, whistling down the
tunnel from far away.
She lifted the torch higher, and saw that
the tunnel widened into a cave only a few
paces ahead.
At first, as she edged closer, the cave
looked empty, but then the firelight
reflected off something black and glossy
in the shadows against the back wall.
Scales, black scales, rising and falling
in sleep.
It was a night wing for sure.
Sunny stopped and stared at the
slumbering dragon.
Is that my father?
He was bigger than thorn, but not
enormous, nowhere near the size of morrow
seer or burn.
Deep lines were etched into his face, so
he looked as if he were in pain, even in
his sleep.
His talons were curled awkwardly into
stiff shapes, and his tail flopped
heavily along the ground behind him
barely moving as he breathed, as though
it were made of stone.
Sonny took a quick breath in, and then
stepped closer.
It wasn't just his tail.
Other parts of the dragon, his back legs
his shoulders, the edges of his wings
looked heavier and thicker than a normal
dragon's scales.
Like he's actually turning into stone.
Is that possible?
She lifted the torch. and peered at the
section of tail closest to her.
The black scales looked like dark pebbles
here, sinking into the skin beneath.
She was so preoccupied, studying this odd
phenomenon, that it took her a moment to
realize that the dragon's eyes had opened
and he was staring back at her.
Oh, she gasped, jumping back.
I'm sorry.
I didn't.
I mean, I didn't mean to wake you.
I was, The storm.
I don't bite, he said in a deep, serious
voice.
Oh, Sonny said again.
Well, that's good.
You mean, you don't bite other dragons
right?
Like me?
Are you being reassuring?
He blinked slowly at her.
I don't bite.
Other dragons.
Great. said Sonny, not feeling very
reassured.
It was unsettling how he hadn't moved a
muscle of his body as he spoke to her.
Even his jaws seemed to hinge very slowly
open for him to talk.
So, hi.
I'm Sonny.
He didn't answer.
She waited a moment, then said, are you
stone mover?
That seemed to surprise him a little.
If the tiny flicker of movement in his
brow meant anything.
Yes.
It is my father.
It's really him.
He's still alive, and right here in front
of me.
And he doesn't look crazy and homicidal.
He just looks sad.
Stone mover blinked again.
How did the Talons find out my name?
I'm not from the talons, she said.
Do the talons come here?
Oh, right.
Kestrel said we could send her a message
through you.
I guess that would be useful when you're
an underground movement and never know
where you'll have to hide.
True, he said.
After all, I am not going anywhere.
Oh, Sunny said, glancing at his scales.
Because what happened to you?
You are nosier than the talons, he
observed, but without any anger in his
voice.
It is my animus curse.
Really?
Sonny said.
This happened to you when you used your
magic?
I thought you'd lose your, you know, soul
or something, not this.
She waved her claws at the petrified
scales weighing him down.
I turned the magic on itself, he said.
The curse appears in my scales now
instead of taking my soul.
He sighed through his nose, a sad, windy
sound with drifts of smoke.
Too late, anyway.
Too late for what?
Sonny asked.
My soul.
He managed to turn his head a fraction
toward her, with an eerie, creaking
sound.
His dark eyes were as still and
unreadable as the underground cave like.
The things I have done.
You mean like building the tunnels?
Sonny said.
And now there was a definite flash of
surprise all the way through his eyes.
Then it faded, and his eyes narrowed, as
he examined her from horns to talons.
It might have been scary once, his
expression, except that the rest of him
was so pathetic and sad.
He could hardly even move.
Sonny didn't feel afraid of him at all.
Who?
Oh, you?
he asked.
I'm, Well, this felt awkward.
Just throwing it out there mid
conversation, but how else could she tell
him?
Was there an easy, not shocking way to
break this kind of news?
Okay, the truth is, I'm your daughter.
Thorn is my mother.
I only just found her just, wow, just
yesterday.
No, 2 days ago, and she told me about you
and Sunny talked on, not sure what to
think of the expressions darting across
Stone Mover's face, confusion, suspicion
hope, dismay.
Maybe anger?
And I wanted to meet you.
I hope that's, I hope you, Well, I know
it's weird because she never got a chance
to tell you about me, so, We had eggs, he
rasped.
You had me, Sonny said, an egg, one
dragonette.
Just me.
She looked down at her talons.
Mother wanted to tell you, but she never
got your note.
She didn't know you were here until she
found it yesterday.
She's been looking everywhere for you.
Her father sighed through his nose and
closed his eyes.
I thought she'd given up on me.
She might have now, Sunny said, trying to
prompt more of a response.
Why didn't he care more?
Why hadn't he tried harder?
She felt a wave of sympathy for her
mother.
Why didn't you go look for her?
I'm not.
The right dragon for Thorn, he said.
Perhaps I never was.
She obviously thought you were, Sonny
pointed out.
She really worried about you.
He sighed again.
He sighs a lot, Sonny thought, wishing
she could poke something into his nose to
make him stop.
There's nothing I can do.
I did all the wrong things.
A long, long time ago.
And nothing can change that.
Something suddenly scrabbled in the dark
nearby, and Sunny nearly leaped onto
Stone Mover's back in terror.
But when she swung the torch around and
then down, the light reflected off tiny
little eyes and pointed ears, and wet
russet fur.
It was a fox.
Sauntering into their cave as bold as
anything.
Sunny realized it had come down another
passageway, and she could feel the wind
coming from that direction as well.
The passage must lead to an exit out to
the mountainside.
The fox carried a dead squirrel in its
jaws, and it gave Sonny a scornful look
as if it certainly didn't expect her to
dare pick a fight with someone as tough
as him.
Shoo, Sonny said sternly.
Go find yourself another cave.
Oh.
This is dinner, Stone Mover said.
He hinged his jaw open, and to Sonny's
wonder, the fox trotted over and dropped
the squirrel right into his mouth.
It stepped back and gave Sonny another
haughty look as Stone Mover began to
chew.
Wow, Sonny said, are foxes intelligent
too?
Like scavengers?
What if all animals are smarter than we
think they are?
Is there going to be any prey left that I
won't feel bad about eating?
How did you train it to do that?
Stone mover waited until he'd swallowed
and then he said, I didn't.
I enchanted him.
Sonny frowned at the fox.
You mean with animus magic?
That only works on things, not animals.
Turns out, it works on animals.
Said Stone Mover.
If you're desperate, and try hard
enough.
She folded her wings in and shivered.
That's creepy.
Dinner doesn't mind, he replied, and it
took her a moment to figure it out.
You call the fox dinner?
she said.
Why not?
His shoulder moved an infinitesimal
amount, the smallest of shrugs.
Because that's peculiar, she said, and
really creepy for him if he knew what you
were saying.
I didn't think about it, he said.
I've never introduced him to anyone
before.
Anyway, I only enchanted him to bring me
food every few days.
He still has a fine ordinary life as a
fox.
I'm sure.
As if in answer to this, dinner shook
himself vigorously, scattering water all
over sunny, and then trotted out of the
cave again.
I mean, Stone Mover concluded, I had to
do something, or I would have starved.
Hmm.
Sonny said.
She didn't like the thought of any dragon
using magic to command a living thing.
Would animus magic work on something
bigger than a fox?
She didn't want to follow that thought to
its possible conclusion.
I can't believe.
I have a daughter.
Stone Mover said, and Sonny felt a little
warmer toward him, hearing the sadness in
his voice.
I used to dream.
I would think about what our dragonettes
might look like.
If Thorn and I ever, but I thought it was
too late.
I bet you didn't picture me.
Sonny said ruefully.
I don't have the sandwing tail barb, and
I also don't have any cool nightwing
powers.
I always thought maybe I looked weird
because of the prophecy somehow, but he
would have sat up if he could.
She could tell.
His head twitched a little closer to
her.
His breath smelled like squirrel
prophecy.
About the dragonette saving the world and
stopping the war?
Sonny said, you know, you must know.
Yes.
He mused.
I'm one of them, she said.
Hidden alone from the rival queens.
That's me.
It's kind of a long story.
But he started, and paused.
And then Sonny was scared, because the
look in his eyes was the look of news she
knew she didn't want, and it was
righteousness and pity, and truth is the
important thing, and she didn't want it.
She didn't want him to say it.
Stop, don't, she blurted, but at the same
time, he said, But don't you know?
The prophecy isn't real.
Chapter 17.
Hmm...
Stone mover said, studying her
expression.
You did know.
You know it's fake.
Well, I've heard that, Sonny said.
The walls felt as if they were tilting in
toward her.
She curled her claws and twitched her
tail, avoiding his eyes.
That's what Maro seer said, but why
should we trust him?
Stone Mover managed to look faintly
amused.
Morusir wouldn't make himself seem any
less powerful if he could ever avoid it.
He must have been forced to tell you the
truth, for some reason.
He was manipulating us, like always, Sonny
said, but just because I don't like him
doesn't mean that prophecy couldn't be
real.
Oh little dragon.
Stone Mover said, and she got the feeling
he'd already forgotten her name.
I promise you.
The prophecy is not real.
I was there when they came up with it.
I was also there when the night wing
scribes were ordered to write more about
our so called powers.
Building them up in every scroll, every
story.
Queen battle winner planned that
carefully.
But no night wing is at any power to see
the future, or read minds, in over a 100
years.
If anyone ever did.
That is the truth.
Sonny wanted to throw things, and yell
like her mother did when she was angry.
Nightwings.
She growled.
You guys make it really, really hard to
like you.
Why are you telling me this?
You obviously haven't told the talons or
everyone would know.
Because I suspect I am dying.
He said with a dry cough, and someone
should know.
If not my own daughter.
Then who?
Well, hooray, Sonny said.
Lucky me.
She tucked her tail around her talons and
hunched her wings up.
After a moment, she said, really?
Are you really dying?
I'm always dying.
He answered, which also made Sonny want
to poke him in the nose.
She honestly had no idea why her mother
had ever liked this dragon.
But at least he's telling me the truth.
That's more than I can say for most of
the grown up dragons I've ever known.
She tried to push down the bitterness she
felt about night wings and all their
lies.
She tried to look at just stone mover, her
father, and see him as his own dragon, not
one of a tribe.
He's really sad.
Imagine, if I had been born with Anima's
powers, into a terrible place like the
Nightwing Island.
The queen must have used him from the
moment they found out what he could do.
He never had a choice about what to do
with his life.
Maybe nobody does.
Even though I want to end the war so
badly.
Maybe there's nothing I can do.
The prophecy was really fake.
Her life was really a lie.
She was really not special.
And she was really not destined to save
the world.
She looked at her father, whose eyes had
closed.
His breathing was starting to slow down
as if he were falling asleep again.
Can I stay here tonight?
she asked.
Please do, he said quietly.
Sunny blew out the torch, and curled up
in a ball in the warmest corner of the
cave, across from Stone Mover's petrified
scales.
She rested her chin on her front talons
feeling like her own scales were made of
stone too, heavy, and exhausting to lug
around.
She wished she could wake up back in the
cave under the mountain 2 months ago
before any of this had happened, when she
still believed in the prophecy, their
destiny, a wonderful future, and perfect
parents waiting out there for all of
them.
Her eyes closed, and her sadness drifted
away into sleep.
Sunny was back in the stronghold
wandering through Burns Weirdling
collection, except instead of a tower, it
had become an endless maze of
increasingly creepy oddities.
Every time she turned a corner, a new
disturbing thing lurched toward her.
She realized Flower was sitting on her
shoulder, holding onto her neck like one
of the rainforest sloths and chattering
quietly to herself.
This was comforting only for a moment, and
then a headless gray dragon suddenly
loomed out of his shadowy doorway
tottering at her, and splattering blood
from its claws.
Sonny leaped aside, pressing her back
against the wall, she closed her eyes.
Stop, stop.
Don't be scared.
This is just a dream.
You're safe now, far away from Bern.
She imagined the bright rolling sand of
the desert, trying to change her dreams
surroundings by force of will.
After a few moments.
She felt the warmth of sunlight on her
face, and she opened her eyes.
It had worked.
She was standing on the desert sand, and
right in front of her was a scavenger.
Sunny started back with a yelp of
surprise, and so did the scavenger.
But it didn't turn and run, and it didn't
scream.
It just stood there and blinked at her
with enormous brown eyes.
She reached up to her shoulder.
Flower was still there.
This scavenger in front of her was not
flower.
Sonny had never seen it before.
Ah, Sonny thought.
It's so cute.
She guessed it was female, like flower
although this one seemed smaller and
younger.
Seeing flower.
That's probably why she was dreaming
about scavengers, although it was
surprising to dream up one she'd never
seen before.
A long, dark mane flowed from the
scavenger's head down to the middle of
her back, and she had the same adorable
little nose and monkey features as
Smolders pet, including the long, thin
clever paws with no claws on the end.
Sonny tilted her head at the scavenger's
paws.
Wait.
She was holding something.
Something about the size of an orange
which caught the desert sunlight with a
shimmer of blue.
While Starflight had been trapped with a
night wings, he'd found a way to
communicate with his friends by dropping
into their dreams, using an old animus
touched sapphire called a dream visitor.
Apparently, there were 3 of them out
there in the world somewhere.
And he had found one on the Nightwing
Island.
Glory had explained it to Sonny and Clay
and tsunami, rolling her eyes, as if she
couldn't believe they'd forgotten that
one sentence in one scroll they'd studied
years ago.
Sometimes she could be as bad as
Starfight, although nobody would ever
dare tell her that.
Sunny took a step toward the scavenger
but she didn't even flinch back.
Instead, she took a step towards Sonny
holding out her free paw.
She pointed at Flower and chattered
something.
Am I not dreaming?
Is this real?
Could a scavenger possibly have a dream
visitor?
How would it have gotten a dragon Jewel
like that?
She inhaled sharply, flaring her wings.
The only possible way, by stealing it
from the queen of the sand wings 20 years
ago.
Where did you get that?
she asked, flicking her tail at the jewel
in the scavenger's paw?
The scavenger looked down at the dream
visitor.
Her eyes widened, and the desert sand
behind her suddenly went blurry.
Sonny caught a glimpse of black shapes
around her. towering against a background
of trees and moonlight.
With a muffled yelp, the scavenger gave
Sonny a fierce look, clutched the
sapphire to her chest, and vanished.
Wait, Sonny shouted.
I need that treasure.
She pounced on the spot where the
scavenger had been, digging frantically
in the sand, but of course, it was gone
popping out of her dream as abruptly as
it had popped in, and there was no way to
get her back.
The scavenger was the one who had the
dream visitor, and therefore controlled
where she went and who she saw.
But why would she visit me?
And how?
I thought you could only visit the dreams
of dragons you've met before.
Or seen.
She must have seen me somewhere.
Sometime while we were traveling around
Pyria, although I'm sure I didn't see
her.
Sunny sat down, sweeping her claws
through the sand.
So if I can figure out where, maybe I can
find her.
And the stolen sandwing treasure.
She closed her eyes and concentrated
trying to bring back those blurry dark
shapes that she'd glimpsed behind the
scavenger just for a moment.
They'd looked familiar, and there had
been trees too.
So it wasn't the kingdom of the sea, or
the sky kingdom.
Were there scavengers in the rainforest?
The trees didn't look tall enough.
Sonny's eyes snapped open.
The forest between the mountains and the
desert, where I saw the ruins of the old
scavenger den.
The little scavenger was in the ruins.
Which means now I know where to start
looking.
Part three.
The Eye of Onyx.
Chapter 18.
It was still raining when Sonny woke up
the next morning.
She could hear the pitter patter at the
far end of the passageway, and the breeze
that gusted toward them smelled damp and
fresh.
But it came along with dim morning light
and the wind wasn't as cold or fierce as
it had been the night before.
She felt sure that the worst of the storm
had passed.
She stood up and stretched, reaching her
wings as wide and high as they would go
and pressing her talons out in front of
her.
Everything felt less awful again
somehow.
Her father was still asleep.
Sonny hesitated, half tempted to leave
without saying goodbye, but she couldn't
do that to him.
Stone mover?
She picked up the burnt stick she'd used
for a torch, and nudged a part of his
shoulder that didn't look entirely made
of stone yet.
Mm, he answered.
His eyes slowly peeled open.
I have to go, she said.
Already.
He sighed.
This time long and smoky.
So she had to step back to breathe.
Can't you stay?
It's really.
Quiet. here.
Really lonely, you mean, she thought.
I'm sorry, she said.
Then added with a burst of excitement, I
think I've figured out how to end the
war.
I mean, I think I found a clue sort of.
At least, I have an idea.
Stone Mover's eyes were dark and
puzzled.
But, he said.
But why?
The prophecy isn't real.
Remember?
That doesn't matter, she said.
I'm not doing it because a prophecy told
me to.
If I can stop the war, I think I should.
It would be nice if someone else would
take care of it, but maybe that's what
everyone else is hoping.
And maybe someone just has to do it.
Hmm. said Stone Mover.
Somehow, I suspect, it won't be that
easy.
Maybe it will be.
Sonny said brightly.
I'll find the eye of Onyx, and give it to
one of the queens, and that's all it'll
take.
Oh, said Stone Mover.
That'll never work.
I thought you might say that, Sonny
said.
Don't worry, I'll come back and tell you
all about it when it totally does work.
She smiled at him, and she thought she
saw the slightest movement of a maybe
smile twitching around the corners of his
mouth.
I wish, he said, then stopped.
I don't even know where to begin with
wishing, Sonny thought.
I wish the talons hadn't taken me?
No, because then I wouldn't have grown up
with my friends.
I wish I'd been born looking like a real
sandwing.
No, because then I wouldn't be me.
And I wouldn't want to be anyone else.
Maybe I wish the prophecy were real.
I wish I knew for sure that this would
work.
Sunny shook out her wings.
Just wish me luck, she said.
I'll see you soon.
She could sense Stone Mover watching her
gloomily as she headed up the passage
toward the light and the quiet rain.
She wondered what her mother would think
of him now, how much he had changed since
they knew each other.
None of my friends got to know both of
their parents.
I'm lucky they're both still alive.
And I'm lucky they're not that bad.
But now that I've met both of them.
I know which one I want to be like.
I'm not going to sit in a cave and mope
because things aren't the way I want them
to be.
I'm going to go make them happen.
The way Thorn started the outlaws and
searched for me.
If she had given up, how would we ever
have found each other?
She'd have been just another dragon in
the scorpion den?
And maybe our paths would never have
crossed.
The passage ended in a shallow cave
overlooking the mountain range below.
The sun was rising in the east, which was
also the direction of the rainforest, but
the forest with the scavenger was to the
west.
Do I have time?
What if Scarlet gets to the rainforest
before I do?
Sonny hesitated, with her claws gripping
the ledge, and her wings outspread?
Maybe Scarlett had been bluffing about
knowing where the dragonettes were.
How would she guess they were in the
rainforest, if no one else had found them
there?
Maybe she was only trying to scare
Sonny.
Well, she did a good job of that.
Too bad I don't have the obsidian mirror
anymore.
It'd be useful to know what Scarlet is
doing.
Maybe I should go warn my friends and
then come back.
But what if the scavenger leaves the
ruins?
This could be my only chance to find the
eye of onyx and stop the war.
It was a detour, but she had to risk it.
She leaned forward and plummeted down the
mountainside, soaring west toward the
scavenger ruins, and, she hoped, the
missing treasure.
The burnt village was easy to spot from
the air, a dark gash, stark and black
against the surrounding greenery, sunny
spiraled toward it, studying the trees
with our sharp eyes, and looking for any
movement that might be a scavenger.
Nothing so far, but it was late afternoon
and Sonny wasn't even sure whether
scavengers were normally nocturnal or
preferred the day.
She landed lightly in a cloud of ash that
smelled like a wood fire.
The ruins were still and deserted, and
Sonny wondered uneasily if she had been
wrong.
What if the scavenger wasn't here?
Or what if she'd been here, but was now
gone, and Sunny had missed her?
Think positive.
She paced the entire perimeter of the den
searching every structure with even half
a wall still standing, every noise made
her freeze and listen, her head cocked to
the side, but it was always squirrels in
the nearby trees, where other little
creatures scurrying in the underbrush
which reminded her that she was hungry.
So she caught a mouse and ate it, sitting
on the old bell platform at the center of
the village.
Well, there was no one here now, but that
didn't mean she should give up.
Maybe the scavenger would return later
except she probably wouldn't if she
spotted a dragon prowling through the
ruins, but then again, if she'd stolen
the treasure from the sand wings, that
meant she had to be fairly bold and
reasonably stupid.
Still, Sonny decided to hide, just in
case.
She found a tree with thick, overlapping
leaves and wide branches, and settled
into the crook of the trunk, keeping a
sharp eye on the burnt village.
From here, she had a good view of most of
it, and she spent the rest of the day
watching and waiting.
By nightfall, as one of the moons climbed
cheerily up the sky, Sonny had begun to
doubt herself again, I should just go, I
don't have time to sit here.
I have to get to my friends in the
rainforest.
Besides, if she comes during the night, I
won't be able to see her anyway, if only
I could see in the dark like tsunami.
She dug her claws into the bark, forcing
herself to be patient.
If the Eye of Onyx was nearby, it was
worth waiting for.
Once she had that, she'd have a way to
end the war.
Which won't stop Scarlet from wanting to
kill us, of course.
She stared hard at the village.
Now a shadowy mass of odd lumps and
pointy shapes, overlaid with a silvery
moonlight.
Was that?
Something was moving in the forest
outside the ruins.
A small light bobbed up and down, not far
from the ground, blinking in and out as
it went behind trees and bushes.
Now her ears could pick out the sound of
footsteps.
They were very quiet.
But here and there a twig snapped, and
she recognized the noise of paws brushing
through leaves.
Softly.
She unwound her tail from the branch and
slithered down the trunk.
She crept silently through the dark
village toward the light as it left the
trees and floated toward a set of
collapsed stone stairs.
If Sunny remembered right from her
earlier tour of the ruins.
There were 2 of them.
Two scavengers, one of them with short
fluffy hair, but the other one's hair was
long and she moved in a quick, confident
way.
Sonny was short, was the same scavenger
from her dream.
She waited until they climbed onto the
steps and sat down.
They were warbling in low tones that
sounded like some of the rainforest
monkeys, and the one with the long hair
sometimes waved her paws, as if she were
drawing a picture in the air.
Flower did the same thing, Sunny
remembered.
Now, the trick would be to approach them
and get the treasure without scaring them
off, and without getting attacked.
They didn't look like they were carrying
any sharp little weapons, but you never
knew with scavengers, according to the
scrolls.
And if these 2 had stolen the treasure
that meant they'd killed Queen Oasis, so
they could be very dangerous.
She paused in the shadows for a moment
considering, and finally decided a direct
approach was the only option.
Don't run away, she said, stepping out in
front of them and spreading her wings.
Both scavengers yelled with fright, and
promptly tried to run away.
Sonny leaped into the air and landed in
front of the scavenger from her dream.
That was the one she wanted.
I said, don't run away, Sonny barked, even
though she knew the scavenger couldn't
understand her.
Hey, come back.
She flung her tail out, and tripped the
little creature as it bolted in another
direction.
I won't eat you, I promise.
She pounced, and managed to trap the
scavenger between her front talons.
The 2nd scavenger suddenly came running
out of the ruins and threw something at
her.
This turned out to be the tiny lamp
they'd been carrying, which bounced off
Sunny's scales, but left a stinging burn
where it hit.
Ouch.
Sonny roared.
All right.
I might eat you if you keep doing that.
She swept her tail around and knocked the
2nd scavenger over, then picked up the
1st scavenger and hopped a step back
growling.
The scavenger between her claws was
kicking and wriggling, and being
generally impossible.
Sonny was trying really hard to hold it
gently, but it was like hanging on to a
moonbeam.
And the other scavenger was already
struggling back upright, probably to
attack her again.
Sonny looked around and spotted a
building that hadn't burned as badly as
the rest of them.
Two of the walls still stood, forming a
corner made of heavy round stones.
The walls were as tall as Seni's head, too
tall for a little scavenger to jump off
unless they were more like frogs than
Sonny thought they were.
She deposited the 1st scavenger on top of
the wall, then whipped around, seized the
2nd scavenger, and stuck him up there as
well.
They both made little yelping sounds and
clung to the stones.
There, Sonny said.
Now you can't run away.
She sat down and folded her wings back.
So, where is the treasure?
Their big eyes stared back at her.
Sunny reached for a branch, set it on
fire, and stuck it upright in the ground
so she could see them better.
The scavenger from her dream pointed at
Sonny, and chattered something at the
other scavenger.
If she were my pet, I could give her a
name, Sonny thought.
Maybe something like holler for all that
noise she was making.
And the other one could be fluffy for his
hair.
She smiled, holler and fluffy, totally
cute.
But also maybe totally responsible for
this whole war if they were the ones who
stole the treasure.
They looked a little small to be treasure
thieves, but then all scavengers were too
small to be trying something that
idiotic.
The dream visitor, Sonny said.
Cupping her front talons together as if
she were holding a jewel.
The one you had in my dream?
Where is it?
She tilted her head.
Holler and Fluffy started arguing, or at
least it certainly looked that way
raising their voices and barking at each
other, waving their paws.
Sunny watched this for a moment, then
stuck her claw between them and said, all
right, you're adorable, but that's
enough.
Dream visitor, treasure?
Now?
She rested her open talons between them.
Holler hesitated, looking at Fluffy, and
then reached into a pocket of the fabric
that was draped around her.
She pulled out the sapphire and dropped
it into Sonny's palm.
Whoa, Sonny said.
She hadn't actually expected that to
work.
She raised the jewel to her eye and
studied it.
It certainly looked like the animus
touched gems from the scroll.
Thank you, Sonny said to Holler.
Where's the rest?
Holler blinked at her.
Um, Sonny said.
She took the jewel and put it on the
ground, then drew a large circle around
it in the ashes, and mimed adding more
jewels to the circle.
Then she spread her wings around it, and
waved at the imaginary pile of treasure.
The rest of the treasure that you stole
where this came from?
She picked up the dream visitor and waved
it again.
Fluffy indicated the imaginary treasure
embarked something at Holler.
Holler ignored him, pointed over Sunny's
shoulder, and said something to her in
what really sounded like an imperious
tone of voice, if it wasn't too crazy to
think about scavengers trying to order
dragons around.
Sonny narrowed her eyes at Holler.
Now that she had a moment to think about
it, she could see that both scavengers
were smaller than flour.
They didn't seem entirely full grown.
Scavengers reached their full size before
20 years, didn't they?
So if the treasure had been stolen 20
years ago, surely it couldn't have been
these 2 who took it.
But there was the dream visitor, real and
heavy in her claws.
Fluffy began chattering vigorously at
Sonny.
Holler grabbed his shoulder and tried to
stop him, but he fended her off.
He pointed at the imaginary pile of
treasure, and then at himself, and then
at Sonny.
That, me, ew.
And then he mimed picking something up
and giving it to Sonny.
Is he offering to bring me the treasure?
Sunny's hopes rose.
Holler stamped her foot and snapped at
him, he put his paws on his hips and
yapped back.
I have an excellent idea, Sonny
announced.
She gently scooped her claws around
Fluffy and lifted him off the wall onto
the ground.
He yelled and flapped around a bit until
she let him go and stepped back, and then
he stopped, watching her warily.
You go get the rest of the treasure, and
when you come give it to me, you can have
Hollerback.
Sonny tapped holler lightly on the head.
This took a while to sink in.
Sonny pointed to the forest, held up the
dream visitor, pointed to Fluffy and
Holler, in several different combinations
until finally Fluffy took a few steps
toward the trees, calling up to holler
she yapped back at him, and he bobbed his
fluffy, shaggy head, then hurried off
into the darkness.
I hope this works.
Sonny said to Holler.
I'm not actually going to eat you or
anything.
Even if he doesn't come back.
Yibble, yibble, yibble.
Holler said to Sonny, or at least that's
what it sounded like.
You're very cute, but you're all a lot of
trouble, Sonny said.
Yibble.
Yibble yibble.
Holler shouted, pointing over Sonny's
shoulder again.
Or maybe she was pointing at Sonny's
shoulder, where Flower had been sitting
in Sonny's dream.
Oh, Sonny said, thinking of Glory's
sloth.
Do you want a ride?
Are you sure?
Sonny flicked her tail.
You won't be scared?
You bull?
Holler demanded.
All right, Sonny said, scooping her up.
Holler shrieked, with a little more
terror than Sunny thought was necessary
considering she'd asked for this.
As Sonny set her on her shoulder, Holler
grabbed Sonny's neck and balanced herself
across her scales, making startled
yelping noises.
Hold on tight, Sonny said, swinging her
head around to check that Holler was
firmly in place.
She spread her wings and leaped into the
sky.
It was a clear starry night.
All the clouds from yesterday's storm had
blown away, and 2 of the moons were half
full in the sky overhead.
The rustling leaves below them looked
like waves rippling on the sea.
Sunny soared up in a long arc, swooped
down across the forest, and veered back
around again.
The scavenger was quiet on her back, which
was much preferable to shrieking.
I hope Fluffy understood me, Sonny
thought.
I hope he hasn't gone to get a pack of
other scavengers with pointy things.
Imagine, if he really does come back with
a missing treasure, I could be moments
away from holding the eye of onyx.
The eye of onyx, and power over the whole
kingdom of sand.
Sunny shivered from horns to tail, and
felt the scavenger clutch her neck
tighter.
Whoever holds the eye could be queen.
Even I could be queen.
That would be one way to end the war.
None of the 3 sisters wins, and I take
the throne.
Sonny, Queen of the Sandwings.
Of course, that would leave 3 dragons
with a single unified mission, kill me.
It was scary, but it gave her an eerie
thrill to think about too.
What if that was her real destiny?
To rule the sand wings?
She glanced down at the forest and saw a
movement near the torch she had lit.
Fluffy was back.
She tucked in her wings and dove toward
the ruins, landing with a thump right in
front of him.
Fluffy jumped back with a yell.
His eyes widened when he saw holler on
Sonny's shoulder, and he launched into
another shouting fit, practically hopping
up and down.
Holler slid off Sonny's back and joined
in.
Sunny wasn't interested in their little
monkey squabble, though.
She was interested in the bulging canvas
sack that Fluffy was clutching.
Reaching over Holler's head.
She deftly lifted the sack out of his
paws.
She turned toward the firelight and
fidgeting with excitement, emptied the
contents of the sack onto the ground.
Gold coins and jewels tumbled out and
bounced through the ashes, clinking and
clattering into a small pile.
Most of the jewels were tiny, none as big
as the dream visitor, and barely worth
stealing.
The biggest object was a statue of a
dragon carved from blue stone, with
emeralds for eyes.
The Lazolite dragon, Sunny Guest
remembering the scrolls about the missing
treasure.
She sifted through the pile, her heart
sinking.
She knew the answer at 1st glance, but
she dug through it all, examining every
coin, just to be sure she was right.
She was.
The Eye of Onyx was not there.
Chapter 19.
This isn't all of it, Sonny cried
whipping around to face the scavengers.
Where's the eye?
Why isn't it here?
They stopped chattering immediately, and
jumped away from her, holding their paws
up in the air.
Fluffy pointed at the sack and Yibble
yibbled frantically.
You must have it.
Where else could it be?
Sonny started pacing back and forth.
She could feel smoke rising from her
snout, and she knew she was probably
scaring the scavengers, but they didn't
run away.
I need the eye of onyx.
It's my one chance to end the war.
She stopped and faced them again.
How am I supposed to end the war without
it?
Yibble?
Holler said tentatively.
Yibble.
Yibble?
Well said, Sonny said to her, that's very
helpful.
She sat down and frowned crossly at the
pathetic pile of treasure.
Ribble.
Yibble?
Fluffy said to holler.
Herbal yobble, she snapped back.
Someone else must have it, Sonny said
thinking aloud.
If you had it, you'd have brought it to
me, because you were worried about
Holler.
You wouldn't keep the one thing I need.
When I'm sure scavengers prefer shiny
little things like all of this, so you
don't have the eye of onyx, which means
it's, Somewhere else in Pyria.
She sighed, and then stopped herself mid
size so she wouldn't sound like stone
mover.
Her 1st theory was probably right, and
some other dragon had stolen most of the
treasure.
Perhaps they had the eye of onyx and
didn't realize what it was, or what it
could do.
But that didn't help Sonny, who had no
way to track down the real thief.
She felt something touch her talent and
looked down.
Holler was standing in the curve of
Sonny's wing, patting her talon in a way
that seemed to say, don't worry, and it's
not the end of the world.
You're brave and cute, Sonny told her.
I wish I could keep you.
If glory can have a sloth.
I don't see why I can't have a scavenger
or two.
She glanced at Fluffy, who was edging
closer. glancing up at her warily.
But it's too dangerous.
I'd feel terrible if one of you got
hurt.
She gave Holler a thoughtful look.
These small, breakable scavengers were
brave enough to fight or ride a dragon
who could eat them in 3 bites.
Could I be that brave?
Like, for instance, could I try to stop a
war?
Even if I don't have a magical jewel, or
a mystical prophecy to back me up, even
if my friends decide not to help.
Could I still do it?
Isn't it important enough?
Why shouldn't I try?
So what if there's no foretold destiny
saying I have to?
Shouldn't I do it anyway?
Just because I want to?
But how?
She tapped her claws on the ground
thinking.
Eeble rubble snob?
Holler said.
She pointed to Sunny's shoulder again.
Sorry, Holler.
I don't have time to take you for another
ride, Sonny said regretfully.
I have to go.
She shook out her wings and reached to
scoop all the treasure back into the
sack.
She was a little bit tempted to let the
scavengers keep it, but she had a feeling
she could find some use for it, giving it
back to the sand wings, perhaps.
I'm going to find my friends and see if
they'll help me.
She informed Fluffy and Holler.
And then, then I've got a war to stop.
She patted them each gently on their
heads before gathering her wings to take
off.
As she sailed into the sky, she looked
back and saw them waving.
She wondered if she'd ever see them
again.
Maybe she could come back and look for
them after the war was over.
The weather was with her this time, and
she flew through the mountains much
faster than she had on the way out, when
she'd had to stop every time the night
wings rested or ate.
She always ate light, so it didn't take
long for her to pause.
Catch anita squirrel or a lizard once a
day and keep flying.
So it was only 2 days later when she
cleared the mountains and saw the
rainforest ahead of her, illuminated by
the rising sun beyond it.
It looked so vast and green and
peaceful.
Sonny found herself caught by a moment of
longing, a wish that she could just dive
into those leaves and stay there
forever.
There would be enough to do, helping
glory rule the rainforest and organize
the night wings.
It was beautiful, and there was always
enough food, and the rain wings were
easygoing dragons to share a tree with.
The war would come here eventually.
She told herself.
Even the rain wings aren't safe.
We already know that from what the night
wings did to them, and between Scarlet
and the 3 sisters looking for us, we
probably aren't safe anywhere either.
No hiding in caves.
That's my promise to myself.
No hiding at all.
When the world is all wrong, I'm going to
be a dragon who does something about it.
Her nerves started to get the better of
her the closer she got to the rain wing
village, though.
She kept picturing her friends' faces
doubtful, kind, but condescending, all
really?
You, Sonny, and that is sweet, but now
let's be serious.
Her stomach was doing flips and spirals
by the time she spotted the tree houses
on the outskirts in the early afternoon
and she was almost tempted to turn around
and fly away again.
What if they're mad at me?
She suddenly thought, with another
stomach lurch.
What if everyone's furious at me for
running off?
It had occurred to her to use the dream
visitor while she was traveling, but
she'd decided against it.
She wanted to explain everything to her
friends face to face.
A movement distracted her from her
thoughts.
Something shifting out of the corner of
her eye, but when she looked, she
couldn't see anything but dangling vines
and bright orange flowers.
Immediately she ducked and rolled.
So the tranquilizer dart shot right past
her and thudded into a tree trunk
startling several shiny blue frogs.
It's me, Sonny shouted, twisting to wave
her claws with the leaves around her.
It's sunny.
I'm Queen Glory's friend.
She held out her talons and spread her
wings wide, hoping one of the hidden rain
wings would remember her.
A face materialized on a nearby branch.
His scales shifting from brown and green
to dark purple.
The dragon blinked a few times, looking
more wary than most rain wings Sonny had
ever met.
The queen was looking for a little gold
dragon, said a voice behind Sonny, and
another dragon emerged, this one shifting
to the Clementine orange of the flowers.
This could be her.
Shouldn't we knock her out anyway?
asked the purple dragon.
Just to be safe.
You know, the queen keeps telling us to
be more careful.
She means about the night wings. said the
orange dragon blithely.
This one's not a night wing.
I sure she's fine.
On the one talon.
Sonny certainly didn't want to be shot
with a dart.
She wanted to be wide awake when she saw
her friends again.
On the other talon, she was afraid she
could imagine this exact conversation if
say, a smoldering, vengeful sky wing
happened to show up in the rainforest
looking for them.
Oh, she's not a night wing?
Well, then, let's take her straight to
the dragonets.
No worries.
I am Glory's friend, she promised them.
There's nothing to worry about Scarlet
later.
I need to see her.
The queen.
Let's see.
She might be in the audience tree house
said the orange dragon thoughtfully.
Or the healer's hut, said the purple
dragon.
She's there a lot.
Or visiting the night wing camp, or
checking on the progress of the school.
Or reviewing, all right, Sunny
interrupted.
I'll just look for her.
Thank you.
They both flicked their tails and bobbed
their heads, and their scales immediately
began shifting back to camouflage as
Sonny flew on.
The healer's hut, she decided, so I can
see Starflight.
But before she got there, she spotted the
mahogany brown scales of a mud wing
stretched out on one of the sleeping
platforms.
Clay!
She yelped happily.
She barreled up to him, and nearly flung
her wings around him before she realized
it wasn't clay at all.
It was some other mudwing dragonette, who
jumped back with a startled expression
and hid something behind his wings.
Whoa, Sonny said, skidding to a stop on
the wood.
Who are you?
He responded rudely.
Sonny usually liked everybody, at least
at first, but something about this dragon
immediately rubbed her the wrong way.
Where's clay?
she asked.
How should I know?
He demanded.
Sonny frowned at him, then turned to fly
away.
If he didn't want to be helpful, she
didn't need to bother with him.
Hey, he called.
Come back.
Sonny ignored him.
She had noticed the angle of the sunlight
and realized that it was the rain wing
suntime, when most of them would be
sleeping high up in the treetops
recharging their scales.
She wondered if Glory was up there too, or
if she ever let herself sleep.
Just then, she spotted the healer's hut
and coming out of it, opening his wings
to fly was clay, definitely clay this
time, every wonderful brown scale of
him.
Sunny dove into his wings, nearly
knocking him backward, except that he was
big enough to catch her.
He made an oof noise, and then realized
who she was.
Sonny, he roared.
It's you.
You're alive.
You're all right.
He seized her and swung her around, her
tail flying out behind her, and then
quickly put her down.
Are you all right?
He asked anxiously.
He touched her wings and checked her
talons.
We thought something terrible had
happened to you.
We've been searching and searching.
Come, come in.
He dragged her into the hut before she
could say anything.
Starflight.
Sonny's back.
Two black dragons turned their heads in
unison toward the door.
Sonny recognized fate speaker, the night
wing who had been one of the alternate
dragonettes, raised by the talons in case
they needed a spare set to fulfill the
prophecy.
She was crouched beside a nest of leaves
where Starflight was lying with his wings
spread out.
Sunny flinched at the side of the burns
all along Starflight's dark scales.
Some kind of silvery ointment glistened
over the wounds, and she saw a little of
it on fate speakers talons as well, as if
she'd been helping to put it on.
Sonny, Starflight said in a hoarse voice
really?
Sonny realized, with a stab of guilt and
horror, that Starfly's eyes were covered
with a mask of leaves, carefully
plastered in place.
It's me. she said, hurrying over to his
side.
She nudged his shoulder gently with her
snout, trying to share her warmth with
him.
I'm here.
Starflight let out his breath.
Are you all right?
He said anxiously.
Better than you are, she tried to joke.
I told him you were fine.
Fate speaker interjected, in a helpful
voice.
She patted the edge of the leaves where
Starflight lay.
I had a vision.
I mean, it was fuzzy, but I was pretty
sure you were fine.
Starflight coughed awkwardly, as if he'd
been trying to avoid talking about fate
speakers visions for days.
Sunny remembered what Stone Mover had
told her, that no Nightwing had had
prophetic powers or mind reading for
generations.
So was fate speaker lying?
Or did she believe her own wild stories?
She didn't seem cruel enough to deceive
Starflight about whether Sonny was all
right, but then Sonny didn't really know
her at all.
I'm sorry I wasn't here to take care of
you.
Senny said, touching one of Starflight's
wings gently.
I took care of him, fate speaker said.
Sonny felt a flash of something odd, like
she wanted fate speaker to shush and go
away.
Jealousy.
But wouldn't that mean that I like
Starflight the way he likes me?
Did she?
It would be nice if she could love him
back, it would make him happy.
And she did care about him.
Plus, he was a real hero.
He'd just saved the entire night wing
tribe from extinction.
We don't have time for mushy romance
right now anyway.
She told herself sternly.
Whatever's going to happen with me in
Starfight, whatever we are, we'll figure
it out after we stop the war.
She glanced around the room and noticed
that Webbs was still there, asleep in a
corner, although the venomous scratch on
his tail looked almost completely
healed.
There were a few rain wings as well, 4
with injuries that might have happened
during the attack on the Nightwing Island
and 2 others whose breads rattled in
their skinny chests as they slept.
Sunny guessed they had been prisoners, and
were still recovering from their
treatment at the talons of the night
wings.
She could see spots on their snouts and
ankles, where iron bands had rubbed the
scales raw.
The only other dragon occupying a bed was
the Sky Wing, Flame.
He'd grown up with fate speaker among the
talons of peace, as another possible
alternate for the dragonettes.
She could tell that the healers had
applied the cactus milk antidote to the
wound that slashed across his face, but
it would still leave a nasty scar.
She wondered if his face had looked that
furious before he was injured.
She suspected yes.
He was awake, glaring around the tree
house, with trails of smoke coming out of
his nose and ears.
So where were you?
Clay asked, bumping Sonny's wing with his
own.
Tsunami thought maybe you'd been
kidnapped.
Isn't that crazy?
Well, I kind of was kidnapped, Sonny
admitted.
Starflight and fate speaker both gasped.
But I got away, except then I got caught
again, and then I was a prisoner in Burns
stronghold for a while.
What?
Starflight tried to sit up and nearly
fell off his bed.
Clay's eyes were wide and shocked.
I'm here now, though, aren't I?
Sonny said.
It all turned out fine.
I've taken care of myself, mostly, she
added honestly, it was a little crazy, but
I should tell you all at the same time
where are tsunami and glory?
Tsunami was drilling rain wings and
evasive maneuvers, although apparently
what that actually meant was a lot of
yelling things like, pay attention, and
leave that toucan alone, and why are you
pink, stopping pink, and 3 moons, are you
eating again?
Sonny half hoped that meant she'd be all
yelled out, but of course it didn't.
Tsunami had plenty of yelling energy left
for Sonny.
Where have you been?
she roared.
Do you know how worried we've been?
How could you do that to us?
I was so sure the Night Wings did
something to you that I nearly threw them
all back to the volcano.
We've had search parties out every day
but not one sign of you, anywhere.
Not even Deathbringer.
Well, he said he smelled you over to the
west, but who trusts him?
Not me is who.
I haven't slept in days, sonny.
Days.
She grabbed Sonny and wrapped her wings
around her in a fierce hug.
Sonny felt her own anger melting and
realized she'd been furious with tsunami
ever since overhearing the conversation
in the obsidian mirror.
She may not take me seriously, Sonny
thought, but she really does love me.
I'm sorry, Sonny said, muffled, into
Tsunami's shoulder.
But I swear I was doing important
things.
I'll tell you all about it.
Where's glory?
Checking on the night wing camp, Tsunami
said, relaxing her grip on Sonny, but
keeping one wing around her.
She is kind of awesome with them, all
scary and tough and royal, like a real
queen.
Do not.
Tell her I said that.
Sonny grinned up at her.
Are they behaving?
For the most part, tsunami said.
They were all absolutely starving, so
just giving them enough food is making
them a whole lot happier and easier to
deal with.
Glory's letting them hunt and eat as much
as they want, except for the saws.
Those are off limits, apparently.
I guess being a giant sucker for cute
furry things is a rain wing genetic
defect.
I wouldn't need them either.
Sonny pointed out.
Well, but that makes sense.
Tsunami said.
You practically are a cute furry thing.
Sunny debated getting riled up about this
but tsunami was already turning to one of
the rain wings, all of whom were staring
nosily at Sunny, and ordering him to
fetch glory.
Tell her to meet us in the healer's hut
she said, and no dawdling.
If you stop to admire so much as one
beetle, I will seriously bite you.
All right, the rain wing said affably, and
flew off in a way that probably counted
as a hurry for a rain wing, but was only
marginally faster than your average
snail.
I swear, tsunami muttered through her
teeth, Sonny, you'll probably be shocked
to hear this, but I don't think I'd make
a very good rain wing.
Sonny laughed.
I missed you. she said, and meant it.
It wasn't long before they were all
gathered around Starflight's bed.
Sonny felt a rush of joy as glory swept
into the room.
Here were all her friends, all together
in one place like they were supposed to
be.
Sonny, Glory said, and the relief in her
voice was matched by the bright yellow of
her scales.
She even reached out and squeezed Sonny's
front talons, which was more affection
than Sonny would have expected from her.
Thank goodness you're alive, because now
I can totally behead you.
Starflight, what's our official policy on
beheading right now?
Our Constitution says no beheading Sonny
he said loyally.
Let's amend that.
Glory said, flicking her tail to, I can
behead anyone who worries me half to
death like this.
I know you're probably mad, Sonny said.
Glory's ears and wings were starting to
shade more red than yellow.
Okay, definitely mad, but there were lots
of stuff happened and it had better be
wildly important stuff.
Glory growled.
You know what I don't need in my 1st week
as queen.
In addition to a whole new tribe of
pretty much the worst, most unhealthy
most annoying dragons ever.
I don't need to also be freaking out
because one of my best friends has
disappeared.
I don't need to be using my best dragons
on patrols searching for you when they
should be helping me run a brand new
experimental 2 tribe kingdom.
That's me, Deathbringer said, poking his
head in from outside.
Sonny jumped.
She still wasn't used to seeing any night
wings in the rain wing village apart from
Starflight.
When she says her best dragons, she's
talking about me.
I am not, Glory said, a little too
indignantly, Sonny thought.
Quit stalking me.
This is not stalking, he objected. sliding
into the room as if he were perfectly
welcome.
This is protecting you.
Nobody invited you to this private
conversation.
Tsunami said bossily.
Hey, I'm just making sure the queen is
safe, he said, spreading his wings.
The queen can take care of herself.
Glory pointed out.
Out of the 2 dragons in question, the
queen happens to be the one with
camouflage scales who can shoot venom.
What can you do again?
Sit in the dark, is that it?
Guess what?
I can do that too.
Inky Black spilled across her scales, and
she looked down her snout at him.
I can stop dragons from killing you, he
said.
Three, assassination plot so far, Your
Majesty.
No one's better at stopping assassins
than the world's best assassin.
You poor dragon, Glory said, if only you
had a shred of self-esteem.
What?
Sonny cried dismayed.
Nightwings have tried to kill you.
Three times already?
So he says, Glory observed.
She didn't look remotely scared or even
ruffled.
Apparently, he's my bodyguard now.
Not that anyone asked him to be, ahem.
It's true.
I did have to fight my way past a whole
pack of volunteers, he mused mockingly.
Oh no, wait, it's just me.
The only dragon who cares if you live or
die.
He's just trying to make his list look
longer than mine.
Glory said to Sonny.
We're keeping track of who has saved 2
more often.
I say it doesn't count if you have to
save me from your own dragon murdering
self.
And he says, I shouldn't get credit for
sending him away before the ice wings got
him.
Sunny couldn't help and notice that
Deathbringer was apparently allowed to
know where the rain wing village was and
to roam around it freely.
So whatever she said about him, glory
really must trust him, certainly more
than any other night wing.
If you 2 are quite finished jabbing at
each other, tsunami said, rolling her
eyes, I'd like to hear what Sonny's been
doing for the last week.
Me too.
Clay said fervently, sidling up beside
her.
Sonny twined her tail around his, relieved
that at least one of her friends wouldn't
be mad at her, no matter what she'd done
or how worried he'd been.
Well, she said.
I found my parents, and I met Burns
brother, and I saw peril again, and Queen
Scarlet is alive.
Oh, and she's maybe coming here to kill
us, although I hope she doesn't really
know where we are, although she said she
did.
Glory cleared her throat quietly, but
everyone turned to look at her anyway.
Um, she said.
So, yes, actually, she does know where we
are.
She squinted at the skylight, rubbing the
back of her head.
She, maybe you visited me in a dream with
a dream visitor and saw where I was.
So, yes.
That seems like something worth
mentioning, tsunami yelled.
I was going to tell you all, Glory said
huffily, but then Starflight disappeared
and I became queen and I got a little
busy.
Anyway, Sonny interrupted, before the 2
of them could start one of their
interminable arguments.
So she was in burned stronghold, but
she's not anymore.
Could you start at the beginning?
Starflight asked.
I'm a little confused.
Me too.
Fate speaker chimed in.
As if anyone asked you, Sonny thought
then felt incredibly guilty for thinking
it.
All right, Sonny said.
It started with these 3 night wings
grabbing me.
Chapter 20.
And so, Sonny finished, I decided we
shouldn't wait any longer.
Maybe we'll never find the Eye of Onyx
but we can still choose a queen and end
the war.
Someone has to, and I think it should be
us.
She paused and looked around at her
friends, whose faces ranged from
disbelieving to astonished, too terribly
worried.
I can't believe all of that happened to
you, Starflight said, in a low, shaken
voice.
And we weren't there to protect you
Tsunami said, exchanging a glance with
clay.
She did all right, Glory said
unexpectedly.
Stealing the Obsidian mirror?
That was crazy brave.
Crazy and brave, I mean, and talking
peril into saving Thorn.
Well, that would have made me nervous.
Also, confronting scavengers.
Deathbringer chimed in, he gave a little
shudder out to his wingtips.
No, no, no, thanks, not for me.
You're scared of scavengers?
Glory asked amused.
No, he said.
I just...
Give me the heebie jeebies, that's all.
With their eyes and paws and faces.
That's pretty cute, Glory said.
The big bad assassin, terrified of itty
bitty scavengers.
One day, I'll throw a sword waving
scavenger at you and see how tough you
are.
He bridled.
But, Sonny, Clay interjected.
We can't stop the war.
The prophecy isn't true, remember?
So?
she said.
If there had never been a prophecy, would
the war have to go on forever?
No, it has to end sometime.
I vote right now.
But it doesn't have to be us, Starflight
said.
Then immediately added an almost a mumble
Maybe it has to be us.
He reached up to the leaves on his eyes
remembered they were there, and lowered
his claws again.
No, fate speaker said, grabbing
Starflight's talons.
It doesn't have to be you.
It especially doesn't have to be you.
You've done enough.
Sonny's right, though, he said.
Why shouldn't it be us?
Maybe everyone else is waiting for the
prophecy, and so they don't realize they
could end the war themselves.
And think about all the dragons who need
this war to be over.
My brothers and sisters, said Clay.
If they're still alive.
Anemone, tsunami said, so she doesn't
have to use her anima's powers and lose
her soul.
All the sand wings, Glory added.
They need a queen and a unified kingdom.
So will you help me?
Sonny said, picking nervously at a vine
of small star shaped red flowers that
snaked through the window.
Well, even if we did, what's the plan?
Tsunami said practically.
Pick a queen, and then Sand Deathbringer
to kill the other two?
Yikes.
Deathbringer said, flaring his wings.
Give me the easy job, why don't you?
Oh, if only we knew Pyria's best assassin
Glory mused teasingly.
No, no, Sonny said, flapping between them
before they could go too far down that
road.
No killing.
It would be almost impossible, tsunami
mused.
I assume dragons have tried before.
What if we got an animus to enchant
something, Starflight suggested.
That was Blister's plan to use anemone
and it was a smart one.
Enchanted Spear to go kill Burn, or
perhaps we could put her life essence in
a tree and set it on fire, or something
like that.
We are not making anemone do that.
Tsunami snarled.
Are you serious?
Can an animus dragon really do those
things?
Fate speaker asked.
That's absolutely terrifying.
It's a little more complicated than that
but basically, Deathbringer answered
her.
And yes, it's terrifying.
No, Sonny said again, we're not going to
kill them.
I agree with tsunami, Clay said.
We can't ask Anemone to use her powers.
That would be awful for her.
I wasn't thinking of anemone.
Starflight protested.
I was thinking of Sonny's father, stone
mover.
He's sort of beyond hope anyway, isn't
he?
Is he?
Sonny closed her mouth to think about
that.
She had a feeling that if he used his
magic again, that would be it for stone
mover, especially if he used it for
something as massive as killing 2
dragons.
But would it be worth it?
To save the rest of Pyria?
Would he do it?
Could she bring herself to ask him to do
it?
He was disappointing that he was still
her father.
Didn't she want to get to know him
better?
With either of those options, we'd have
to pick which sister we want to be queen
Glory said, and they're all terrible.
Blaze seems nice.
Clay said optimistically.
Blaze is a dizzy idiot, who'd be dead by
day too, Glory said.
I say blister, she's evil, but she's
smart, so she'd probably rule the kingdom
fine.
And if we're her allies, she'll leave us
alone, I think.
Well, maybe not.
Okay, probably not, but at least we'd
know where she was.
Wait, Sonny said.
I don't want to kill any of them.
Burn is the least awful, tsunami argued.
She's mean, but she's not scheming.
We'd see her coming if she tried anything
on us.
Mean and brutal, Starflight reminded
her.
Remember the murdered dragons in her
collection, and the Skywing egg she
smashed?
Just an egg, not even a dragonette yet.
As long as she's alive, I don't think
we're safe.
He paused, then added, I don't think
Sonny will be safe.
Sonny leaned over to brush his wing with
hers.
So how do we decide?
Clay said.
Who do we choose and who, and how?
I mean, are we really going to?
No, Sonny said.
Listen, for once, please?
But tsunami, glory, fate speaker, and
death bringer all started talking over
her at once, arguing about the sisters
and how to get rid of them.
Sonny clapped her talons over her ears
and shouted, stop.
I said stop.
Everyone blinked at her in this sudden
silence.
No, she said again, more firmly, we are
not killing any of them.
We're not using magic to do something
underhanded.
We are going to get all 3 of them in one
place, and then we will either have a
competition, like the rain wings have, or
we'll let all the sand wings decide.
Let the sand wings decide?
tsunami said skeptically.
What?
Like, when we decide things together?
Starflight said, understanding
immediately.
By voting, or talking it out, like the
Night Wings or Queen Coral's Council.
All the sand wings?
Glory said.
I don't see how that could work.
They'll never agree to it.
Death bringer said, shaking his head.
The sisters.
They haven't been in one place together
in over 18 years.
They certainly won't put the decision
about the throne and the claws of their
future subjects.
Well, that's what we're going to try
Sonny said stubbornly.
I think we can get them all together
especially if you guys help me.
But if you don't, it doesn't matter.
I'm doing it anyway.
She settled her wings back and looked at
her friends defiantly.
There was a long pause.
Sonny could imagine what they were
thinking, what they were about to say.
Oh sonny, it's a sweet idea, but it'll
never work.
You have too much faith in the goodness
of dragons.
You're so naive and ridiculous.
Why don't you work on a project here in
the rainforest instead, like counting
bananas or something?
Your crazy ideas and obsession with the
prophecy is just...
All right, said Clay.
I'm in.
Sonny's heart leaped.
She beamed at him.
Me too. said Starflight, struggling to
his feet.
It's worth a try.
I want it to work.
But you need to rest.
Fate speaker protested.
We need to be safe.
Starflight said, and we won't be safe, and
neither will our friends and all the
dragons who count on us until the war is
over.
I agree, said Glory.
I'll help too.
Although I can't leave my dragons here
for long, not with the night wings so
close by and not settled yet.
The Night Wings are your dragons too
now.
Deathbringer pointed out.
Sonny caught the way he looked at glory
and thought, what he really means is, I
am yours, now, and forever.
Is that how Starflight feels about me?
She glanced at him with his sad bandaged
eyes and determined expression.
I don't.
I don't think that's how I feel about
him.
I mean, I love him, but not like that.
Fine, tsunami said.
Fine, yes, of course I'm in.
It's never going to work, but I'll do it
whatever it is.
So, then, what are we doing?
Suddenly they were all looking at Sonny.
Even Starflight's face was tilted in her
direction.
You wanted their attention.
You wanted them to listen to you.
You'd better earn this.
We start by sending a message to Bern
Blister, and Blaze, she said firmly.
We start with blister, and we get to her
through the talons of peace.
Chapter 21.
This is awesome, Tsunami said.
I'm so excited.
Going to see my very favorite dragons in
all of Pyria.
Are you being glory now?
Sonny asked.
Queen of sarcasm?
I can be sarcastic too.
She doesn't get to be the queen of
everything, tsunami grumbled.
She tilted her wings to do another sweep
over the shoreline.
They were on the eastern outskirts of the
mud kingdom, on the edge of the kingdom
of the sea.
Below them, the ocean rushed up onto the
beach and then back, wave upon white
topped wave.
The sky was gray from edge to edge, and
the air was wet with something that
couldn't decide if it was mist or rain.
It was dreary.
Sunny missed the hot, dry desert.
You can even tell it was almost the
middle of the day.
The sun was well hidden behind those
ranks of clouds.
Her wings felt unpleasantly damp as she
circled around behind tsunami.
Where is that blasted mud wing?
Tsunami muttered, scanning the beach.
I wish we hadn't had to bring him, Sonny
said.
I'm not convinced he really knows where
he's going.
I wish we could have brought our mudwing
instead.
Our medwing doesn't know where the talons
of peace camp is, tsunami pointed out
ogre supposedly does.
Okre was the disagreeable mud wing Sonny
had met in the rainforest.
It turned out he was one of the alternate
dragonettes as well, so he'd grown up
with the talons of peace and had agreed
to go back to them and guide Sonny and
tsunami there.
The other 2 options, Flame and Fate
Speaker, had had slightly more violent
reactions.
Fate speaker had declared passionately
that she wouldn't leave Starflight's
side.
She said he needed her, which gave Sonny
another jealous twinge, and added that
the talents never particularly liked her
anyway.
Flame, on the other talon, had thrown an
entire bowl of mangoes at them, and
roared that he wasn't letting anyone see
him with his face all destroyed, least of
all the talons who'd just handed him over
to the stupid night wings in the 1st
place.
So they were stuck with ocher, which had
meant 3 days of travel with a dragonette
whom Sonny liked less and less.
He was like the not funny, not adorable
opposite of clay, constantly hungry, but
in a pushy way, instead of a sweetly
embarrassed way.
He'd even made himself a sack out of
leaves with a handle of vines that he
could hang over his neck, and he'd filled
this with half the fruits in the
rainforest as far as Sunny could tell.
That way he could eat and fly at the same
time, dripping bright yellow and purple
juice all over his brown scales, and
spattering the ground below them, and
incidentally, refusing to share.
Not that she wanted anything from a bag
he'd drooled all over anyway.
Besides, tsunami added, Glory still needs
clay back at camp to help with the night
wings, especially if Queen Scarlet is on
her way.
I don't understand why she hasn't come
after us yet, Sonny said with a shiver.
She glanced down at her own small
necklace, a pouch containing the dream
visitor.
They'd been using it for the last few
days to check in with her friends back in
the rainforest, but so far everything was
quiet there.
It made Sonny's scales feel wriggly and
oversized, not knowing where Scarlet was
and what she was plotting.
Tsunami followed her gaze to the dream
visitor pouch.
We could have avoided this whole trip, she
pointed out.
Sonny shook her head.
It's not safe.
If we used the dream visitor to contact
blister, or even the talons of peace, or
to check on Scarlet, they might catch a
glimpse of the rainforest and realize
where we are.
Like I figured out where the scavenger
was when she dream visited me.
Or Glory said she caught a glimpse of the
weird link tower behind Scarlet too.
We couldn't risk it.
I know.
Tsunami sighed.
So here we are, looking for the talents
of peace.
My, your favorite dragons.
Sonny finished for her.
I don't trust them, tsunami added.
That's why you're here, Sonny agreed.
Because you think otherwise they might
grab me and do something nefarious.
Trapping us in an underground cave for 6
years comes to mind.
Tsunami muttered.
Sunny squinted at a dark shape winging
out of the fog up ahead.
That's ogre, right?
And there's someone with him, tsunami
said.
Snapping her head up and frowning
fiercely.
A few someone's.
As the group of dragons came closer, she
humped with surprise.
I've seen that dragon before, she told
Sonny.
The one in the lead, the sea wing with
the black spirals on his gales.
I saw him meeting with riptide, the very
1st time I saw riptide in the kingdom of
the sea.
I didn't realize at the time that he was
with the talons of peace.
He's flashing something at us, Sonny
pointed out.
The sea wings glow in the dark scales
were lighting up in some kind of
pattern.
Tsunami growled.
If he's with the talons, he should know
that I don't understand aquatic, since he
was probably one of the squidheads who
made the decision not to teach it to me.
Maybe I should go over there and thump
him and then pretend I misunderstood what
he was saying.
I think he's just suggesting we land
Sonny guessed.
Since all the approaching dragons were
now veering down toward the beach.
Well, sure.
I could have figured that out, tsunami
said.
But he didn't have to rub my snout in a
ditty.
She flapped on ahead and Sonny followed.
They landed on the sand, which was wet
and clumpy between Sonny's claws.
Across from them were ogre and 5 dragons
from the talons of peace, an ice wing, a
sky wing, a sand wing, and 2 sea wings
one of them green with black spirals on
his scales, the other sky blue with dark
blue horns.
Wait, Sonny thought.
I know that other sea wing.
Riptide, tsunami cried.
The blue dragon's whole face lit up.
You're alive, he said, stepping forward.
That's far enough, said the other Sea
Wing. flaring one wing in riptide's way.
Of course I am, tsunami said to Riptide
ignoring the green dragon.
What are you doing with these?
Sonny kicked her as hard as she could.
Remember why we're here, tsunami.
No insulting the dragons were asking for
help.
Tsunami glared at her, but she seemed to
get the message.
With the talons of peace, she finished.
Queen Carl threw me out.
Riptide said sadly, furrowing lines in
the sand with his claws.
She considered killing me, or imprisoning
me again, but she said I'd fought bravely
in the Battle of the Summer Palace, so
she let me leave with my life.
I didn't know where else to go.
I thought the talons might know where you
were, but he trailed off.
But we had no idea.
Said the other Seawing, in a clipped, cold
voice.
Tsunami gave him an incredulous look.
You're not seriously mad at us, are you?
Because no, I am mad at you.
That's how this works.
This is Nautilus.
Riptide interjected quickly, the leader
of the talons of peace.
For now, growled the Sky Wing, flicking
her red tail back and forth, and
glowering through a trail of smoke.
Do you have the other dragonettes?
She choked her head at ocher, who was
munching his way through a banana, and
eyeing the seashells around his claws, as
if he was wondering whether they might be
edible too.
We don't have them, tsunami said.
But we know where 2 of them are, Sonny
added.
Our friends help them get away from the
night wings.
They didn't want to come back here though
tsunami said.
We offered.
The Skywings scowled at her.
Which two?
Is Viper one of them?
demanded the Sandwing.
Uh-oh.
Sunny thought.
She shook her head, but before she could
answer, the ice wing hissed, there's a
dragon coming this way.
They all turned and saw someone flying
over the cliffs around the beach, high
above their heads.
The sun caught on red scales, and all the
dragons on the sand tensed.
Is it a Skywing Scout?
One of Ruby's soldiers, or someone
working for Bern?
Or Queen Scarlet?
Sonny thought worriedly, before she
realized this dragon was smaller and a
different color.
He was also clearly heading toward them
as if he'd been watching them for a
while.
That looks like flame, said the Skywing
squinting.
But it can't be.
What's wrong with his face?
It might be flame.
Sonny said, glancing at tsunami.
He could have followed us.
Maybe he changed his mind about coming
back.
Maybe he just didn't want to fly with us
tsunami said, or with him anyway.
She flipped her tail at ochre.
Flame called the Sky Wing.
Flame.
The dragonette was soaring down toward
the sand now.
When he heard his name, he faltered in
mid-flight and nearly crash landed on the
dunes.
Mother, he called back, wobbling upright
again.
The Sky Wing shoved past Sunny and
Tsunami, and caught Flame as he dropped
toward her.
She let out a roar at the side of his
face.
What happened to you?
Who did this?
She wrapped her wings around him and
pulled him close.
Flame seemed to collapse into her, burying
his head in her neck.
Sonny heard muffled sobbing, and felt a
wrenching stab of pity for the sky wing
dragonette.
She'd only ever seen his mean, prickly
grouchy side, but clearly he could be
someone else with someone who really
cared about him.
I miss my mother, she thought, wishing
she had large, warm wings wrapped around
her right then.
I guess I've always missed her, but I
miss her even more now that I know her.
Thorn was so far away, on the other side
of the continent.
Sonny folded back her wings and lifted
her chin.
I'll see her again soon.
As soon as this war is over.
That's avalanche.
Riptide said quietly to tsunami, nodding
at flames, mother.
She's a spy, so she normally lives in the
Sky Palace, and she left Flame here to
keep him out of the war.
He hesitated.
She was away when Maru Seer came and took
the dragonettes.
She was furious when she came back and
found him gone.
She nearly killed Nautilus.
Nautilus shifted uneasily on his talons.
Some dragons don't understand the things
we have to do for peace, he said, but not
in a way that sounded like he meant it.
Do. Do I want to know what happened to
the others?
he asked.
Fate speaker is fine.
Sonny said, but we don't know what
happened to Squid, and Viper is dead.
The sand wing across from her snarled and
raised his venomous tail.
How?
An accident in the night kingdom, tsunami
answered.
Piper was fighting and fell into some
lava.
It was her tail that did that to Flame's
face.
We need Morrow seer.
Nautilus growled.
Several of us would like to have words
with him.
Words and teeth and claws.
And tails, added the sandwing.
He looked angry, but not devastated.
Sonny wondered if he was an uncle instead
of Viper's father or something like
that.
Marosir is dead too, Sonny said.
So we need your help.
Oh, really?
said Nautilus.
Suddenly, the wonderful independent
dragonettes need us.
Don't be a rotting tooth, Tsunami said to
him.
If you want this prophecy fulfilled and
this war stopped, you'll help us, so shut
up.
He opened and closed his mouth a few
times, then settled for flashing
something with his luminescent stripes
that Sunny guessed she wouldn't want
translated.
We need to send a message to Blister, she
said.
You're the only ones we could think of
who might be able to reach her.
She's looking for you pretty seriously
Riptide said.
You probably just have to stand out in
the open for a day and she'll land on
you.
Right, sure.
Tsunami answered, except we're trying to
do this in a not ending a dead way?
Fair enough, he said.
Good idea.
I support that plan.
What do you want us to tell her?
Nautilus asked.
If we can get in touch with her.
And if we agree to do this.
Sonny looked him in the eye, knowing
perfectly well that he'd do anything she
said if it meant a chance at peace.
He may have made some terrible decisions
over the last 7 years, but she believed
that he did care about one thing very
much, and that was ending the war.
Tell her to meet us on the 10th midnight
from tonight. she said, in the entrance
courtyard of the stronghold in the
kingdom of sand.
If she doesn't show up, she forfeits her
chance to be Queen.
This is it?
The sand wing demanded.
You're fulfilling the prophecy in
choosing a queen?
It's blister.
Come along and see, Sonny offered.
Anyone who wants to?
Bring all the talents of peace.
If it goes the way it should, you won't
be fugitives anymore.
If blister shows up and everything goes
as planned, then the war will be over.
We'll think about it, Nautilus said.
But even he had an unmistakable
undercurrent of excitement in his voice.
It's important to tell her, Sonny
insisted, we don't know how else to reach
her.
We're not like friends with her, Riptide
said, just so you know.
It's not like the talons of peace are
working with her, I swear.
But you can find her?
Tsunami asked.
She sends one of her soldiers to the
ruins of the summer palace pretty much
every day, Nautilus said, hoping for a
message from Queen Coral.
That's how we'll reach her.
Good, tsunami said.
Thank you, Sonny added.
She turned to tsunami.
Then we'd better go.
So we can send our messages to the other
2 sisters.
We only have 10 days now.
Tsunami swept her tail through the sand
and looked over at Riptide.
I could come with you.
He said hesitantly, as if he wasn't sure
he'd be welcome.
I think, tsunami said, it'd be better if
you stay and make sure blister shows up
at the stronghold.
Then bring some of the talons of peace
with you.
And I'll see you there.
He nodded, tilting his wings back with a
hopeful expression.
Alright, tsunami said.
See you soon.
It sounded like a promise.
Bye, Ocher, Sonny said, making one last
effort to be friendly to the unlikable
dragon.
The mud wing had gotten his claws stuck
in a pineapple as he tried to peel it and
was now trying to shake it off.
Have a nice life.
Yeah, yeah, he muttered.
He accidentally whacked himself in the
snout with the top of the pineapple and
yelped with pain.
Tsunami and Sonny rolled their eyes at
each other and lifted off into the sky.
They flew over Flame and his mother, still
wrapped around each other on the beach.
Sonny felt another jab of pity, although
she knew the Sky Wing dragonette didn't
want to be seen that way.
She glanced back as they reached the edge
of the beach, and saw that the other
dragons had turned to leave, but riptide
was still staring after them.
Are you all right?
Sonny asked tsunami.
I mean, about riptide?
Have you forgiven him for lying to about
being a talent?
Tsunami gave her a rueful look?
It's complicated, she said.
I hate being lied to, and the talons are
the worst, but when I saw that he was
alive, I was just really, really happy.
Is that weird?
No, Sonny said.
I know what you mean.
I'll see how I feel after the war is over
tsunami said.
When everything's a little more normal.
Not that we know anything about normal or
what that's supposed to look like, right?
But then I think, well, we'll see.
I hope blister shows up.
Sonny said, as they soared up over the
cliffs.
I hope this works.
It will, tsunami said confidently.
We'll get all 3 sisters to the
stronghold.
I'm not worried about that.
What happens once we're all there
though?
That part worries me quite a lot.
Chapter 22.
In some ways, burn and blades should have
been easier to send a message to.
They both had a fixed home base. burn at
the stronghold, blaze in her fortress in
the ice kingdom, but Sonny was not about
to waltz into either place, and she
didn't want to send anyone she knew to
face them.
She didn't trust Bern or Queen Glacier
not to just kill the messenger.
After a lot of arguing, though, Glory had
offered a solution for Blaze.
Sanda Rainwing disguised as an ice wing
to pass the message along.
Send me, was her actual suggestion.
I could be there and back in a couple of
days.
Absolutely not.
Deathbringer had said.
You are the dragon holding this
rainforest together.
Two tribes depend on you.
If anything happens, you're leaving chaos
behind, and Blaze will probably recognize
you.
True, Clay had agreed, but you could send
someone else.
Maybe Jambu?
He's been there before.
Sonny pointed out.
He knows where Blaze's fortress is.
He's already changed his scales to look
like an ice wing, so he should be able to
do it again.
Glory snorted.
As long as he doesn't fall asleep or get
distracted by something shiny.
Or I could go, Deathbringer offered.
I know where it is too.
Absolutely not.
Glory had echoed back at him, only half
teasing.
Remember the part where you tried to kill
Blaze?
You're the last dragon she'd trust.
Glacier probably has soldiers prepared to
kill you on site.
She's probably told them to kill any
night wing who comes along just in case
it's you.
Oh, Deathbringer said.
You totally care if I live or die too.
Sonny could practically see the struggle
in glory's scales, as she tried to stamp
out any bits of pink that were trying to
sneak through.
Well, sure, she said.
A dead messenger wouldn't do us much good
at all.
Deathbringer laughed, and Sunny realized
that he was deliberately provoking glory
because he liked the way she shot him
down.
If that's what he's looking for in a
dragon, she thought, he certainly picked
the right one.
Send Jambu and Mangrove.
Sonny suggested.
They both know the way, and they can keep
an eye on each other.
Everyone had agreed to this plan
including Jambu and Mangrove, but Sonny
still felt anxious as she watched the 2
rain wings slip into the tunnel that led
to the kingdom of sand.
It was the day she and tsunami got back
from the talons of peace.
The flight had taken them 3 days with
almost no stops.
Seven to go, she thought.
Be safe.
Glory said to them, that's an order from
your queen.
Yes, Your Majesty, Jambu answered.
Grinning in a way that suggested he just
liked saying those words, not that he was
actually listening.
Steak camouflaged as much as you can. the
whole way there, and you don't have to go
into the fortress, or even all the way to
the fortress.
If you find an ice wing patrol before you
get there, tell them to tell Blaze, and
then you come home, right away.
Understand?
Yep, said Mangrove.
We still understand, like we did 5
minutes ago when you last explained it.
And 5 minutes before that.
And all right, go away, Glory said
flicking her tongue out at them.
Remember to tell them she has to show up
Sonny called, or else she doesn't get to
be queen.
Make sure that part of the message gets
to Glacier.
She was the least sure about Blaise, who
seemed perfectly happy to hide in her
fortress and let other dragons do all the
fighting for her.
If she was going to show up, Sonny had a
feeling it would be only because Queen
Glacier dragged her there.
As soon as their tails had disappeared
Sonny turned to clay.
Ready?
Sure, Clay said.
I mean, I've eaten breakfast.
What else do I need to do?
Oh, maybe some more breakfast.
That's a good idea.
Sonny laughed, and soon the 2 of them
were aloft, soaring north through the
rainforest toward the mud kingdom.
Do you think anyone will listen to us?
Clay asked her after they'd flown for a
while.
The landscape below was shifting from
jungle to swamp, with shorter trees and
brownish green ponds visible here and
there.
In the distance to their right, they
could see a shimmer of water that had to
be the big lake.
That's where Queen Morin's palace was.
They were definitely not going there.
Sunny tilted her wings to the west
heading for the mountains.
I think someone will listen, she said.
We just have to find the right someone, a
mudwing patrol, I think, not Skywings or
Sandwings.
I bet they'll listen to you anyway.
As far as she was concerned, Clay could
talk anyone into anything, because anyone
could see that he was sincere and wanted
the best for everybody.
Clay rumbled nervously deep in his throat
maybe we don't have to do this.
Maybe Bern will stay in her stronghold
and just be there when we get there.
She's more likely to go out again, looking
for another battle, Sonny said.
She thought for a moment, then added, or
looking for us.
No, we have to make sure she'll be there
in 7 days, or this won't work.
They found a sheltered grove of pines at
the foot of the mountains where they
could sleep that night.
There had been surprisingly few dragons
out that day, a few solitary scouts, and
some 2 dragon patrols, but Sunny had
decided to avoid them all.
She wanted to get farther away from
Morehen's palace, just in case anyone
tried to drag her and Clay back there.
She'd expected to see more soldiers out
and about, though.
It was a little unsettling how quiet the
skies were.
Clay was thoughtfully watching the stars
as she curled up against him in the
dark.
Sonny, he whispered.
I know I'm bad at remembering stuff, but
Pyre only has 3 moons, right?
Of course, she whispered back.
Why?
That thing over there, he said. pointing
with one of his wings.
It looks kind of like a moon coming this
way.
Sunny followed his gaze to a glowing
shape in the sky.
It was bigger than the other stars
although not quite as big or round as a
moon.
She couldn't remember ever noticing it
before.
Freaky, she said.
I wonder what it is.
Not one of the regular moons.
Look, you can see all the others there
and there, and over there, right on the
edge of the mountains.
None of them were full, but 2 of them
were more than halfway there, and filled
the sky with light.
I might fly up the mountain a ways and
take a closer look, Clay said, is that
all right?
Sure, Sonny said, sitting up.
I'll come with you.
They climbed higher and higher, looking
for a clear view of the sky, and finally
stopped on a ledge not far from the
peak.
Clay seemed almost entranced by the
strange new thing in the sky.
And so it was Sonny who looked down, and
gasped, and grabbed his arm and pointed.
Clay, look, she whispered.
The valley below them was dotted with
fires, almost like a lake reflecting the
stars above, but they could clearly see
the shapes of dragons gathered around
those fires, and the glint of weapons
being polished and sharpened and ready
for battle.
That's where they all are, Sonny
whispered.
The mud wings are gathering for
something.
This must be almost their whole army.
Clay stared down at them, his tail
twitching.
That could have been him down there, she
realized.
If there had been no prophecy, he'd have
grown up like any ordinary mudwing, he'd
have led his brothers and sisters into
battle.
He'd have fought and died for Queen Morin
and by extension, her ally, Bern.
They're planning something big, Clay said
I wonder how soon.
Let's go find out, Sonny suggested
spreading her wings, but you.
He started.
I'm just a sandwing, she said, I could be
your ally.
In the dark, maybe no one will look twice
at my tail.
She curled it up in an imitation of the
scorpion like way the sand wings often
held their tails.
After some arguing, she won the debate
and they flew down to the mudwing camp as
cautiously and quietly as they could
move.
There didn't seem to be any guards on the
outskirts, and they slipped in among the
campfires on silent feet.
Many of the dragons around them were
sleeping, although Sonny saw at least one
member awake in each small group.
She remembered what they'd learned about
mud wings in Clay's home village.
Each troop was made up of brothers and
sisters, who fought alongside one another
through thick and thin, led by whichever
one was the biggest, their big wings.
Someone here could pass a message to burn
she whispered to Clay, but how do we
decide who?
And what if they're all going off to a
battle tomorrow?
Do you think we can stop them?
She had to hurry to keep up with Clay's
longer strides.
He was pacing purposefully through the
camp, studying each group of dragons, and
she wasn't sure he was even really
listening to her.
Oh, she thought, I'm an idiot, of
course.
Of course, he was looking for his
brothers and sisters.
He'd only met them once, but they were
often on his mind.
He'd wondered aloud about them several
times in the last few weeks.
Sunny hadn't met them, so she couldn't
help him search, but she stayed close on
his heels as they walked and walked
through the camp, which was even bigger
than it had looked from up on the
mountain.
Here and there she spotted sand wings and
sky wings as well, which made her feel
less conspicuous at least.
Suddenly, Clay stopped and blocked her
path with his tail.
He nodded at a group of 5 dragons
clustered around a fire, drawing
formation plans in the dirt.
Is that them?
Sonny asked softly.
He nodded, then started forward again.
Read.
He whispered from the shadows.
Shh.
Don't call out.
It clay.
All 5 dragons whirled toward him as he
stepped into the circle of light.
Clay, yelped the smallest one quietly.
He jumped over the fire and bounced
around Clay, stepping on his talons a few
times by accident.
Hey, Omber, Clay said affectionately
punching the little dragon gently on the
shoulder.
Everyone, this is sunny.
Reed is the big wings.
My sisters are Sora and Pheasant, and my
3rd brother is Marsh.
Hi, Sunny whispered to all of them
nodding at each of the trusting brown
eyed faces.
It's great to finally meet you.
The way they looked at clay.
There was a bit of terrifying hope there
as if they were expecting him to come
with extra fireproof scales to protect
them all.
Are you all right?
Reed asked.
He was almost, but not quite as big as
clay.
And he held his head up and shoulders
back, as if he was very aware that he
shouldn't have been the big wings.
But he too looked at clay with hope
rather than envy or worry.
We've been wondering, we've heard
rumors.
Oh, we're fine.
Clay said.
Indestructible.
Don't you worry.
He grinned at Reed, nudging his side.
What is all this?
Why are you here?
The 5 mudwings exchanged looks, as if
they weren't sure whether to answer that
question.
Would it be treason to their queen?
Or loyalty to their brother?
Reed was the one who nodded.
Yes.
Tell them.
A huge offensive, pheasant said, her
voice shaded with anxiety and fear and
resignation.
Wipe out as many ice wings as we can in
one huge sweep, and hope we kill Blaze
while we're at it.
Queen Morin is leading us herself, said
Reed, and Queen Ruby is supposed to bring
her troops over to attack from the
north.
The order that came down was, we keep
fighting, as long as any enemies are left
alive.
Take no prisoners, Zora whispered
shuddering.
Kill everyone.
Byrne wants to end the war fast before
you guys miss everything up, Umber
added.
That's the word going around the camp
anyway.
And as long as the sea wings are still in
hiding.
She can focus all her energy on the ice
kingdom, Reed explained. on destroying
them.
Every last ice wing, Marsh finished
unless we all die first.
He stared into the flames of their
campfire.
The 3 moons were not enough to combat the
dark that was pressing in around them
like shadow wings folding over their
heads.
The fire flickered and spat, illuminating
amber underscales and dark brown tails
and waves of orange light.
You can't do that, Sonny said.
She could hear her voice shaking.
All of you against the ice wings?
You really might wipe them out.
The entire tribe.
And so many of you will die trying, Clay
said, reaching one wing around Umber.
It's so cold in the Ice Kingdom.
We were there, just on the outskirts, and
it was freezing.
Imagine how much worse it'll be right in
the heart of it or up by Glacier's
palace.
Hundreds of dragons will freeze to
death.
You might.
You mustn't.
He broke off, clearing his throat.
Marsh and Sora shuffled closer to him, and
he spread his other wing to go awkwardly
around them as well.
He's right, Sonny said.
This is a suicide mission.
Suicide or genocide?
Those are your only 2 outcomes.
Clay, we can't let this happen.
What else can we do?
Reed demanded.
We're part of an army.
These are our orders.
Orders from our queen.
You could run away, Clay said.
Come with us.
We'll hide you.
We can, but you know that's not good
enough, Seni said to him.
We have to stop this from happening at
all.
There's 5 of us against Queen Morhen.
Queen Ruby, and all of Burns army.
Reed pointed out.
Who's going to listen to us?
I'm sure you're not the only one who are
worried, Senny said.
She twisted to look at the fires all
around them, and wondered how many of the
sleeping dragons were caught in
nightmares about the battles to come.
Nightmares.
She touched the pouch around her throat, a
possible idea was starting to come to
her.
When are you supposed to attack?
Clay asked.
We move out tomorrow morning?
Pheasant answered.
A few days to cross the mountains in the
desert, those who make it, and then we'll
be at the ice kingdom.
So we have to do something about it now
Sunny said, standing up and pacing around
the fire.
Where is Queen Mohan?
Is she here?
Do you know?
Reed and the others looked alarmed, apart
from Umber, who looked excited.
You can't just go talk to the Queen, Reed
said.
She'll never let you get away.
There are orders to capture you all if
anyone sees you.
Although everyone's looking for 5
dragonets together, and most dragons
don't know what you look like.
But if you walk right into her camp, you
might as well put on your own chains.
We're not going to do that, Sonny
promised.
I have a plan.
A sort of a plan, a something worth
trying anyway.
So which way is she?
Umber flicked his tail toward the center
of camp.
Right in the middle of everything, he
said, like a real big wings.
Please don't kill her.
Sora said softly.
She's not a bad queen.
We're not going to, Clay assured her, we
would never. don't do that.
We'll be back, Sonny promised them.
She plunged into the darkness with Clay
close behind her, weaving between the
fires again.
Do you really have a sort of plan?
Clay asked.
Because I have no plan.
Except maybe a throwing up So nervous
plan.
I do, Sonny said, curling her claws
around the dream visitor.
I just have to see the queen and make
sure she's sleeping.
Oh, Clay said.
Aha.
He took the lead, adjusting their
direction, and soon they saw a brightly
burning circle of fires ahead of them.
Wide awake guards were posted between the
fires, staring alertly out of the camp
and up at the sky.
But beyond the guards, they could see a
huge dragon, as big as morrow seer, curled
in a slumbering ball.
Firelight reflected off her russet scales
and caught the glitter of gemstones on
her ankles and head.
The spines on her back moved slowly up
and down as she breathed.
Clustered around her were 4 other dragons
all smaller than her, all glittering with
gems and sleeping as well.
Her brothers and sisters?
Sonny guest.
They stopped well out of sight of the
guards, studying the royal camp.
Clay nodded.
I think so.
He grinned.
If Starflight were here.
He could tell us all their names and
personal histories, and what they each
eat for breakfast every day.
Sonny grinned back, although inside, her
stomach felt as though it were trying to
eat itself.
I remember one thing I read, she said.
It said that no mudwing queen has ever
been challenged by a sister, only
daughters.
I didn't understand it then, but I do
now.
In your tribe.
Brothers and sisters are always loyal to
one another.
A sister would never try to take the
throne from her big wings.
Clay nodded.
That feels right to me, he said.
Sonny stared at the queen, trying to
memorize her features or what she could
see of them.
Would this work?
Was she really going to risk it?
The image of 100s of ice wing corpses
flashed through her head.
Of course I am.
Struck by another idea, she studied all
the queen's brothers and sisters too.
She wondered how many times the dream
visitor could be used in one night.
All right, she said, pulling clay away.
They chose the darkest patch of shadow
they could find outside the camp with the
mountains looming over them.
Maybe you should be the one to do this
she whispered to Clay, trying to pass him
the dream visitor.
He shook his head and pushed it back to
her.
You've used it before, and you'll know
what to say.
And if it's me, well, she might think
it's a normal dream.
Just another mud wing, voicing her inner
anxieties or something.
But if it's you, she'll know it's real.
A real message from the dragonettes
because nobody else looks like you.
That's true, Sunny thought, and then
Riley.
So maybe there is a good reason to look
this weird after all.
You can do it, Sonny.
Clay said.
I'm completely sure.
He twined his tail around hers, and she
felt a tiny bit less terrified.
Sonny cupped her talons around the dream
visitor and held it to her head, closing
her eyes.
She'd only ever used it on her friends.
Please let this work.
She prayed.
She thought of the huge brown dragon
she'd just seen.
Queen Morin.
Let me in.
After a long moment, she opened her eyes
and found herself standing ankle deep in
mud.
Mud stretched around her, and endless
warm swamp dotted with mangroves, and
dozing crocodiles.
The sun was high above them in a hazy sky
and insects buzzed through the long
cattails.
Sonny turned in a circle and spotted
Queen Mohen pacing across a dry island
that stuck out of the mud.
Several scrolls were scattered around her
talons, many of them covered in brown
spatters, and a large map of Pyria was
scratched into the dirt.
The queen lashed her tail and drew long
lines with her claws across the mountains
furrowing them through the sketched out
kingdom of sand, and then slashing
furiously at the corner of the map that
represented the ice kingdom.
She stopped, shook her head, and glanced
down at the mud.
With a jolt of horror, Sonny realized
that there were dead bodies lying half
submerged around the Queen's Island.
She recognized at least one of them as
one of the queen's brothers, who'd been
sleeping nearby in the royal camp.
This is a real nightmare.
She might not be able to hear me.
But Sonny had to try.
She waited through the mud, which felt
gloppily real against her scales and
clambered up onto the island behind the
mud wing queen.
Mohan whirled around and stared at her.
Sonny spread her talons.
I'm harmless, she said, I'm here to
talk.
Here, now, the queen demanded.
Can't you see?
in the middle of a campaign, and everyone
is dying, and it's all my fault, and I
can't save them.
She slashed her claws across the kingdom
of sand, and turned to look down into the
mud again.
Her wings trembled, and she lowered her
snout to the closest corpse.
No, no, I command you not to die.
This is a dream, Sonny said firmly and
loudly.
You're only dreaming, I promise you.
The queen drew back from the corpse.
Hmm, she said.
It's a nightmare, Sonny said, but they're
not dead.
Your brothers and sisters are asleep
right beside you in the camp.
They're safe, at least for now.
What does that mean?
Queen Morhen asked.
Her voice sounded less strained, and her
wings were relaxing.
Is that a threat?
Not at all, Sonny said hastily.
I want them to be safe too.
I want all your subjects to be safe.
That's why I'm here.
The queen looked up at the sky, then
around at the swamp, down at the map, and
back at Sunny.
This is really a dream.
Then how are you here?
Old magic, Sonny said.
But that's not important.
Do you know who I am?
I have a guess, said the queen.
Shouldn't there be 5 of you?
There are 5 of us, Sonny said.
But I'm the one here talking to you.
I'm here to tell you not to attack the
Ice Kingdom.
Not tomorrow?
Not ever.
Too many dragons will die if you do, on
both sides.
Is that an omen?
Queen Morhen asked.
Did your night wing tell you that?
You know it doesn't take a nightwing
prophecy to see that future, Sonny said.
Touching one claw lightly to the
scratched up map beside her.
You know how many of your dragons you'll
lose.
The queen drew a line in the dirt in
front of her.
But then the war will be over, and
perhaps that'll be worth it.
Bern has promised us immunity from attack
for the next 100 years if we help her
win.
If we don't, she'll destroy us.
She is a powerful enemy, Little
Sandwing.
A lot more powerful than you, and she's
an enemy I don't intend to make.
You don't have to, Sonny said, thinking
that's how Bern got her mudwing alliance
with intimidation and threats?
So Queen Morhen joined the war to protect
her dragons.
It sounds backward, but I can see it.
We're going to end the war.
We have a message for Bern.
Meet us at midnight in 7 days time in the
main courtyard of her stronghold.
If you can tell her to do that, instead
of attacking the ice wings, we'll find a
way to stop the war.
And you can come too.
We want everyone to see that this is the
end of the fighting.
No more dragons have to die.
Queen Morhen tilted her head with a
skeptical expression.
It sounds like a tail, from one of the
sea wing queen's silly romantic scrolls.
What are you planning to do?
You'll see.
Sonny said.
Just be there.
Be there instead of watching your dragons
die in the ice kingdom.
Bring the sky wings too.
Everyone who wants this war to be over.
The queen nodded slowly.
I'll think about it.
Are you choosing burn then?
We are choosing peace, Sonny said.
That's the important thing.
That sounds like you're avoiding the
question.
Morehen pointed out.
Does it matter?
Sonny asked.
As long as the war is over?
The queen thought for a long time and
inside.
Perhaps not.
Make sure Bern is there, Sonny said.
It's important.
It sounds like it, said the mud wing
queen.
She brushed her tail over the map of
Pyria, erasing it, and all the agonized
claw marks she'd drawn on it.
I'll see what I can do.
That sounded a little ridiculous to
Sonny.
If the queen of the mudwings couldn't do
as she'd asked, then what chance did
anyone have?
But she didn't say that.
She bowed and stepped back.
Thank you, Your Majesty, she said
instead.
Good luck, said the queen.
You're very small to be in charge of
saving the world.
And weird looking, Sonny agreed, but we
can do it if everyone helps.
Hmm.
Queen Morhen pulled her wings in close
and stared down at the mud covered bodies
of her brothers and sisters all around
her.
Maybe.
As Sonny lifted the dream visitor away
from her head, stepping out of the dream
she thought she heard the queen whisper
one last thing.
I hope so.
Chapter 23.
Sonny was tired after visiting the
queen's dream, but she made herself step
into the dreams of the royal siblings
next.
Three brothers and one sister, all of
them having similar anxiety dreams, most
of them about Queen Morhen dying in some
awful way.
One of the brothers was having such a
terrible nightmare that Sonny wasn't able
to get through to him at all.
But the others saw her, and they seemed
to listen to what she said.
They each answered that it was up to
Morehen to make the decision, but Sonny
had a feeling the queen would listen to
her siblings more than any other advisor
she might have, and if they could
persuade her.
Well, it was worth the chance.
After that, as she and Clay were walking
back through the camp, passed so many
sleeping dragons, she stopped, brushing
his wing with hers.
We can do more, she said.
Not all of them, but if even a few
dragons talk about having dream messages
from us, Maybe that'll make a
difference.
Aren't you tired?
Clay asked.
You look like you haven't slept in a
week?
There had been a lot of exhausting flying
lately.
More than she was used to, and all she
wanted was to curl up under Clay's wing
and sleep for the next month, but that
was not an option.
I can do it, she assured him.
Let me do some too, he said, holding out
his talons.
You can rest while I do that.
They chose sleeping dragons at random
standing in the shadows nearby, and
dropping lightly into their dreams.
Most of them were nightmares.
There were nightmares all through the
camp.
Sometimes Sonny could break through and
show them they were dreaming, and then
they would listen.
She kept her messages brief.
The war is almost over.
No more killing.
Don't go to the ice kingdom.
The war will be over soon.
You can help.
Stop fighting, spread the word.
They found Reed and the others again as
early morning light was beginning to
creep across the camp.
Umber, Marsh, and Sora were fast asleep
in a pile of tails and wings, but
Pheasant and Reed were awake, watching
for them with matching, anxious
expressions.
We did our best, Clay whispered, pressing
their talons in his.
Hopefully, you'll get new orders soon.
But we should go before we're seen, Sonny
said.
Do you want to come with us?
Clay asked.
Reed sighed, and looked at his sleeping
brothers and sister.
No, I mean, I do, but we are loyal to the
queen, and we don't want to be
fugitives.
I wish I could at least give you Umber or
Marsh, but they won't leave the rest of
us.
We stick together.
That's our way.
I'm sorry, Clay said reluctantly.
I wish I could stay.
If you do have to fight.
I wish I could be there with you.
Me too, Reed admitted, in a low voice.
Pheasant shook her head, but didn't say
anything.
She nudged the others away, and they each
hugged Clay goodbye.
See you soon, Sunny said, trying to sound
more hopeful than she felt.
Be safe, Clay said.
I'm glad you have Reed.
He wrapped his wings around his brother
again.
And then he and Sonny hurried off through
the camp toward the safety of the
mountains.
They stayed on the ground, afraid that
the guards would spot them if they flew
this close to the camp.
Most of the campfires were now just dying
embers, but a few had been rebuilt, and
the smell of roasting meat and smoke
floated through the pre-dawn air.
Birds fluttered and chirped in the trees
at half hearted intervals, as if they
weren't sure they should be awake yet.
Sunny's eyes ached, and her wings had
never felt heavier.
They had reached the scrub brush on the
hills overlooking the camp, when Sunny
heard a different sound coming from
behind them, not the rustling and
stamping of dragons, or the clanking of
weapons.
She heard singing.
Oh, the dragonettes are coming.
Clay, she whispered.
Do you hear that?
Am I imagining it?
He stopped and lifted his head to
listen.
They're coming to save the day.
Voices in the camp below, more than one
in different parts of the camp.
The mud wings were singing.
They're coming to fight, for they know
what's right.
It was the eerie version they'd last
heard in the Sky Palace, not the usual
rousing bar song that tsunami used to
sing around the cave whenever she wanted
to annoy the Guardians.
Sutny had been trapped in her bird cage
alone.
On display above the banquet, Scarlet was
holding for Bern.
But everyone there had heard it.
The sound of the prisoners singing
echoing over the cliffs in the night.
Sonny could remember the shivery, hopeful
feeling it had given her, and she also
remembered the expressions on some of the
soldiers' faces, hope, dread, longing.
Most of them much more complicated than
the pure fury visible on Scarlet and
Burn.
She felt it again now, like sand
trickling across her scales all the way
down her spine.
Those dragons singing.
Those were the dragons who believed in
them.
They were the reason she and her friends
had to do this.
I hope we can do this.
I really, really hope we can do this.
She glanced up at Clay, who smiled at
her.
Just being near him made her feel like
anything was possible.
Clay was so real and solid, and
dependable, and kind.
He would always be there.
Clay had kept all of them from killing
each other as they grew up under the
mountain, trapped with only one another
and their guardians.
If he hadn't been there, would they have
been more like the alternates?
The fake dragonettes of destiny, who'd
hated one another?
Kutsunami, glory, and Starflight have
turned out that way, hostile and
aggressive, and angry all the time, if
they hadn't had clay to keep them
together.
Would Sonny have ended up like fate
speaker, clinging to a belief in a
friendship and loyalty that didn't
exist?
But that hadn't happened.
They'd had clay.
And he stopped them from fighting too
much, and he made jokes when anyone was
sad, and he made them care about one
another, and he believed in all of them.
He'd made them a family, even though they
were from different tribes.
He really is our big wings.
Let's get back to the others, she said
and he nodded, and soon they were winging
their way back to the rainforest.
Six more days.
We can do this.
She's not coming?
Sonny cried.
What do you mean she's not coming?
A shower of raindrops pattered over her
wings, sending pink and red hibiscus
flowers whirling down past her toward the
ground far below.
Jambu shook his head, looking very
literally blue from horns to tail.
We tried, but every ice wing we talked to
basically laughed at us.
They said Blaze never leaves her fortress
and she won't until Glacier lets her go
which will be when burn and blister are
dead.
They know if she gets near one of her
sisters.
She's dead, Mangrove said.
She doesn't stand a chance in a challenge
duel.
Then why do the ice wing support her?
Glory said crossly.
Don't they want the sandwings to have a
strong queen?
No, of course they don't.
She answered herself. figuring it out as
she spoke.
The one kingdom they share a border
with.
Wouldn't it be great if it happened to be
ruled by a vain, silly dragon, who was
totally in debt to them and did
everything their queen ordered, maddening
for us, but sensible for them.
Queen Glacier knows what she's doing.
Unless she loses, like if Blaise happened
to die somehow, in which case she'd have
to deal with Burr right on her border, all
enraged and looking for vengeance.
All right, yes, I can see why she'd keep
her safely locked up.
Three moons.
That was like watching her brain work on
the outside of her head.
Fate speaker said to Starflight.
Well, we can't let her stay all locked up
Sonny said.
It's not going to work unless all 3
sisters are there, right?
Don't you agree?
Yes, Glory said.
And tsunami and Starflight nodded as
well.
If what you want is to forge a peace
treaty, All the combatants need to be
present to agree to it.
Glory scratched her snout, thinking
perhaps it would be enough to have Queen
Glacier there.
But I don't think so.
Glacier would know that it would look
like weakness to come in her place and
let Blaze stay in hiding, safer for
neither of them to show up.
But doesn't Queen Glacier want to end the
war too?
Sonny said.
I'm sure she does.
I'm especially sure she would if she knew
what burn and the mud wings were planning
a few days ago, even if they've put off
their invasion plans for now.
Are we sure about that?
Starflight asked.
They're really not invading?
It doesn't look like it, Glory said.
On her shoulder.
Her sloth woke up, chirruped sleepily, and
tucked itself closer to her wing before
closing its eyes again.
We've dream visited with Clay's brother
and also sent out scouts to check.
It seems like that mud wing camp is in a
holding pattern.
No one flying off to kill ice wings, at
least for now.
Queen Morehen is waiting to see what
happens at the stronghold, Sonny said
shaking loose flowers off her wings, which
means our plan really has to work, or
else the invasion might still happen.
Maybe if we could tell Queen Glacier that
she'd let Blaze come.
Maybe, tsunami said, but we can't get to
the queen if she's in her ice palace.
Not that it would be safe to go talk to
her no matter where she is.
And none of us have seen her.
So we can't even dream visitor.
Clay pointed out.
But we can dream visit Blaze, Sonny
said.
I think that's what we have to do.
Glory, you should do it.
You really convincing.
Glory looked down at the sapphire as then
he passed it to her.
She thought for a moment, then shook her
head.
No, she won't listen to me.
She kept saying, I shouldn't be part of
the prophecy, remember?
She wouldn't take me seriously.
And she's jealous of glory.
Death bringer interjected.
Blaze doesn't like any dragons prettier
than she is.
Which glory is.
Not that I've noticed myself personally.
It's just a fact.
Enough out of you.
Glory said, folding her wings in, but not
before Sonny spotted the hints of pink
blooming along the edges.
I've already said you can be the night
wing liaison, so flattery won't get you
anything else, Mr. Clever Scales.
It's not flattery to state the obvious. he
said.
It should be sunny or tsunami.
Glory said, ignoring him and passing the
sapphire back into Sonny's talons.
Tsunami actually got wounded trying to
help her. so she might be impressed by
that.
But then, tsunami is about as diplomatic
as a starving rhinoceros, so I'd probably
vote for Sonny.
I beg your pardon.
Tsunami objected.
I can be very diplomatic when I want to
be.
I'm sure, Glory said.
Any other votes?
As each of them voted for her, Sonny felt
as though her own scales might turn
pink.
You are all, you're such a bunch of
tsunami sputtered.
Frog faced blobs of camel spit?
Sonny suggested.
Tsunami started laughing so hard, she
nearly fell off the branch.
All right, fine, she said, recovering at
last.
I don't see how I can compete with that
kind of mastery of language.
But then you should use the dream visitor
to talk to your mother, Sonny said, or to
someone in your kingdom, some sea wings
should come to the stronghold if any of
them are willing to see what happens.
Tsunami nodded, bumping Sonny's shoulder
affectionately.
I can do that.
I'd like to check on anemone anyway.
That night, Sonny took the dream visitor
and flew to the pool by the tunnels.
She chose the tunnel that led from the
kingdom of sand to the rainforest.
The one that led to the night kingdom
smelled of burnt scales and fire, and
still radiated heat.
She crouched in the darkest part of the
tunnel, where it was pitch black.
There was nothing around her to offer a
clue about where she was, even if the
dream visitor gave the dreamer a glimpse
of her, all she would see was blackness.
Hopefully Blaze would think it was a cave
in the mountains, if anything.
She closed her eyes and held the blue
sapphire to her head again.
It hummed in a strange way, like far away
chanting faintly heard through layers of
rock.
Blaze.
Sonny pictured the beautiful sand wing.
They'd only met once in the Ice Kingdom.
Later, she'd overheard tsunami describing
Blaze to Kinkachu.
She's pretty but silly, one of those
overly optimistic dragons, like Sonia
sometimes, although Blaze is more self
centered.
This comparison had made Sonny want to
shred a tree with her bare claws.
She was nothing, nothing like Blaze, and
if tsunami thought so, then she really
must think Sunny was an idiot with no
brains in her head at all.
Don't think about that now.
Concentrate on getting into Blaze's
dreams, she thought.
And then she opened her eyes and realized
she was already there.
She stood in the desert, claws sinking
into warm sand.
Blaze was flying, her polished scales
shimmering in the bright hot sunlight.
She shone against the clear blue sky, and
beautiful jewels sparkled all along her
scales.
She kept circling in the air and twisting
her head to look down, not far from where
Sonny was, but she didn't seem to notice
Sonny at first.
Sonny lifted herself onto her back talons
to look around, and spotted a clear pool
of water not far away.
Blaise was admiring herself in the
perfectly still reflection.
Good grief.
Sonny muttered.
She flared her wings and waved at the
sand wing in the sky.
It took a lot of flapping before Blaze
finally gave a little start and veered
around to stare at Sonny.
Sonny beckoned, wanting to have this
conversation on solid ground.
Blaze landed in front of her, kicking
sand up Sonny's nose without noticing
she'd done so.
She swished her tail around and sat
gracefully.
Hello, I know you, don't I?
she asked.
We've met, Sonny said.
I'm one of the dragonettes.
That was all she had to say.
Dragonettes of destiny didn't sound right
to her anymore, not since she'd found out
the truth about the prophecy.
She wondered briefly what would happen if
she just told the sandwing sisters that
the prophecy was false.
Then they really wouldn't listen to us
she thought.
We'd have no chance of making this work.
We have to let them believe it, at least
for now.
Oh, of course.
The weird looking sandwing, Blaise said.
Right.
Which necklace do you think looks better
on me?
I've always liked rubies, but these
emeralds are smashing too, right?
She held out 2 gem studded necklaces
draped sparklingly across her claws.
Blaze, Sonny said.
Do you want to go home?
The Sandwing princess looked around
blinking.
Aren't I home?
This is a dream.
Sonny said patiently.
I mean, really home, home to the
stronghold in the desert, to sand and
roasted lizards and warm sunshine every
day.
Oh my.
Blaise said. a wistful sigh.
I remember my rooms in the stronghold.
They were so big and pretty, with tall
windows on 3 walls.
I really do look my best and full natural
sunlight, you know.
She spread her wings and swished them
gracefully around, admiring them.
Sonny managed not to roll her eyes.
So come to us.
Don't keep hiding in that cold, dark
fortress.
If you come to the stronghold.
We'll end this war and you can go home.
What?
Blaise said, tilting her head.
Right now?
The 3rd midnight from tonight, Sonny
said.
Didn't anyone give you our message?
No one said anything about a message, said
Blaze.
From the dragoness of the prophecy?
How could they keep something like that
for me?
Well, I am offended.
She thought for a moment, then
brightened.
Oh, so you did pick me.
Well, wait, Sonny said.
We haven't picked any of you yet.
We.
Right, of course.
You haven't announced it or anything, but
you're going to pick me.
The only way I can go home, after all, is
if my sisters are dead.
Oh, how lovely.
I knew you would choose me.
I am very nice.
And doesn't everyone want a beautiful
queen.
Not at all, Sonny thought.
We're really looking for a peaceful
outcome, she said.
That's our goal, and then whoever becomes
queen.
I'm going to order a new bracelet to
celebrate.
Blaise declared. jumping up and nearly
dancing around Sonny.
And a crown.
Of course, I need a crown.
Oh, now I really have to decide rubies or
emeralds.
I suppose I could have 2 crowns or lots
and lots of crowns.
I am so excited.
Blaze, stop, Sonny said desperately.
The princess wasn't listening to her at
all, and Sonny didn't want to lie to her
or make her show up under false
pretenses.
The important thing is that you be there
at the stronghold, and then we'll figure
out who should be queen.
It might not be you.
Do you understand?
Glacier is going to be pleased too, said
Blaise, talking right over Sonny.
I'll have to convince her to let me go
but I can win arguments when I really
want to.
I'll tell her there's a new crown in it
for her too.
I think she looks best in sapphires
naturally.
So you'll be there?
Sonny said, even knowing you might not be
queen when it's all over.
Blaze was already swanning back to the
still pool.
You can live in my palace if you like, she
called back to Sonny.
I could give you a really important job.
Ooh, like helping me get dressed in the
morning.
Sometimes it takes me simply hours to
choose the right anklet.
Midnight, at the stronghold.
Sonny cried after her.
Three midnights from tonight.
That means not tonight, not tomorrow
night, but the night after that.
Will you remember?
Will you count right?
Queen Blaze, sang the sand wing princess
as she lifted into the air.
Doesn't that sound pretty?
Oh, dear.
Sonny thought.
She stepped out of the dream and stared
into the blackness all around her.
Will Queen Glacier listen to her?
Will she be there?
What if all of this falls apart and we
fail?
She gripped the dream visitor tightly in
her claws?
That's not an option.
If Blaze doesn't show up, I'll fly to the
Ice Kingdom and drag her back myself.
In 4 days time, either the war will be
over, or we'll all be dead.
Chapter 24.
Night had fallen, and the sky was full of
dragons.
That was the 1st thing Sonny noticed when
she stepped out of the tunnel onto the
desert sands, the air crackled with the
sound of wing beats and the smell of
fire.
Dragons soared overhead like a 1000000
bats, sinuous shapes silhouetted across
the moons.
It was time.
This was the night.
All 3 sandwing sisters would be in the
same place for the 1st time since the war
began.
If they show up, Sonny thought.
She glanced at the night sky again.
It certainly seems like every other
dragon empire might be here.
And it was easier to see them than it
should have been because of the mystery
orb in the sky.
It had gotten bigger and brighter every
night, and now it was the same size as
the other moons, 2 of which were full.
Between the 3 of them filling the sky, it
looked like another brightest night.
A new brightest night, when there
shouldn't have been one for another 94
years, Sonny thought.
If that's not an omen, what is?
She hadn't said that to her friends
though.
She knew they'd roll their eyes at her
and the whole idea of destiny, or omens
but still, that 3rd uncanny moon in the
sky made her feel somehow a little more
hopeful, like maybe things would be all
right.
The way she used to feel when she thought
about the prophecy.
Sonny climbed up to the ridge overlooking
the stronghold and stood between 2 cacti
gazing down at it.
The long black structure, all shadows in
the moonlight, was vast and forbidding
even from a distance, and she still had
nightmares about the weirdling tower.
She couldn't imagine stepping back inside
there of her own free will.
But that was exactly what she was about
to do.
The sound of shifting sand behind her
signaled the arrival of her friends, and
Sonny turned to see Clay, then tsunami
then Starflight and fate speaker emerged
from the tunnel.
Fate speaker glanced around at the desert
at the way the sand seemed to run all the
way to the edge of the sky.
She shuddered.
This place is freaky, she whispered.
Starflight, I don't think it's safe
here.
Shouldn't you stay behind?
Starflight shook his head.
No, I have to be here.
I'm not missing this, even if I can't see
it.
He'd been practicing with Tamarin, the
blind rain wing all week, how to fly with
someone guiding him, how to sense
unexpected obstacles, and most of all, how
to ask for help.
Sunny slid down the hill to them and
brushed Starflight's wing with hers to
let him know she was there.
He leaned toward her, touching the
bandage on his eyes.
What is that?
Fate speaker asked, staring up at the
sky.
Starflight, why is there a 4th moon?
Sonny had already described it to him
although his explanation didn't make all
that much sense to her.
I think it's more like a comet than a
moon.
Starflight said to fate speaker.
I remember a scroll that mentioned
something like that in the sky 100s of
years ago.
Maybe it circles around and only comes
back every 1000 years or so.
Have you noticed the earthquakes?
I think they might be caused by the
comet.
The ground trembled quietly under them.
The way it had several times in the last
few days.
Sunny dug her claws into the sand
glancing up at the stars.
But it's not going to, like, land on us
or anything, right?
Fate speaker said, because it sure looks
like it's gotten bigger.
I think maybe it's going to fall on us.
Ooh, I think maybe I'm having a vision.
Stop that.
Starflight said, smacking her gently with
his wing.
You know those powers aren't real?
Your visions are just your imagination.
Fate speaker shot him a very indignant
look, but he luckily couldn't see.
I know that's what Stone Mover said, but
I think it doesn't apply to me.
My visions are totally real.
And when this moon comet thing crushes us
all.
Everyone will be sorry for not listening
to me.
All right. he answered.
We'll see.
Where's Glory?
Tsunami asked, coming back from scouting
the top of the dunes.
Right behind us, said Clay, and he jumped
out of the way as more dragons started
coming out of the tunnel.
It was strange to know that all these
dragons were rain wings, but to see
instead, sky wings and night wings and
mud wings.
Glory had decided to bring 15 rain wings
along to be voices for peace if necessary
and to be dangerous venom spitting backup
if really necessary.
She decided it would be safer for her
dragons if they came in disguise.
Their camouflage scales making them
anonymous bystanders.
Those 3 tribes were the easiest disguises
no poisonous tales, webbed talons, or
serrated claws among them.
There were 5 actual night wings as well
plus Death Bringer, who'd refused to stay
behind and let glory go without him.
But you could be useful here.
Glory had argued back in the rainforest.
You could keep an eye on the night wings
for me.
I'd rather keep an eye on you. he
retorted, and on all the dragons you're
about to go chat with, who literally want
to kill you.
Hey, that's how you and I met, Glory
said.
Maybe I'll charm them out of the idea
too.
I'm not sure charm is quite the word I'd
use.
He'd mused, and gotten a swat to his nose
as a thank you.
But she'd let him select 5 night wings he
thought were more trustworthy than the
rest, so that the tribe would be
represented at this gathering.
Sunny thought that was probably a good
idea, although she was still having
trouble forgiving the black dragons for
all their lies.
Mangrove and grandeur had been left in
charge of everyone while they were gone.
The 5 Dragonettes climbed up to stand on
the ridge, surveying the stronghold below
and the clouds of dragons who were
already descending on it.
What if they start fighting?
Fate speaker asked suddenly, all these
dragons from different tribes who've been
at war for so long?
What if something happens and they start
trying to kill each other?
Sunny curled her tail around her talons.
What an awful thought that hadn't even
occurred to her.
It'd be a huge battle, Deathbringer
said.
That might end the war itself.
With 100s more dead dragons, Sonny said.
No, that's not all right.
We'll stop them if we have to.
Right, tsunami said.
By asking nicely?
Is that the plan?
You'd be surprised how effective asking
nicely can be, Sonny said.
Maybe if you ever tried it, you'd know.
Yeah, Glory said with a grin, and tsunami
glared at both of them.
Well, let's get down there before
anything happens, Clay suggested.
Before we go, Sonny said, turning to her
friends, I just, I just want you guys to
know that I love you.
And I don't regret anything that's
happened.
I'm not mad about the fake prophecy, or
the talons stealing us, because without
all of that, I wouldn't have grown up
with you.
And you're more important to me than
anything.
You are my brothers and sisters.
You're my real family.
So it was worth it, no matter what.
Oh, Clay said, pulling her into his wings
for a fierce hug.
Uh-oh, Glory said, a mushy speech.
We're all going to die, aren't we?
She means she loves you too.
Tsunami translated, dragging Sonny away
from clay so she could hug her as well.
And so do I. Me too.
Starflight said quietly, and they all
wrapped their wings around him together.
Sonny felt the sinewy curve of his
shoulder pressing against her snout, and
smelled the herbs in the bandage on his
eyes.
Horse Starflight.
Is that enough of an answer for him?
I do love him.
But, like a brother.
I wish I felt more.
There wasn't time to say anything else.
It was almost midnight.
They leaped into the sky, soaring down
toward the stronghold with the rain wings
and night wings streaming out behind
them.
From above, as they approached, Sonny
could see that the courtyard looked
deserted.
The monument to Queen Oasis was a tower
of darkness, rejecting the moonlight, and
casting a long shadow across the sand
circle around it.
The soldiers' barracks were empty.
The flat white stones stretched blankly
glowing, as if they were made of the same
stuff as the weird moon.
Fire flickered from torches that studded
the courtyard like claws.
What if they don't come?
The dragons who had flown into watch, were
gathered all along the walls, wing to
wing.
They had torn out the heads on spikes, and
dropped the gruesome trophies onto the
sand below, making room for the 100s of
spectators instead.
It was hard to tell which tribe was which
in the silvery moonlight.
All the dragons seem to have scales of
silver and black and gray.
But Sonny was pretty sure she spotted sea
wings sitting next to mud wings, ice
wings beside sky wings, sand wings and
night wings and rain wings, barely a few
claws from one another.
That's what I really want.
Sonny thought.
A pyrea where all dragons can see that
we're basically the same, no matter what
kinds of natural weapons we hatch with, or
don't hatch with for some of us.
A pyrea where it doesn't matter what
tribe you're from, because you can have
friends from any tribe, like us.
As her gays scanned the walls, she
spotted familiar sandwing scales, and her
heart squeezed happily.
Thorn was here, along with 6 claws and
Kibley, and no doubt more out claws.
Even if everything went horribly wrong
Sonny had this strange, warm feeling that
her mother would care about her and want
to know her, whether or not she saved the
world.
Sonny was surprised to find herself
thinking, maybe that's better than a
prophecy and a great destiny.
But I do still have to save the world.
Right now, in fact.
She was on one side of Starflight, with
fate speaker on the other.
They guided him down to the sand, and
Sunny heard fate speaker describing the
scene for him in a whisper.
Clay thumped down next to her, and
sneezed as sand went up his nose.
Tsunami and glory arrived without
Deathbringer, who had been sent to the
walls along with the dragons they had
brought with them.
Sonny was a little surprised that
Deathbringer had agreed to be that far
away from glory, but she glanced at the
determined look on Glory's face and
figured she wouldn't have argued with
that either.
Glory herself was disguised as a sky wing
red and gold scales rippling along her
wings.
Ironic, right?
she'd said, lashing her crimson tail.
Now at least I look like I belong in the
prophecy.
And judging by the murmurs coming from
above them, the audience was thinking the
same thing.
The 5 dragonettes, Sonny thought, as
Marosir foretold.
Here we are.
Prophecy or no prophecy.
Now, where are the queens who blister and
blaze and burn?
A rumbling growl came from the dark
entrance to the old palace, and Bern
stepped out into the moonlight.
Chapter 25.
Three moons, sunny thought.
She's even bigger than I remembered.
Burn was a massive, heavy dragon, with
jagged scars all over her pale yellow
scales, including a particularly vicious
one all along her side under her left
wing.
A more recent wound was slashed across
her snout, oozing olive green pus and
dark blood.
Her black eyes glittered, and her stained
claws gleamed with what looked like fresh
blood as she slithered across the stones
toward them.
So, you came.
She hissed.
I thought the rumors couldn't possibly be
true.
She cast a seething look up at the 100s
of watching dragons.
I hope you have a good reason for
disrupting my battle plans.
This war is over, Sonny said, as loud as
she could.
There was a ripple of whispers along the
walls as her words were passed along.
Really, said Bern, because you say so.
Is that it?
Because we all say so, tsunami retorted.
She flared her wings to include all the
dragons above and around them.
Interesting.
Said Bern, but I see a problem.
In fact, I see 2 problems, flying this
way right now.
Sunny World, and saw a massive dragons
arriving from the east.
Blister and her forces, she thought
hopefully.
She looked north and spotted flashing
silver scales.
Please let that be blaze with the ice
wings.
It's possible.
I won't kill you, Burns said.
After all, you've brought me my sisters
to kill, which is more help than any
other dragons have been.
Then again, you're very annoying.
This is not about killing, Sonny said.
The sounds of wing beats we're getting
closer, so she turned to watch blister
land next to the Queen Oasis Monument.
Blister sank her talons into the sand for
a moment, shooting a deadly look up at
the obelisk.
Blaze and Queen Glacier landed a moment
later, off to Seni's left.
Blaise eyed her sisters nervously, stand
close to the ice wing's side.
Blisters slithered out of the sand and
paced slowly between sunny and clay, her
snake like gaze pinned on Byrne as she
circled her older sister.
You're still alive, Blister remarked. in
a cold, calm voice, that's a pity.
She paused and narrowed her eyes at the
dragonettes.
I was hoping you'd have my sisters dead
before I got here.
What?
Burn snarled.
They've chosen me as queen, not you.
No way.
Blaise cried, then hurriedly backed into
Glacier as her sisters whipped their
heads toward her.
They picked me.
They told me to come here.
We haven't chosen any of you, Sonny said
firmly, and we're definitely not killing
any of you.
Unless we have to.
Glory observed.
Feel free to provoke us.
Shh, Clay said, nudging her.
We are here to find a peaceful solution
Sonny announced.
Either you 3 decide among you, peacefully
who's going to be queen, or everyone else
here will decide for you?
No more armies, no more dead dragons.
Burn barked, a harsh, disbelieving
laugh.
I have a better idea, she snarled.
First, I kill my sisters, and then I kill
all of you, and then I stuff you, and
spend the next 100 years telling your
dead face about peaceful solutions.
Out of the corner of her eye.
Sonny saw a flurry of movement from the
part of the wall where Thorn was
perched.
No one is going to let you do that, she
said to Burne, trying to sound much
braver than she felt.
In fact, Blister interjected suddenly.
I've already made a gesture of peace.
Didn't you get my present, burn?
An eerie silence fell for a moment. as
Burns stared down at her.
I was thinking.
Blister hissed into the stillness.
But this war has gone on too long.
I thought if I sent you a gift, something
I know you've always wanted.
That perhaps we could mend fences and
reunite the family.
She bared her teeth at the palace
entrance, and Sunny spotted smoldered
just inside the doorway, where she'd 1st
seen him.
Aha!
Burn snarled.
That was from you.
Smolder, bring me the box.
Now, he said, don't argue with me.
She growled, and he vanished into the
palace.
A gift?
A gesture of peace?
Reuniting the family?
That doesn't sound like blister.
Sonny flicked her tail anxiously.
Or is she really willing to stand down
and let burn be queen?
Smolder returned a few moments later
carrying the box that Sonny had seen on
the top floor of the Weirdling Tower when
she'd been chained up there.
As he set it down in front of Bern, it
let out a malevolent hiss.
Bern, be careful, Sonny said.
She had a horrible sinking feeling in her
chest, and she really didn't like the
look on Blister's face.
I, I think this might be a trick.
Of course it is, Burns said, especially
if it's from my clever little sister.
Sending me a present, thinking I'll open
it without any suspicion, as if I don't
recognize the hiss of the dragon bite
viper when I hear it.
It's not a trick.
Blister said coolly.
I know you've always wanted one for your
collection.
Dragon Bite Viper?
Fate speaker whispered to Starflight.
Rare and deadly, he whispered back.
The only snake in Pyria, that can kill a
dragon with one bite.
He shifted nervously on his talons.
If that's really what's in there, I hope
that's not really what's in there.
Well, the trick's on you.
Burns said.
She sank her claws into the top of the
box and ripped it off with a vicious
tearing sound, fast as lightning, her
talons shot into the box, and lifted out
a writhing, hissing rope of scaly fury.
The snake's head was pinned between burns
claws, so it couldn't bite her.
Its whole body wriggled and lashed, like
the eels attacking in the sea wing
prison.
I know your sick, twisted mind.
You thought this would kill me.
Burn snarled at blister.
So it'll be very poetic when it kills you
instead.
She took a step toward her sister, and
then stopped suddenly, looking down.
Oh, Blister said.
I got you too.
Did I leave out that part?
A 2nd dragon bite viper lunged out of the
box and sank its teeth into Burns ankle.
Its venomous fangs slid like shards of
ice right between her scales.
The screaming seemed to come from
everywhere at once.
Blaze was probably screaming the loudest
shrieking and flapping her wings as if
she were the one who'd been bitten, all
along the walls.
Dragons were pushing and yelling and
leaning in to get a better look, or
taking off into the sky to get as far
away from the snakes as possible.
Burn stamped one foot down on the 2nd
snake, crushing it, but it was too late.
Black veins were shooting up her leg and
spreading through her scales.
What's happening?
Starfight asked, reaching out for Sonny.
Sonny touched his wing with her own.
There was a 2nd snake in the box, and it
bit burn.
This was Blister's plan, the one I
overheard her talking about in the
mirror.
Send burn something she really wants, and
figure out a way for it to kill her.
Clever and evil and sinister.
She looked over at blister, who was
watching her sister's death throes with
an enthralled, smug smile on her face.
We can't let her be queen.
All of Pyria would be in danger if
blister were queen.
But what else can we do?
She's not going to accept Blaze on the
throne instead.
And it looks like this is the end for
burn.
Burn let out a furious roar, and
collapsed to the ground with a crash that
shook the earth.
Her wings twitched and convulsed as if
they were possessed.
She clawed at the air, reaching for
blister.
I'll kill you, she snarled.
I'll claw that.
I'll, it hurts.
Stop it.
Stop the.
She roared again, howling her agony at
the sky.
Her ankle was entirely black now, the
claws curling in and shriveling.
The venom marched up toward her heart
fast and unstoppable.
Is there anything we can do?
Sonny asked.
Clay, Starflight.
Starflight shook his head mutely.
Burn rolled onto her back, wheezing as
the black tendrils looped together in the
center of her chest.
Her arm flopped to the ground.
Her talons opened, and the 1st snake
slithered loose onto the stones of the
courtyard.
The Viper?
Blaise shrieked.
It's going to kill us.
Pandemonium erupted along the walls.
Fly, screamed several dragons.
Kill it, roared others, or it will kill
us all.
Blister was in the air already, hovering
over them and watching gleefully as the
snake shot toward the dragonettes.
It moved like lightning, zigzagging
across the stones faster than flight.
Up, up, up.
Tsunami shouted, shoving at her friends.
Starflight.
Fate speaker screamed.
Sunny whirled, and saw Starflight stumble
forward, his wings unfolding, but slowly
too slowly, his talons reached out, trying
to orient himself.
The snake was nearly at his feet
already.
Sunny and fate speaker reached him at the
same time, grabbing his forearms, and
trying to lift him bodily into the sky
but they were both small, and Starflight
was heavy and confused and unwieldy.
His tail thwacked the ground, and his
wings nearly overbalanced them all as
they tried to struggle into the air.
The viper hissed, and it sounded as if it
was coming from inside Sunny's skull.
It's going to get one of us, Sonny
realized, with a jolt of horror.
Let it be me.
Please don't let Starflight die.
And then something hit her, like a
boulder slamming into all of them.
Sunny, fate speaker, and Starflight
tumbled backward, a tangle of wings and
tails catapulted across the courtyard.
Sonny was flung loose from the others and
skidded across the sand, crashing finally
into the queen oasis obelisk.
She shoved herself back up, dizzy and
disoriented.
What had happened?
Had someone pushed them?
Did the snake bite anyone?
Was Starflight all right?
Her head took a moment to clear.
And then she realized there was a dragon
lying on the stones, where she'd been
standing a moment before.
The dragon who'd slammed into them, the
dragon who'd saved their lives.
It was clay.
Chapter 26.
No, Sonny screamed.
Sonny, stay back.
The viper's still alive.
Deathbringer yelled from overhead.
She realized that he was holding glory in
the air, and the rain wing queen was
fighting to get away.
But no one was holding her back, and she
didn't care about the snake.
She didn't care if she did get bitten.
She wasn't going to leave clay lying
there, dying.
She scrambled across the courtyard and
threw her wings over him, shaking him
with her talons.
Clay, she yelled, clay.
He looked dazed, but his eyes were open.
Maybe the snake had missed him.
She couldn't see it anywhere.
Maybe.
Oh, Clay said, trying to sit up.
Ow, I...
My leg.
Wow, that really hurts.
He pressed his claws to his head and
looked as if he might pass out.
And then Sonny saw the wound.
The fang marks in the flesh of clay's
right thigh, a black starburst had
already appeared around the 2 holes
pulsing bigger and bigger across his warm
brown scales.
Clay?
Sonny started to cry.
Please don't die.
I'm, I'm, uh, open to suggestions, he
said, with a small, breathless laugh.
He reached toward his leg, then flinched
back, gritting his teeth in pain.
Tsunami thumped down on his other side
and let out a gasp at the side of the
snake bite.
She twisted to look at the courtyard
around them.
Where's the snake?
she said.
Where did it go?
I don't know, Sonny said.
She could barely see through her tears.
She leaned against clay, trying to send
all the warmth from her scales into him.
Hey, it's all right.
Clay said, although his claws were
clenched, and his wings were starting to
shudder.
It's not such a bad destiny, sonny.
I'd die to save you and Starflight over
and over if I had to.
His voice caught on the last few words
and he stopped, breathing hard.
I order you not to die.
Tsunami said, grabbing his shoulder.
Clay, stop.
Stop it.
Stop dying right now.
Her normally bossy voice was full of
panic.
Ow!
Death bringer roared from up in the sky.
And a moment later, glory crash landed
into Sonny.
No, no, no.
Glory said, looking at the growing burst
of black.
Her scales had turned lily green and
white, the colors of fear and panic and
pain.
No, we have to be able to stop this.
There must be something we can do.
Starflight, she bellowed.
Think, how do you stop a dragon bite
viper's poison?
The scrolls must have said something, she
muttered, touching clay's scales.
He winced as her claws brushed the
blackened area.
Why can't I remember anything?
Why is it spreading so fast?
Sonny looked around for the 1st time and
realized that the dragons along the walls
had fallen completely silent, staring at
them.
Blister and Blaze were watching too.
One with cold interest, and the other
with horror.
Over by the wall, Starflight was trying
to find them, stumbling forward, with his
claws held out, although fate speaker was
trying to drag him back.
And there was something hurtling out of
the sky toward them, something that
blazed, fiery orange, and trailed smoke, a
dragon with burning scales.
Out of the way.
Pearl yelled, Sonny, get everyone out of
the way.
Tsunami reacted first, weeping over clay
to shove Sunny and Glory back.
The heat from peril's scales swept over
them as the sky wing hit the ground and
nearly slid into clay.
You can't die!
Carol yelled at him.
I won't let you.
Don't tsunami started forward.
What are you?
I'm burning out the poison, peril said
and she stabbed her smoldering claws
straight into the center of the black
starburst on Clay's leg.
With a roar of crazed agony, Clay surged
up as though he was trying to fly away.
Tsunami, Glory, and Sonny, flung
themselves at him and pinned him down, but
he was bigger and stronger and fighting
hard.
Deathbringer, get down here.
Glory yelled, and a moment later, the
night wing was there, adding his weight
to theirs.
Sonny grabbed Clay's front talons in hers
and held on for dear life.
Clay, it's all right.
She's helping you.
But Clay was in too much pain to hear
her.
He jerked and thrashed.
His howls digging into Sonny's heart like
ice wing claws.
She closed her eyes and leaned into him
the awful smell of melting scales and
burning flesh assailed her, as if she
were burying her snout in the night wing
volcano.
She felt more dragons join them, holding
down Clay's wings and keeping his claws
away from peril.
When she opened her eyes again.
It was who she expected, Riptide, and
Starflight, and also who she didn't.
Thorn, clasping Sonny and Clay's talents
between her own.
Mother, she whispered with relief, resting
her head against the warm sand wing
scales.
This should have been me, Thorn said, but
I couldn't get you in time.
Sonny shook her head and chanced to look
at Clay's leg.
Carol still had her talons buried in his
scales, carving out everything that had
been touched by the black venom.
There was a scorched, gaping, bleeding
hole in clay's thigh, and Sonny had to
look away quickly before she threw up.
I'm not sure he can survive this.
Thorn whispered gently to Sonny, that big
of a burn.
He can, Sonny said fiercely.
Maybe no one else could, but he can.
Fireproof scales, Starflight said, across
from them.
Oh, I hope, Thorn said, and then she
spread her wing around Sonny's back and
pulled her close, falling silent.
A few moments later, peril said, that's
all of it.
In an exhausted voice, and stepped back.
I think, it better be.
I don't see any more venom to you?
She asked Sonny.
Clay?
Clay, are you all right?
Clay had passed out.
His wings were limp and his head lulled
to the side when Riptide let go of it.
Is he all right?
Peril said, her voice rising.
Tell me it worked.
It worked, Glory said.
She rested her talons on Clay's chest
which was rising and falling evenly.
The black venom had stopped spreading.
Peril had burned it all out of him.
Sonny could see his fireproof scales
trying to fix themselves, warm brown
smoothing over the scorched spots.
But the whole peril had had to gouge out
of his leg, was too big for the scales to
knit over.
Clay was going to be scarred, and
probably limping for life.
But he was alive.
He'd survived the snake bite.
That was all that mattered.
Thank you, Sonny said to peril.
She automatically reached to hug Peril
but the Sky Wing jumped back before they
could touch.
Seriously, tsunami said, rubbing her face
with her talons and sitting back.
You, that.
I don't know what to say.
Glory had her tail curled around her
talons and was holding her wings in close
as wave after wave of odd colors spread
through her scales.
Death bringer put one wing around her
gently, and she let him.
Maybe, Clay mumbled.
And they all leaned closer to hear him.
Maybe peril is the wings of fire.
He lapsed back into unconsciousness.
Sonny saw the nervously delighted
expression on Parel's face and felt as if
her heart might explode.
The night wings just made that up.
Wings of fire was nothing but a pretty
phrase to them.
But it is something, and it's more than
perils burning scales.
Peril helped us because clay is
wonderful.
He was kind to her when no one else ever
was, and he believed in her, no matter
what she'd done.
His heart is the real wings of fire.
She glanced around at her friends.
Clay's heart, tsunami's courage, glory's
determination, Starflights, loyalty.
I think the wings of fire are inside all
of us, inside every dragon.
Maybe you just have to reach inside and
find it.
A sinister hiss interrupted her thoughts
and she whirled around as a jolt of fear
ran through her.
The dragon bite viper was slithering up
between 2 of the stones, eyeing the group
of dragonettes with a dark, cold, lidless
glare.
Peril leaped forward and smashed her
talons down on it.
The snake flailed horribly for a moment
and then crumpled into a shriveled, burnt
out husk.
Oh, well. said blister's voice behind
them.
That would have been convenient, killing
all my enemies with one snake, so to
speak, Blister flicked her tail up, and
studied them for a long moment as they
turned to face her.
Tsunami squared her shoulders and glared
back at her, talons clenched, as if she
was ready to fight.
But I think I'll deal with you later
Blister said.
Her eyes shifted toward the hordes of
gathered dragons, and Sunny realized the
blister wasn't sure what they would do.
If blister tried to kill the prophecy
dragonettes, right here in front of
everybody, would they stop her?
How would they all react?
For now, Blister said, I'm finally just
one step away from the throne that is
rightfully mine.
And that step, of course.
She turned to her sister, Blaise, who
cowered back against the ice wing queen
is killing you.
Chapter 27.
You don't have to kill her, Sonny
protested, as Blister advanced on Blaze.
Perhaps, Blister said over her shoulder
but I certainly want to.
Can't you fight for me?
Blaise pleaded, turning to Queen
Glacier.
I don't want to die like this.
Queen Glacier looked torn.
She had to know there was no chance Blaze
would survive this duel, which meant
she'd get none of the promised territory
for the ice wings.
And she'd be left with a bordering
kingdom, ruled by a queen who'd been her
enemy for 18 years.
But Sonny could see that Glacier wanted
to be just and fair.
She couldn't fight a Sandwings battle for
her, not one on one, for the throne like
this.
The ice wing shook her head.
I'm sorry, Blaze.
This is your fight.
She touched Blaze's wing with her own
briefly, then turned and flew up to join
her fellow ice dragons on the wall.
Blaise faced her sister, wide eyed with
fear.
You can forfeit, Sonny cried.
You don't have to fight.
Let her be queen and live.
It's too late for that.
Blister snarled.
She wanted to be queen badly enough to
fight for it all these years.
She can't back down now that it's just
the 2 of us.
With a swift, sudden movement, blister
darted a blaze, bit down viciously on the
edge of one of her wings, and darted away
again.
Ow!
Blaise shrieked.
She staggered back, staring at her wing.
Three moons?
It's bleeding.
I'm bleeding.
Oh, brother.
Glory said, but there was pity in her
expression.
Shouldn't we stop them?
Sonny asked her friends.
It's royal sandwing business now
Starflight said, touching the bandage
around his eyes and ducking his head.
They'll fight and blister will win.
But the important thing is that it means
the war is over.
There will be a queen on the sandwing
throne, and no one else has to die.
Except Blaze, Glory observed.
The 2 sandwings circled each other
hissing and jabbing with their tails like
2 scorpions.
Poor Blaze, Sonny said.
It doesn't seem fair.
She curled into Clay's side, leaning
against his scales.
I wish someone else could be queen, fate
speaker said.
Blister is so creepy.
And smart, Starflight agreed.
Who knows what she'll do once the throne
is really hers?
He scratched his claws across the stone.
With the United Sandwing Armyator claw
tips and the treasure.
If she's the one who stole it, She could
easily be the most dangerous dragon in
Pyria.
Isn't there anyone else?
Sonny asked.
She turned and saw Smolder still standing
in the shadows of the doorway.
He met her eyes and started toward her
carefully avoiding his sisters.
I don't think so, Starflight said.
None of the 3 sisters have exactly taken
the time to have dragonettes.
Hello, Smolder said, sliding up to them.
Flower was perched on his shoulder
staring around at all the dragons with
her big, brown, dragon like eyes.
Aren't you all dramatic troublemakers?
Do you think blisters going to let me
live?
I'm guessing no.
This would probably be a good time for me
to run away.
He cast a speculative glance at the sky.
But to where?
Could you use another outlaw, perhaps?
He asked Thorn.
You have some nerve, Thorn snapped.
I should kill you myself or that trick
you played, locking us in the library.
As if I had a choice, Smolder said
reproachfully, and it didn't even work.
Burn was this close to killing me until
she got your message about meeting her
here tonight.
I should be mad at him too, Sonny
thought.
But she couldn't be.
He wasn't evil.
He wasn't even mean.
He was a dragon in a terrible family, in
a hard situation, in danger of being put
to death like his brothers at any
moment.
He could have killed her the moment he
got his talons on her.
He could have left her in the tower.
Maybe she shouldn't like him.
But she did anyway.
Smolder pointed to his sister's dead body
with a rueful expression.
I must admit, I never expected to outlive
her.
It probably won't be by much, if that's
any consolation, Thorn said bluntly.
Smolder, Sonny broke in.
Are there any other dragons in line for
the sandwing throne?
Did Queen Oasis have any sisters or other
daughters, or did any of these 3 have
dragonettes?
Smolder shook his head?
Mother was very strict and very careful.
She had just the 3 daughters, so someone
could inherit one day, but she didn't
want a lot of challengers, so she had no
more eggs.
And the rest of us were not allowed to
have dragonettes either.
He fell silent for a moment.
I was in love once.
She was so angry when she found out.
I don't even know what she did.
But I never saw a poem again.
You should have better choices, Sonny
said, stamping her foot.
All 3 of your sisters are terrible.
Blaze let out another yowl of pain as
Blister slashed her claws across her
nose.
Sonny had a feeling this fight could have
been over already, but Blister was
playing with Blaze, showing off for the
audience.
Why can't someone else be queen?
Fate speaker asked.
If glory can be queen of the night wings
who says it has to be a member of the
royal family?
Good question, said Glory.
Who else would have the authority?
Starflight asked.
Why would the other Sandwings listen to
anyone else?
If any dragon could take the throne?
It'd be anarchy.
There'd be challengers trying to grab it
every other day.
I know, Sunny said, but still, if all the
royal options are awful, it seems like
there should be a way to give the sand
wing someone else, a better queen.
Her wings drooped.
After everything they'd been through.
All the worry about the prophecy, and all
the danger they'd been in, and all the
dragons who tried to kill them.
Was this how it ended?
They stopped the war, but gave the
sandwings an evil queen?
Was she supposed to say, oh, well, good
enough.
Flower wriggled off smolders back and
came over to pat Sonny's talons in her
odd, comforting way.
The little scavenger looked up at Sonny
and squeaked, waving her paws.
Scavengers are so crazy, tsunami said.
She ducked her head to sniff at flower.
Look at her.
Just standing here in the middle of all
these dragons.
Where's her survival instinct?
This is the one who stole the treasure
right?
Hey, Squish face.
This is all your fault, you know?
Flower wrapped her arms around one of
Sonny's ankles and tugged, as if she was
trying to drag Sonny somewhere, squeaking
loudly.
What?
Sonny asked.
She looked at Smolder.
What's she trying to say?
He shrugged.
I never know.
Flower jumped up and down, flapping her
paws.
Sonny tilted her head, confused.
The scavenger ran over to the pit of sand
flapped again, ran back to Sonny, tugged
on her ankle, and ran back to the sand.
To Sonny's astonishment, flower threw
herself down and started to dig with her
paws.
What in the 3 moons?
Smolder said.
I'll never understand scavengers.
She's trying to tell us something, Sonny
said.
She followed flower to the sand pit
glancing up at the obelisk.
Did Flower know that the dragon she'd
killed or helped to kill was buried
here?
This is a little morbid flower.
Flower whacked Sonny's front talons
pointed at the sand, shouted something
like, you will throbble and went back to
digging.
All right, Sonny said, and she started to
dig too.
What could she be trying to tell us?
What are you doing?
Glory demanded.
Digging, Sonny said.
She glanced up at Blaze and Blister.
Blaze had 3 more bleeding wounds. and
blister was pacing smugly around her.
Surely the fight couldn't last much
longer.
Why?
Tsunami asked, coming to stand next to
her.
Because Flower wants me to, Sonny said, I
don't know, but it feels like maybe it's
important.
Tsunami and glory exchange glances.
Sonny could guess what those looks
meant.
Another crazy, sunny idea.
Look at her. following a scavenger's
instructions, as if that makes any
sense.
Scoot over, tsunami said.
She flexed her claws and drove them into
the sand.
You too, Glory said to the scavenger
joining them.
Tsunami and glory began to dig, wing to
wing with Sonny.
A moment later, she looked up and found
Thorn digging busily beside her as well.
She tried to hide her smile, but she
couldn't.
Their talons swept the sand away quickly
and soon Sonny could see the gleam of
white bones below them.
That's Queen Oasis.
Why does Flower want us to dig her up?
Before long, they had the front half of
the dragon's body uncovered.
She was huge too, even bigger than burn.
She must have been terrifying when she
was alive.
Flower scrambled into the hole they dug
and carefully climbed around the bones
until she was standing beside the
dragon's skull.
She tapped on the skull's jaws and looked
up at Sonny.
A sudden shiver went down Sunny's spine
as if she knew what was about to happen
although she couldn't have put it into
words.
She reached down and pried open the
queen's mouth.
Inside were 2 sacks, falling apart and
full of holes, but otherwise just like
the one the scavengers had given her in
the forest.
Behind her, she heard glory gasp.
She understood what this meant. 20 years
ago, the night Oasis died.
Flower must have hidden some of the
treasure in the dead dragon's mouth
before she ran off to hide in the dunes.
Maybe she thought she'd have a chance to
go back and get it, or maybe she didn't
want to be caught with it.
Sunny carefully lifted the sacks onto the
sand.
Emeralds and gold coins, and tiger's eye
bracelets spilled out through the holes.
She sliced open the sacks with one of her
claws.
And there it was at last.
The Eye of Onyx.
Chapter 28.
By all the moons, Thorn whispered.
Sunny slit her talons around the black
sphere and lifted it up.
As she did, she realized that it was set
on a chain of hammered gold links so it
could be worn as a necklace.
And then she took a closer look at the
setting.
In molded, beaten gold, on either side of
the onyx stone were 2 dragon wings.
They caught the firelight of the torches
and glowed red, gold, orange as she held
the necklace up.
Wings of fire.
Had somebody known?
Somewhere along the line and told the
night wings?
Was it just a coincidence?
In a way, the prophecy turned out to be
real after all.
Even if somebody thought they made it up
it's real to me, and to all the dragons
who need the war to be over.
But the prophecy didn't make this happen
no all powerful fate or guiding force in
the universe made this happen.
We made this happen.
Me and my friends, and all these dragons
here, and even flower.
She could feel power thrumming through
the sphere, like the obsidian mirror, or
the dream visitor, but stronger and
lighter somehow.
She wondered if animus touched objects
had different auras based on which dragon
had enchanted them.
No wonder no one has been able to take
the sand wing throne all these years
tsunami said.
It's like Queen Oasis was still hanging
on to it.
Glory agreed, nudging the bones with her
tail.
Flower was watching them nervously from
on top of the skull.
Sonny held up the eye of onyx, and made a
little bow toward the scavenger.
Thank you, she said.
This is what we needed.
Sunny, tsunami said.
With this, you could be queen.
You'd be a great queen.
It's true.
Glory said.
Nobody wants blister.
They'd follow you if you want the
throne.
They were right.
Sonny could sense that the magic in the
sphere was not confined to royalty.
Annie Sandwing who held the Eye of Onyx
could command the kingdom, even Sunny
with her harmless tale could be queen.
Another earthquake shook the ground under
her talons.
And I promise not to be jealous, tsunami
said.
Even though this is all highly unfair
because why aren't thrones just falling
into my lap is what I'd like to know?
Sonny imagined it, a palace, an army
treasure, and power.
She'd command the largest kingdom in
Pyria.
She could make the kingdom of sand a safe
peaceful place to live.
She could change the laws, and stop
dragons from fighting each other all the
time.
She looked up at the wings and claws and
teeth lining the walls.
Or could she?
Would she be strong enough to punish
anyone who opposed her?
Would she know how to defend her subjects
if another tribe attacked them?
Would she have to become a different kind
of dragon?
I don't want to be queen, Sonny
realized.
I don't want to fight for my throne, or
worry about the size of my territory, and
how much is in my treasury.
I want to be with my friends.
I want to teach dragonettes how to make
peace and how to find other solutions
instead of war.
I just want to be me.
Sunny.
But it still didn't have to be blister.
There was another choice.
She could feel the eyes of every dragon
on her.
Even blister and blaze had stopped
fighting, alerted by the silence that
something significant was happening.
Blisters stepped toward them with a
hiss.
Sonny looked right at her, then turned
and gave the Eye of Onyx to Thorn.
Something crackled between them as their
claws touched.
A tiny jolt of purple lightning, sparking
along the curve of the black stone.
This is the new sandwing queen, Sonny
said, hearing her voice echo across the
courtyard.
She is our choice.
She is the right choice.
Murmurs and gasps rippled through the
watching dragons.
Fourth moons and fireballs, Thorn said
awestruck.
Me?
Are you sure?
I'm extremely, definitely sure, Sunny
said.
Awesome.
Glory whispered.
And when Sonny looked over at her, the
rain wing queen winked.
Beside her, tsunami was nodding too.
Absolutely not, said Blister. advancing
on them.
That is mine.
I deserve it.
I took the rest of the sandwing
treasure.
I tricked mother into flying toward death
alone.
She gave the old queen's bones a scornful
look.
I used my brain to get out of facing burn
in a challenge duel by turning our fight
into a war.
She hissed at the Dragonettes, her usual
stillness broken into trembling anger.
I am the smartest dragon in Pyria.
I am the rightful sandwing queen.
She flicked her tail at Burn's body, then
at Blaze, who was crouched on the stones
bleeding from several small wounds.
Besides, it's in the prophecy, she
growled, of 3 queens who blister and
blaze and burn, 2 shall die.
And one shall learn, Sonny quoted back at
her.
If she bows to a fate that is stronger
and higher, she'll have the power of
wings of fire.
Marosir was talking about the night wings
hinting that the winning queen would have
to submit to the night wing tribe.
But this is much better.
This is your fate, to accept your new
queen.
She nodded at Thorn.
Blister coiled her venomous tail up
giving Sonny and Thorn a cold glare that
was unsettlingly like the dragon bite
vipers.
You don't seriously think that's going to
happen, do you?
So fight me, Thorn said.
I'm not afraid of you.
I can win this throne in battle, if
that's how you want to do it.
She tossed her head toward Blaze.
Or are you only willing to fight weak and
cowering dragons?
Blister's expression was hard to read.
Is she afraid to fight, Thorn?
Sonny wondered, or is she calculating her
next move, coming up with another evil
trick?
I don't have to fight you, Blister said
pacing closer and closer.
Her obsidian eyes glittered in the
moonlight.
You have no right to this throne.
The eye of onyx is mine.
Suddenly she lunged forward, and snatched
the smooth black sphere out of Thorn's
talons.
Orange sparks flew off the eye where
blisters claws touched it.
There was a hissing, crackling, spitting
sound that seemed to fill the whole
courtyard and expand outward, shock waves
spilling over the walls and the desert
beyond.
Blisters, talons started shaking.
It looked as if she was trying to drop
the eye, but she couldn't.
Lightning flickered across the black
stone and then out, darting along
blister's arms and up into her wings.
She jerked back, nearly lifting into the
air, and fell, still clutching the
sphere.
But she didn't scream.
She never made a sound.
Even as her tail smashed into the ground
and her head thrashed from side to side.
The lightning cracked again, faster
ripping through the sand wing's body.
And then blister, the dragon of their
nightmares, the sister whose evil schemes
had started the whole war exploded into a
pile of black dust.
Nobody moved.
Nobody spoke for a long, long moment.
And then Blaise said wonderingly, it's
me?
I'm the sister who survives?
Thorn stepped forward, and Gingerly
picked up the Eye of Onyx again.
It made a little humming sound, and
flickered with dark purple lines just
once, then went quiet.
What happened?
Starflight asked.
Beside him?
Fate speaker shook her head, for once too
shocked to speak.
I think we'd better do some research
about the exact enchantment on that thing
Glory said, giving the eye of onyx a wary
look.
I can see why Oasis kept it in her
treasury instead of wearing it, Thorn
said.
I'm a little traumatized right now.
But she lifted the necklace over her head
and let the chain settle around her neck
with the onyx stone and the dragon wings
resting in the center of her chest.
They bumped against the moonstone that
was already there, and Sonny thought of
her father.
We proved him wrong.
We really did it.
We ended the war.
She looked up at all the dragons who were
watching, from the walls, from the sky
and now spilling into the courtyard, sand
wings coming forward to greet their new
queen.
Blaze was the 1st one to reach her
crouching and bowing low to Queen Thorn
behind her, others followed suit.
This is really strange.
Thorn whispered to Sonny.
I hope you're planning to help me figure
this all out.
I will, Sonny said, but you'll be
brilliant.
She caught a glimpse of smolder.
Six Claws and Kibley among the bowing
dragons, and she saw Queen Glacier, Queen
Coral, and Queen Mohan watching from the
walls, looking relieved.
And I think there will be lots of other
dragons willing to help you figure it out
too.
She realized that Clay was sitting out
beside Starflight, rubbing his head, and
she hurried over to him with tsunami and
glory right behind her.
His bewildered, worried, wonderful face
alive, and all right, made her whole body
feel as though it was full of light.
Wow.
Everything hurts.
Clay said.
He blinked at them, and at the sky where
the sun was rising, and at the courtyard
full of dragons.
Oh, did I miss anything?
Epilogue.
One month later.
It was a perfect day for flying.
Trails of white clouds splashed across
the bright blue sky, as if they'd been
painted on in long, thin brushstrokes.
The wind whisked around them, fast and
breathless and playful, and the mountains
below looked like sharp green gemstones
in the warm sunlight.
Can't you imagine it?
Sonny said to her friends.
Wouldn't it be perfect?
They stood on one of the peaks of Jade
Mountain, with all of Pyria spread out
below them.
From here, on a day like today, Sunny
could see the white sands of the desert
far off to the west, and the dark green
of the rainforest to the east.
She could see the ocean glittering blue
in the south, and the jagged teeth of the
mountains stretching in a long line north
toward the sky kingdom.
She opened her wings and felt the wind
whoosh around her, nearly lifting her off
her talons.
I can see it, tsunami said.
We could use the caves as classrooms, but
have everyone outside as much as
possible.
Lots of sunshine.
Gloria agreed.
Mandatory sunshine.
And field trips, Clay suggested, limping
over the rocks to them.
So every dragonette can feel mud and sand
and the ocean, and snow, and also eat
mangoes.
He granded glory.
Mandatory mangoes.
And scrolls, right?
Starflight said.
Lots and lots of scrolls, all the scrolls
in Pyria.
We could have the biggest library in the
world here.
He paused, and even with a bandage over
his eyes, they could see his face fall.
Sunny twined her tail around his, knowing
he felt more comfortable when he was
touching another dragon.
Don't worry, Starflight.
Fate speaker said from his other side
nudging him gently.
We'll figure out a way to make scrolls
that blind dragons can read too.
And until then, I'll read you every
single scroll we find, I promise, I'm not
going anywhere.
He smiled shyly in her direction.
And Sonny felt another stab of guilt.
They'd talked about it.
Finally, once they were all safely back
in the rainforest.
Sonny had found him by himself for once
lying in the sun on one of the leaf
platforms, and she had curled up beside
him until he woke up.
I'm sorry, Starfight, she'd said, and
he'd known right away what she was
talking about.
I know, he'd answered, turning his head
away from her.
I just, I love you, but, like a brother.
She'd hesitated, then said instead, not
like fate speaker loves you.
He folded his wings over his face and
coughed, embarrassed.
It's all right if you love her too, Sonny
said.
You should.
She's, she cares about you.
And she's hilarious.
He hadn't said anything for a long time.
Finally, Sunny had said, I brought you
something.
His head lifted at the sound of the
rustling scroll.
Remember, Tales of the Night Wings?
want me to read it to you?
Ha, he'd said, actually smiling.
It'll sound a little different now that
we know none of it is true.
Sure, please do.
Here, now on the mountaintop.
Sonny thought, well, she hoped that
everything would be all right between
them.
He'd be a great teacher.
He didn't need his sight to do that, and
his flying was getting more confident
every day.
If she ever found someone she cared about
that way.
Well, then things might be awkward again
for a while.
But he had fate speaker.
They'd all be all right.
Do you think anyone will actually come?
Tsunami asked, pacing back from the
northern ridge.
I mean, a school for dragonettes from all
the tribes.
No one's ever done anything like that
before.
The queens might not want their subjects
to understand each other better.
What if we build a school and no one
comes?
They'll come, Sonny said confidently.
We're not the only dragons who want to
avoid any more wars.
This is the best way.
Dragonettes who grow up together will see
how alike they really are, no matter what
tribe they're from, then they won't judge
each other, and they'll be much less
likely to kill each other.
Like us, Clay said, grinning at her.
Unless they're all like tsunami.
Glory choked.
And then, getting to know each other will
make them more likely to want to kill
each other.
Tsunami smacked her over the head with
her tail.
Hey, Deathbringer shouted from overhead
where he was swooping about, surveying
the mountains.
No hitting the queen.
Yeah, Gloria said saucily to tsunami.
You're only a queen, tsunami said.
You might have their rain wings and night
wings wrapped around your tail, but
you're still not the boss of me.
And neither are you, Mr. Mooney Eyes, she
said to Deathbringer, as he landed beside
glory.
I bet I could knock you off this mountain
if I wanted to.
I think you're proving my point.
Glory mused, and then ducked a tsunami
tried to swat her again.
My brothers and sisters will come, Clay
said, I think, if they know I'm here.
Umber was telling me he hardly knows any
history, and his reading's not so great.
He'd love to learn more.
We should ask Webbs to be one of the
teachers, Sonny said.
Now that he's all recovered.
I mean, whatever else you guys think of
him, you have to admit he was a good
history teacher.
And he can't go home to the kingdom of
the sea.
Carl's never going to forgive him, even
if she lets all the other talons come
back one day.
I vote yes.
I'd be happy to finally get him out of my
rainforest, Glory said.
Much as he would clearly prefer to stay
in bed eating fruit forever.
She flicked her tail, turning orange
around her ears.
Kinkajoo and Tamron will want to come for
sure.
They need real teachers, not the scraps
of time I have for them.
I'll send some others.
As long as you promise they'll still get
their afternoon suntime.
Don't forget mighty claws.
Deathbringer suggested, and that little
night wing whose mother hid her egg in
the rainforest.
Moon Watcher, Glory said, nodding.
Poor little nervous dragonette.
And my sisters, tsunami said.
I bet I could get mother to send anemone
and Aucklet.
Although then we might have to let Queen
Kroll visit, like pretty much every day.
Wow, Sonny said, they all survived.
All these dragons we care about.
Isn't that amazing?
I mean, except Dune and Kestrel.
She looked down at her talons.
And Viper, fate speaker added, and my
father, Tsunami said quietly.
Sonny reached over and twined her tail
around tsunamis.
The other great thing about this school
idea?
Sonny said after a moment, is that this
way we can all stay together.
I mean, if you want to.
If you want to go back to your families
you can, but we'll always have a place
where we can be together.
I'd rather be with you all than in the
mud kingdom, Clay said readily, especially
if I can get Umber and the others here.
Same, tsunami said.
I'm afraid if I go home, mother will
somehow get a harness on me, or at least
want to watch me every moment of the day
and it'll be easier to learn aquatic here
than in the Deep Palace, where there
would be a 1000000 eyes on me all the
time, and hardly any chances to come up
to the surface to talk.
She shuddered.
Worse, no one could understand me.
How would I boss anyone around?
Sonny giggled, and tsunami shatter a
grin.
I have to stay in the rainforest, Glory
said, but it's not far.
I could visit all the time.
Starflight didn't say anything, but they
all knew he had no attachment to the
Nightwing village that was being built in
the rainforest.
His father, mastermind, was in prison, or
the closest thing the rain wings could
come up with anyway, until glory could
figure out how to try him for his
crimes.
And fierce teeth was still in the
Scorpion den.
Sonny reminded herself that she had to
talk to Thorn about her and Strongwings.
Once they figured out what they wanted to
do with them.
Oh, I know.
Peril, Clay said suddenly.
Peril could be one of the students.
She's got nowhere else to go, and we'd
know how to take care of her.
Sunny caught the look that went between
glory and tsunami.
They all knew they owed peril clay's life
but it was still hard to feel entirely
safe around her.
She really doesn't know where Scarlet
is?
Tsunami asked.
Isn't that a little weird that she
rescued Scarlet and then Scarlet just
vanished on her?
Peril's out looking for now?
Clay said.
She said Scarlet was appearing in her
dreams all the time before the rescue, but
she hasn't come back since.
Maybe we could use our dream visitor to
look for her, Sonny suggested, except
then she'll see us too, which makes me so
nervous.
I wish we'd found the obsidian mirror.
She'd gone back to the outskirts of the
Scorpion den to look for it, but as she'd
feared, every sand dune looked the same
and a day of digging had turned up
nothing.
Either someone else had found it, which
was also a worrying thought, or the
desert had swallowed it up.
It is disturbing, Deathbringer said
frowning up at the sky.
She's going to come for you sometime
especially you, he said to Glory.
Glory shrugged.
I'll let you worry about that, she said.
Oh, thanks, he said.
You know I will.
Fine by me. she said.
And despite their sarcastic words, the
look they gave each other made tsunami
roll her eyes at Sonny.
I wonder if they'll have dragonettes
together one day.
Will anyone complain that the queen of
the rain wings should be with another
rain wing instead?
A half rain wing, half night wing
dragonette?
What would that look like?
Everything in one dragon?
Or something different, like me?
Then I wouldn't be the only half tribe
dragon in the world.
Below them in the caves, Sonny knew her
mother was having an awkward reunion with
Stone Mover.
They both changed so much over the last 7
years.
There wasn't much in common between the
new queen of the sand wings, and the
partly stone enchanter hermit of Jade
Mountain.
Sonny had been with him for the 1st few
moments, but it had been way too
strange.
So she'd fled out here to her friends
instead.
Oh, she said, remembering something.
One of the things we have to teach
everyone is that the night wings don't
have any of those powers that they've
been claiming to have.
We can't let everyone still be afraid of
them, right?
Except me, fate speaker protested.
I totally so do have powers.
Fade speaker, Glory said sternly.
We talked about this.
All right, all right, your majesty, fate
speaker said, subsiding grumbly, but I
swear my visions really do feel real.
But that comment went away again without
falling on us.
Starflight pointed out.
Didn't that convince you?
Fate speaker had the grace to look a
little embarrassed.
Well, she said, it could still come
back.
Sunny started giggling, and after a
moment, fate speaker's dramatic face
cracked, and she joined in.
What about our prophecy?
Clay said, Won't it confuse everyone if
we tell them it wasn't real after all?
Sonny thought about that for a moment.
Maybe we could say the Night Wings lost
their powers along with their home.
So that was it, the last prophecy.
The last prophecy, Starflight echoed.
Three moons, yes, tsunami said.
That is what I vote for.
No more prophecies ever again.
I guess we just make it up from here
Sonny said, watching the wind tug at her
wings and tail.
Far below them, hawks soared over the
ridges and valleys.
Bad news, Sonny.
I'm pretty sure we've been making it up
this whole time.
Glory said.
Sonny laughed.
That's true.
And things turned out all right anyway.
Well, I know what I want my destiny to be
Clay said.
I wanted to be sleeping and being friends
with you guys forever.
Oh, wait, also feasting.
Lots of feasting.
That sounds great, Starflight said, best
destiny ever.
We can make that happen, Sonny said
smiling, and all of them spread their
wings and leaped into the wide open sky.
Wings of fire will continue.
The war is over.
The false prophecy has been fulfilled.
But the Dragonettes still have enemies.
A dark evil, buried for centuries, is
stirring.
And a young night wing may have had the
1st true prophecy in generations.
Something is coming to shake the earth.
Something is coming to scorch the
ground.
Jade Mountain will fall beneath thunder
and ice, unless the lost city of night
can be found.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you've enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, Book 5, The
Brightest Night, by 2ET Sutherland.
A Nightwing Guide to the Dragons of Pyria
read by 2 E T Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by Sebastian Zettin
executive producer Paul R.
Gagney.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of scholastic Inc.
Text copyright 2014 by 2ET Sutherland
production copyright 2016 by scholastic
Inc.
All rights reserved.
Hi, this is Tooey Sutherland.
A Nightwing Guide to the Dragons of
Pyrea.
Sand Wings.
Description.
Pale gold or white scales, the color of
desert sand, Poisonous barbed tail, Forked
black tongues.
Abilities, can survive a long time
without water, poison enemies with the
tips of their tails like scorpions.
Bury themselves for camouflage in the
desert sand.
Breathe fire.
Queen.
Since the death of Queen Oasis, the tribe
is split between 3 rivals for the
throne.
Sisters burn, blister, and blaze.
Alliances.
Burn fights alongside Skywings and
Mudwings.
Blister is allied with the sea wings, and
Blaze has the support of most sand wings
as well as an alliance with the ice
wings.
Mudwings.
Description, thick armored brown scales
sometimes with amber and gold
underscales.
Large flat heads with nostrils on top of
the snout.
Abilities, can breathe fire if warm
enough.
Hold their breath for up to an hour, blend
into large mud puddles, usually very
strong.
Queen, queen moorhen.
Alliances, currently allied with Burn and
the Sky Wings in the Great War.
Sky Wings.
Description, red gold or orange scales
enormous wings, abilities, powerful
fighters and flyers can breathe fire.
Queen, Queen Scarlet.
Alliances, currently allied with burn and
the mud wings in the Great War.
Sea Wings.
Description, blue or green or aquamarine
scales, webs between their claws, gills
on their necks, glow in the dark stripes
on their tails, snouts, underbellies.
Abilities, can breathe underwater, see in
the dark, create huge waves with one
splash of their powerful tails.
Excellent swimmers.
Queen, queen coral.
Alliances, currently allied with blister
in the Great War.
Ice Wings.
Description, silvery scales like the moon
or pale blue like ice.
Ridged claws to grip the ice, forked blue
tongues, tails narrow to a whip thin
end.
Abilities can withstand subzero
temperatures and bright light.
Exhale a deadly, freezing breath.
Queen, Queen Glacier, Alliances, currently
allied with Blaze and most of the sand
wings in the Great War.
Rain wings.
Description, scales constantly shift
colors, usually bright like birds of
paradise, prehensile tales.
Abilities, can camouflage their scales to
blend into their surroundings.
Use their prehensile tales for climbing
no known natural weapons.
Queen, Queen dazzling.
Alliances, not involved in the Great
War.
Night Wings.
Description.
Purplish black scales and scattered
silver scales on the underside of their
wings, like a night sky full of stars.
Forked black tongues.
Abilities, can breathe fire, disappear
into dark shadows, read minds, foretell
the future.
Queen, a closely guarded secret.
Alliances, too mysterious and powerful to
be part of the war.